Sagen wir, der Frühling kommt raus. Brauchen wir jetzt einen neuen Frühlingmacher der Nation? Ich würde mir gerne erklären, wer, lass mich raten, dieser Musiker, dieser Alte, den alle noch mal, ich hab seinen Namen vergessen.
Aber wie kann das sein, dass du den Namen nicht kennst? Das finde ich wirklich ganz erstaunlich. Ich habe den Test gemacht. Mir ist aufgefallen, bei Freunden, die so um die 19, 20, 21 sind, die wissen nicht unbedingt, wer er war. Alle anderen, also ich würde mal sagen 30 plus, weiß natürlich, wer ist dieser Politmacher der Nation. Das ist Toni Marschall.
Richtig. Ich wollte gerade sagen, lass mich noch ein bisschen zappeln und vielleicht fällt es mir ein. Und spätestens, wenn du es sagst, sage ich richtig, also richtig Toni Marschall.
Ja, fast so bekannt wie Roberto Blanco. Roberto Blanco dann noch ein klein wenig bekannter, auch weil er sicherlich medial dann noch präsenter war als Roberto, als Toni Marschall. Durch die Affären war dann Roberto Blanco ja auch in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten immer wieder präsent. Aber Toni Marschall ist einer gewesen, der eine Opernausbildung gemacht hat, aber doch um seine Grenzen wusste und dann Stimmungssänger wurde. Und mit Schöne Maid hast du heute für mich Zeit.
Ho, ja ho, ja ho.
Sag bitte ja, dann bin ich nur für dich da, oh bitte ho, ja ho, ja ho. Berühmt wurde. Und ich frage mich schon, was haben wir heute für Stimmungsmacher? Haben wir noch so Stimmungsmacher der Nation? Also es gibt natürlich diese ganzen Ballermann-Hits und auch da erleben wir so eine merkwürdige Politisierung ja neuerdings, wenn wir nur an Leila denken. Aber hier ging es ja um reine Munterkeit, um gute Laune. Ein bisschen Spaß muss sein, wie es dann bei Roberto Planko heißt. Und das ist diese fröhliche 70er Jahre Bundesrepublik, die es so nicht mehr gibt.
Ich glaube, das ist diese Marvelisierung. Man holt die Protagonisten raus und steckt so das Genre vor allem rein. Die Ballermann-Musik. Dann hat man aber jedes Jahr einen neuen, der halt einfach durchgeprügelt wird. Layla war natürlich auch so eine Marketingkampagne, die lief insgesamt.
Und es hatte eine hohe Partyaggressivität, während die alten Untermacher, Fröhlichmacher der Nation doch einfach nur heiter waren.
Ja, ich habe ja, wie gesagt, es ist ja Januars gerade rum und ich habe andere Réjeu verpasst. Und derzeit muss man ja schauen, er ist jetzt auch schon 76 oder so. Dass dann noch so, wie lange es noch geht, dass er jeden Januar in Frankfurt vorbeikommt.
Wir müssen jetzt unserem Publikum sagen, das ist nicht ironisch gemeint.
Nein, ganz so gar nicht.
Also das ist ja für mich dann eine Grenze, die ich nicht überschreiten würde hin zu andere Réjeu, weil er ja doch zum Teil anspruchsvolle Musik auf seine Art spielt. Und da habe ich dann, da verstehe ich keinen Spaß. Ich sage mir entweder Oper Frankfurt, Wagner, Meistersinger oder Toni Marshall, Schöne Maid.
Ja, ist ja natürlich alles zugestanden. Wir haben ja auch schon wieder zwei neue Operntermine, nachdem ich jetzt drei Wochen lang überlegte, wann ist eigentlich mein nächster Operntermin? Und ich hatte keinen, jetzt stehen zwei an, das ist gut. Ich war auch, du hast hier einen Getränkeuntersitzer mit Mike Joseph. Ich war, um ihn dann doch nochmal zu sehen, bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung, bei seiner sehr kleinen Wahlkampfveranstaltung, so im privaten, fast privaten Rahmen. Und da ging es auch um Kultur. Und da habe ich doch Gruseliges gehört, dass nämlich die Stadt doch nicht so ein richtig fetziges Konzept schon für die Oper hat und so. Man will ja den Willy-Brandt-Platz groß umbauen. Bisher sind ja Schauspiele und Oper nebeneinander. Und man überlegt immer noch, sich gegenüberzustellen, also den Eingebäudekarakter aufzuheben. Das heißt, weil es vor allem darum geht, das Schauspiel nochmal zu renovieren, muss auch die Oper da im selben Gebäude so ein bisschen in Mitleidenschaft dann auch nochmal ausweichen. Man ist sich noch nicht so ganz entschieden. Man saß nur dann auf ihrem kleinen Podium und meinte, wir sollten es jetzt bald mal entscheiden. Also es stehen auch für Frankfurt noch so ein paar Unwägbarkeiten im Raum, was die Operunterbringung und damit auch unser Vergnügen angeht.
Mike Joseph ist der SPD-Kandidat.
Mike Joseph ist ein sehr junger, gerade 40 gewordener SPD-Kandidat, der vor 21 Jahren mit seiner Familie aus Syrien hierher kam und damit so ziemlich Frankfurt abbildet, während die CDU Kai Wegener quasi nochmal gedoppelt hat und ihn als Uwe Becker hier in Frankfurt antreten lässt.
Aber das mit diesen aufwändigen Renovierungen ist so eine Sache. In Köln konnte man das ja erleben.
Ja, so will ich nicht.
Da hat man dann zehn Jahre oder noch länger keine Oper mehr. Beziehungsweise, sie ist in einer Nebenspielstätte, bei der man aber doch sehr, sehr arge Abstriche machen muss. Und ich finde das furchtbar, dass man das nicht anders geregelt bekommt. Andererseits werden hier riesen Gebäudekomplexen 0, 0% hochgezogen. Also die Stadt verändert sich.
Ja, es sieht immer aus wie 0, 0%, aber es hat auch alles 20 Jahre Planung gekostet und so weiter. Und es sind Zeiten finanziert worden und gedacht worden, als es noch kein Corona, keinen Krieg und nichts gab.
Und jetzt hat man ja auch, wenn man jetzt sogar Neubau anstrebt, dann könnte man den ja schon realisieren und lässt die wirklich nur rüberziehen.
Genau.
Und das wird aber häufig nicht gemacht. Sondern man schließt dann erst mal und dann fängt man an. Und dann wird alles doch wieder teurer. Und irgendwelche Politiker kommen ja dann immer, die dann sagen, da könnte man mal sparen und brauchen wir eigentlich die Oper. Wir haben das ja immer wieder in den Städten und immer mit diesen Ausweispielstädten. Das ist einfach nicht tragbar. Aber es wird wahrscheinlich dann auch etwas schlimmer werden, wie alles.
Ja, mal sehen. Ich war kurz mit Mike Josef Bilatt, wie man heute so schön sagt, im direkten Gespräch. Und die Oper kostet 1, 2 Milliarden auf 15 Jahre die Strecke, dieses ganze Projekt, was sie planen. Und das Einzugsgebiet ist riesig. Die Leute kommen nicht nach außen Westend rübergewackelt, sondern die Oper ist weltweit bekannt. Und trotzdem ist die Stadt Frankfurt die einzige, die zahlt. Das Land Hessen hält sich bei der Opernfinanzierung ganz zurück. Und da hat Mike Joseph und auch das derzeitige Kulturdezern noch so ein paar Versuche am Laufen, dass man das mal hier so ein bisschen... Es gibt Besucherzählung und so weiter. Man schaut sich genau an, wo die Leute herkommen und versucht dann noch ein bisschen Gelder zu akquirieren. Aber es ist grotesk. Ich habe auch noch mal kurz angemerkt, dass ich es schon cool finde, auf der einen Seite in meinem Schwimmverein irgendwie zu sein und dann da so Übungsleiter-Abrechnungsmodelle aufzuziehen. Und dann schiebt man so jeden Euro hin und her und dann fährt man am selben Abend abends in die Oper, bezahlt 100 Euro für sein Ticket und die Stadt legt nochmal 200 drauf. Und das findet er auch amüsant, dass es da halt so große Kluften gibt zwischen was macht man vormittags, was macht man so abends. Und naja, Opernfinanzierung wird jedenfalls noch heikel in Frankfurt.
Ja, ich hoffe nicht, dass sie irgendwelche Förderungen wegnehmen.
Man weiß, also Mike Joseph hat auch nochmal betont, sechs Jahre lang in Folge Oper des Jahres und so weiter, Opernhaus des Jahres. Man weiß schon, worum was es geht, so insgesamt und versucht jetzt nochmal alle zu involvieren, dass dann vielleicht auch das CDU-regierte Land der weiterhin SPD-regierten Stadt und so, das sind ja auch immer noch solche Schieflagen.
Das Problem ist ja, dass sehr viele Politiker sehr kulturlos sind und selten in Theatern anzutreffen sind und deshalb dann auch entsprechende Entscheidungen gefällt werden.
Oper ist jetzt, ich will es nochmal wiederholen, du hast es ja sehr gut geschrieben in der e-Mail oder so, wir hatten eine Zuschrift mit einer Frage, pipapo, und dann hast du geschrieben, nein, die Oper ist nicht Hochkultur, die Oper ist Subkultur. Und das sollten wir immer wieder betonen. In die Oper zu gehen, heißt nicht, sich plötzlich an die Schönen und Reichen der Stadt anzuhängen, um etwas außergewöhnlich Supercool und Teures zu sehen. Ja, es ist teuer, aber es ist am Ende Subkultur. Wir sehen da ganz spezielle Milieus, nicht unbedingt die Superreichen, die hängen auf dem Golfplatz rum oder gehen irgendwo Skifahren.
Sehr, sehr randend, da werden die großen Experimente gemacht. Das ist nicht mehr das, womit Reiche sich schmücken. Wir gehen heute Abend in die Oper, sondern wir fliegen irgendwo hin und kaufen in Mailand Schuhe, das ist vielleicht das, womit man noch angeben kann. Frankfurt ist sehr teuer, es ist die beste Oper des Landes, aber man kann auch sehr viel günstiger in die Oper gehen. Ich war beispielsweise gerade in Mainz in der Oper. Das ist natürlich dann nur ein Bruchteil von dem. Da haben dann auch Azubis-Studenten ganz besondere Ermäßigungen. Zum Teil ist es so, dass Studenten in manchen Städten gratis in die Oper gehen können. So drei Tage vorher können sich dann um Karten auf allen Plätzen bemühen. Es gibt Kultur-Jugend-Abos zum Beispiel in Leipzig. Also das gibt es schon alles. Ich würde mir auch wünschen, wenn generell die Preise sinken würden. Und die haben jetzt auch zugenommen, weil die Nachfrage durch Corona geschwächt ist. Das finde ich sehr schade. Aber das ist nicht eine Elite-Veranstaltung, wo man die Schönen und Reichen der Stadt treffen kann. Die sind woanders. Es mag sein, dass da auch mal irgendjemand nur hingeht, um einen Anzug oder Abendkleid zu präsentieren. Aber das ist eigentlich nicht das, was man dort sieht. Man hat ein sehr fachkundiges Publikum dort.
Wenn man das als junger Mensch einfordert, dass der Opa gewelligst billiger zu sein hat, dann sind die Opernhäuser sofort dabei. Wenn man das auf Twitter oder Instagram stories dazu macht, dann kriegt man schon die Likes der entsprechenden Häuser.
Ich habe aber auch schon mit Dramaturgen von Häusern gesprochen, die solche Sachen anbieten. Dann habe ich gefragt, wie wird das frequentiert? Dann sagten die, pro Abend kommen so fünf junge Leute. Da ist also auch noch Luft nach oben.
Also geht mal mehr in die Oper, Leute.
Wir bleiben aber bei den frustrierenden Themen.
Auf jeden Fall. Wir verschieben jegliche Diskurse über Diskurse in den Salon. Denn das ist unser Safe Space. Heute also kaum ein Wort zu Habermas, nichts zu Wagenknecht, Alexander Kluge. Ich habe es auch noch gar nicht gelesen, sage ich ehrlich.
Wir können das ja schon mal ankündigen, was wir vorhaben. Also wir wollen im Salon über zwei Texte sprechen. Einmal hat die Zeit ein Interview geführt mit Alexander Kluge. Dieses ist eingekesselt von anderen Beiträgen, die sagen jetzt aber nochmal richtig ran mit schweren Waffen.
Ja, das müssen wir kurz. Also unter diesem Text in der gedruckten Version steht Eva Elous. Mit der Überschrift Ich will den totalen Sieg.
Aber sie gesteht dann auch, wenn man den Text weiter liest, ein So ganz wird es wahrscheinlich nicht kommen.
Ja, und sie spricht auch kein Deutsch und weiß auch nicht, was die Zeit da genau in der Überschrift gedruckt hat und so weiter und so fort. Das muss man dann immer dazusagen bei so was.
Sie ist doch sehr eigenartige Vergleicher. Sie versucht die Situation in Israel nochmal mit der Ukraine zu vergleichen. Das ist schon sehr eigenwillig.
Neben Esther Perel, also das sind die beiden klügsten Menschen, die zum Thema Liebe, Beziehung und so weiter topmodern reden und sehr fleißig publizieren. Jeder auf ihre eigene Art. Eva Elous mehr so in den Büchern und die Perel mehr so in YouTube Videos oder so. Ich fand es ein bisschen überraschend, sie zum Thema Ukrainekrieg und Krieg allgemein zu lesen. Und dann noch mit dieser Überschrift, es hat auch so einen gewissen Fail-Charakter, wenn man das einfach so wahrnimmt, wie die Zeit das da aufgemacht hat. Aber wie gesagt, ich hat es nur gesehen, weil es auf derselben Seite ist mit Alexander Kluge.
Wir finden uns aber das Alexander Kluge-Interview heraus, dass dann so ein einsamer Stern in dieser gesamten Ausgabe der Zeit war. Denn es gab unglaublich viele Texte, die nochmal in diese eine Richtung gegangen sind und nochmal eine Einordnung, warum Habermas auf jeden Fall falsch liegt. Und dann sprechen wir über den neuen Habermas-Essay, in der Süddeutschen Zeitung erschienen. Und wir wollen nicht so viel über Diskurse über Diskurse sprechen. Aber ich will ein bisschen was noch aufgreifen, weil es mich so sehr geärgert hat. Ich würde es gerne jetzt loswerden, damit man im Sanon freier über den wirklichen Inhalt sprechen kann. Und zwar schreibt Franziska Davies, das ist diese Historikerin mit Ost-Schwerpunkt, die, glaube ich, eine Professur noch jetzt haben will und das Momentum nutzen möchte. Sie schreibt bei Twitter, das Problem ist nicht der dämliche Text von Haber Maas. Das Problem ist die süddeutsche Zeitung, die den Schnodder abdruckt. Also auf diesem Niveau befinden wir uns dann hier. Wir sehen hier von Carlo Massalla Tweets wie Lifegoal, finde jemanden, der dich so sehr liebt, respektiert und achtet, wie Teile der deutschen Elite, den russischen Aggressor. Also da sind wir jetzt angekommen. Wir finden einen anderen Historiker, glaube ich, Jan-Klas Behrens bei Twitter, der schreibt, Jürgen Haber Maas ist übrigens ein Wiederholungstäter. Auch im Historikerstreit hat er über den Stalinismus geschrieben, ohne ihn zu kennen oder zu verstehen. In dieser Tradition steht auch seine letzte Intervention. Und das ist ganz interessant. Ich muss das kurz ausführen, weil ich das wirklich sehr interessant finde. Wir haben mit Jürgen Haber Maas jemand, der damals eine ganz wichtige Rolle in diesem Historikerstreit spielte. Nämlich, er war der Antipode von Ernst Nollte. Ernst Nollte wollte Auschwitz relativieren. Er wollte sagen, na ja, es gab, es war im Prinzip auch nur die Reaktion der Deutschen auf die Verbrechen. Und wir müssen das auch mal miteinander vergleichen können. Und dann wird man sehen, es hat nicht diese Singularität. Habermas ist der und viele andere. Und diese Betrachtungsweise hat sich ja dann auch durchgesetzt. Habermas war derjenige, der gesagt hat, nein, es gibt eine Singularität der Joie. Und an dieser müssen wir auch festhalten. Nun, gibt es hier was interessantes? Hier sagt man aber, der Habermas hat damals schon ganz komisch gelegen. Ich hab mich ein bisschen gewundert über den Tweet. Dann erinnerte ich mich an den Tweet einer Person, den ich nicht wieder gefunden habe, die auch eine wichtige Stimme jetzt ist, was Thema Waffenlieferungen alles anbelangt. Ich will sie nicht nennen, weil ich den Tweet nur aus dem Kopf so zitieren kann. Er ist drei Jahre alt etwa. Da war der Tweet in etwa so. Wir haben so sehr uns die Vergleiche verboten, dass uns gar nicht mehr auffällt, dass wir doch Ausschwitz miteinander vergleichen können. Und das ist eine ganz schlimme Debatte, die aber jetzt von anderen geführt wird. Bei Ernst Noldt hatten wir einfach es mit einem rechten Historiker zu tun, der relativieren wollte. Wir finden das zum Beispiel auch bei Feinden Israels, die dann sagen, ja, was die Israelis machen, das ist ja dasselbe wie damals oder so. Also man versucht eigentlich immer von rechter Seite heraus zu relativieren. Jetzt erleben wir aber, wie so von einer anderen Seite, von so einer moralistischen Seite versucht wird, eigentlich die Singularität von Auschwitz zu untergraben. Und man fragt sich, warum? Und die Antwort fand ich dann bei Joschka Fischer. Und zwar haben wir doch etwas ganz Interessantes erlebt damals bei dieser Rechtfertigung für den Kriegseinsatz im Kosovo 1999. Fischer hielt diese Rede auf dem Parteitrag und betont da die Singularität von Auschwitz und sagt aber dann doch etwas, was eigentlich sagt, nun ja, aber ich verhindere jetzt, wenn ich für diesen Einsatz bin, ein zweites Auschwitz. Ich will, weil ich das nicht einfach nur aus dem Gedächtnis zitieren will, ich würde gerne mal einmal diesen Clip spielen. Ich habe den vorbereitet und ich halte das für eine ganz, ganz falsche Entwicklung, die das jetzt nimmt. Wir hören jetzt Joschka Fischer 1999 beim Parteitrag.
Als es damals zu diesem furchtbaren mörderischen Anschlag auf eine ausländische Familie, auf eine türkische Familie kam, die rassistischen Übergriffe, der Neonazismus, die Skinheads, natürlich steckt da bei mir immer die Erinnerung auch an unsere Geschichte und spielt da eine Rolle. Und ich frage mich, wenn wir innenpolitisch dieses Argument immer verwandt haben, gemeinsam verwandt haben, warum verwenden wir es dann nicht, wenn Vertreibung, ethnische Kriegsführung in Europa wieder Einzug halten und eine blutige Ernte mittlerweile zu verzeichnen ist?
Was hier rhetorisch gemacht wird, ist erstmal, dass er sagt, wir haben Rassismus, Antisemitismus in unserem Lande und sagen da nie wieder. Und dann geht er vom Inland aufs Ausland. Was ist, wenn das dort woanders geschieht, müssten wir dann nicht auch intervenieren? Und dann kommt folgende Conclusio.
Ist das moralische Hochrüstung, ist das Overkill. Auschwitz ist unvergleichbar. Aber in mir, ich stehe auf zwei Grundsätzen. Nie wieder Krieg, nie wieder Auschwitz, nie wieder Völkermord, nie wieder Faschismus. Beides gehört bei mir zusammen, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde. Und deswegen bin ich in die grüne Partei gegangen.
Was also hier doch geschieht, ist, dass wir ja ohnehin ein bisschen skeptisch sein sollen bei Sätzen mit Aber. Dann gilt oft das, was davor gesagt wurde, nicht mehr so ganz. Dass man also eigentlich die Unvergleichbarkeit betont, aber sagt, weil nie mehr Auschwitz, müssen wir auch intervenieren. Und das kann sehr leicht natürlich dann eine Rhetorik werden, gegen die man kaum noch Argumente vorbringen kann. Das sind eigentlich Totschark-Argumente, weil man dann sagt, wir verhindern jetzt gerade wieder irgendwo Auschwitz und rechtfertigen damit alles, was wir interventionistisch tun. Und das ist etwas, was wir jetzt gerade im Diskurs auch erleben, was wir damals beim Kosovo hatten, was wir im Übrigen auch dann nicht von der Grünen Partei, sondern von anderen Stimmen in Deutschland, aber auch im Ausland hatten, im Bezug auf Irak. Dass man sagte, naja, da gibt es die Massenvernichtungswaffen angeblich. Und damit müssen wir jetzt auch einen Völkermord verhindern.
Ja, also in dieser Auschwitz, wenn man es einmal eine Stufe jetzt generalisiert, der Holocaust an sich, ist ja auch der ganz wichtige Satz, es ist geschehen, also es ist geschehen, es kann wieder geschehen. Und unter dieser Maxime Politik zu machen, finde ich ja gar nicht verkehrt. Es ist ja auch Heiko Maas ins Außenministerium gegangen, hat sich vorgestellt, was ist ihr Antrieb, Politiker zu sein. Und dann ja der Geschichtsunterricht, insbesondere zweiter Weltkrieg und alles, was dazu führte. In deren Sicht ist das wirklich schwierig zu diskutieren. Auf der einen Seite Puttler und so. Diese Gleichsetzung jetzt überall um Zwitter zu haben.
Wenn ich diese Gleichsetzung mache und auch nichts anderes heranziehen, also man könnte jetzt auch sagen, Putin ist wie Brülpott. Das ist genauso doof, das dabei zu ziehen, wie zu sagen, Putin ist wie Hitler. Aber wenn ich diese Argumentation mache, dann sage ich, und deshalb muss ich verhindern, dass es ein zweites Ausschwitz gibt. Und dann ist das auch gerechtfertigt. Ich halte das für keine, sagen wir so, für keine redliche Argumentation. Man könnte anders argumentieren, warum man zum Beispiel für Waffenlieferungen ist. Und das ist ja schon ein kleiner Spoiler, Habermas ist ja nicht grundsätzlich gegen Waffenlieferungen oder so. Aber ich halte das für eine sehr unredliche Diskussion, wenn man einfach nur so tut, als würde man mit jeder Intervention, die man so machen will, gar keinen anderen Interesse hat, außer jetzt gerade Auschwitz zu verhindern.
Ja, also dass der Historikerstreit da so reinrutschte, weil kluge, in Anführungszeichen kluge Leute, auf Twitter feststellen, Habermas, der Name, sag mir doch irgendwas, ach ja, da hat er damals auch schon was geschrieben, so ungefähr, auf der Ebene. Würde ich sagen, ja, das ist dann sehr verpeilt.
Nur wenn man das Erbe jetzt einfach hat achterlegt und sagt, ja, Habermas hat auch da schon nicht erkannt, wo die eigentlichen Verbrechen sind, und jetzt erkennt er es ja wieder nicht, dann sagt man eigentlich am Ende, hatte ja dann Ernst Neute aufs falschen Gründen doch recht. Und das finde ich ganz fatal, wenn man in diese Argumentation kommt.
Ich will mal jetzt, wo wir ein Clip hier gespielt haben, an einem anderen Spiel, von Richard David Precht, der im Podcast mit Lanz Habermas verteidigt. Und man könnte nämlich jetzt unendlich viel zu sagen zum Thema, es wäre gerechtfertigt, den Holocaust in kriegerischen, also in politischen Beobachtungen, kriegerischer Auseinandersetzungen immer mitlaufen zu lassen. Aber nicht um dann einen Aber-Satz zu machen, sondern um immer wieder anzufügen oder anzumerken, wir wissen doch, wie weit man es treiben kann, ab wann intervenieren wir denn eigentlich und womit. Und dann hätte man so eine Diskussion offen, wo man sich dann fragt, Pristina und so weiter, ist das jetzt ein Grund einzugreifen, auch wenn es entsprechende Vetos auf UN-Ebene gibt, dass es dann nicht völkerrechtlich fundiert ist mit einer UN-Resolution und man trotzdem handelt. Wie damals, was ja für die Grünen so kompliziert war, in die Regierung gewählt zu werden, uns alle erst einmal überhaupt und dann auch noch den ersten Bundeswehreinsatz im Ausland zu organisieren. Und diese Diskussion, also es ist so eine der ersten Twitter-Diskussionen, wo ich sage, diskutiert das doch. Also da sage ich jetzt gar nicht zu. Das ist einfach, okay, mach das. Ich nehme es nicht mal interessiert zur Kenntnis, sondern ich überspringe es einfach nur noch komplett, was auch die komplette Podcastlandschaft betrifft. Also es ist ja nicht mehr hörbar, was so stattfindet. Weil es aber stattfindet, reagiert Richard David Precht, darauf und ich finde, er macht so diesen, wir haben das ja auch schon festgestellt, er schreibt auf der einen Seite dieses Buch mit Wälzer über die Medienlandschaft, sitzt dann aber in der Land-Sendung mit Wälzer und ignoriert seinen eigenen Text, sondern begibt sich einfach auf die Ebene von Robin Alexander und Melanie Amann und wenn die halt so emotional und irgendwie verquerder einsteigen, machen die das halt auch. Und wir lesen dann das Buch und denken, wieso haben die nicht die Argumente aus dem Buch einfach mal gebracht? Und so ist das hier auch. Richard David Precht lässt so alles, was ihn eigentlich ausmacht und seine Belesenheit, sein eigenes Schreiben, einfach mal links liegen. Und er regiert einfach mal emotional auf das, was er so vorfindet, an Diskurs gerade, nämlich, dass sich alle über Habermass aufregen. Und er regt sich halt über diejenigen auf, die sich über Habermass aufregen.
Dass dieser Text schon wieder, wie der erste Text, den er schon mal geschrieben hat, sei es der zweite Text zum Thema, mit einer Vehemenz angegriffen wurde. Und jetzt, was mich wirklich auf die Palme bringt, sind, dass irgendwelche hergelaufenen Journalisten sich ein Urteil über den geistigen Zustand und über den moralischen Zuschnitt von Jürgen Habermas erlauben. Dass der auf einmal da als alter Trottel mit falscher Moral und was ihm alles unterstellt wird, was er nicht sieht und so weiter.
Sag's ruhig, alter weißer Mann.
Ja, aber zum Teil noch sehr, sehr viel übler. Also wirklich, sage ich dem Motto, der Olle hat doch nicht mehr alle Latten am Zaun. Ich meine, was ist das für ein respektloser Umgang? Habermas weiß genau, dass es nicht so ist, dass alle, die das lesen, eins zu eins seine Meinung teilen. Sie sollen ja einfach nur darüber nachdenken. Und sie müssen es auch noch nicht mal lesen. Man muss es auch nicht teilen. Und Habermas ist der Letzte, der ein Problem hätte mit jemandem, der anderer Meinung ist als er. Er ist ja sozusagen der Vertreter des Diskursiven. Er will ja sozusagen, dass wir uns vielfältig darüber austauschen. Und so jemanden mit dicken Kanonenkugeln abzutun und so weiter, nur weil man die Meinung nicht teilt, das steht unserer medialen Öffentlichkeit extrem schlecht zu Gesicht. So geht man damit nicht um.
Ja, finde ich auch. Aber damit ist halt auch alles gesagt. Dass Lanz hier immer noch versucht, ins Gespräch rein zu grätschen, finde ich so ein bisschen blöd.
Ja, Lanz versucht ja auch noch mit Calo Massalla und alles Mögliche oder Melnik hat ja dann auch gesagt, dass Habermas die deutsche Philosophie beschädigt, Kant und Hegel würden sich im Grabe umdrehen oder so. Als hätte Melnik Kant oder Hegel gelegen. Das ist ja so wirklich absurd. Und ich finde aber, dass wir so eine Polarisierung dort erleben, die ich so nicht kenne. Also das ist schon eine neue Stufe. Dass Autoren sehr seriös, sehr geschätzt, auch von einem großen linksliberalen Spektrum, denn Habermas ist ja am Ende auch ein Linksliberaler, dann jetzt völlig frei drehen, wenn dort ein Text erscheint, der ihnen nicht so ganz recht ist. Und wir zugleich einen Diskurs haben, der auch nicht mehr kritisch hinterfragt wird von den Linksliberalen. Also ich habe mich noch mal erinnert, wie war das eigentlich damals Deutschland ein Sommermärchen, die WM in Deutschland? Das war 2006. Und da weißt du noch um diese Diskussion.
Hast du da auch Fußball geguckt?
Nein, und ich hatte auch kein Fähnchen an meinem Auto. Und ich fand das auch damals furchtbar. Und habe auch damit sehr gefremdelt, auch wenn mir das als unverkrampfter Patriotismus verkauft wurde. Ich bin aber nicht durch die Lande gezogen und habe gesagt, das sind wohl alles Rechtsextreme. Sondern ich habe gesagt, gut, das ist ein bisschen doof. Aber es war mir unheimlich, dass man sich in dieser Weise so positiv auf Deutschland beziehen will. Die Welt zu Gast bei Freunden. Man wollte ein schönes Gesicht von Deutschland nun einmal im Aushand präsentieren. Und dann lese ich aber jetzt überall Kommentare. Es gab zum Beispiel bei BR einen, es gab beim Spiegel einen, warum es ein Fehler war, damals die Wehrpflicht nicht anzutreten. Heute würde ich zur Bundeswehr gehen. Dann haben wir eine, wir haben das ja damals schon im März und vor allem im April, in der April-Folge, im vergangenen Jahr alles rezipiert, so ein, ja man muss sich auch mal opfern für irgendetwas, für höhere Prinzipien, für das Land, für was auch immer. Und das wird dann so auf das Deutschsein übertragen. Und dann ist auch jemand wie Carlo Massalla, der dann in einem Interview spricht von Premiumdeutschen, also von, wie er es dann nennt, also von Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund, die oft gar nicht als richtige Deutsche noch angesehen werden, von den sogenannten Bio-Deutschen, also die dann als, wie er das nennt, die Alis angesehen werden, die aber dann zur Bundeswehr gehen und im Zweifel bereit sind, für das Land zu sterben. Und dann hat er auch das nochmal auf Twitter erklärt, das sind für ihn die Premiumdeutschen, die, obwohl sie von der Gesellschaft nicht genügend Respekt bekommen, dann aber, er sagt es dann, wer von Teilen der Gesellschaft als Deutscher zweiter Klasse betrachtet und behandelt wird und dennoch bereit ist, für dieses Land gegebenenfalls ein Leben zu geben, ist für mich ein Premiumdeutscher. Und da muss ich sagen, das ist einfach ein bisschen doof, wenn man das dann tatsächlich machen will. Und ich finde es auch falsch, wenn wir diese Opferkultur haben. Was kann denn ein Staat von einem Bürger erwarten? Dass man ein guter Bürger ist. Ich würde sagen, die Steuernzahlen sich weitgehend an die Gesetze halten. Ich gehe auch schon mal nachts, wenn jemand hinguckt, über eine rote Ampel, sei es drum. Und sonst kann man dann vielleicht noch darüber reden, ob ein gesellschaftliches Engagement vonnöten ist, um tatsächlich sich als guter Bürger zu erweisen. Aber damit ist für mich, der die Pflicht erfüllt, die Pflicht eines deutschen und auch sonst eines Staatsbürgers, liegt nicht darin, bereit sein, sich für das Land zu opfern. Ich opfere mich nicht für einen Nationalstaat. Und ich finde es ganz verrückt, dass wir inzwischen wieder das Sterben fürs Vaterland als sinnvoll erachten. Man kann vielleicht das eine oder andere verstehen, warum Ukrainer kämpfen oder nicht. Aber was jetzt gerade stattfindet, ist ja, dass wir unseren Patriotismus, mit dem wir zurecht fremdeln, und dem wir dann höchstens als so ein Fähnchen Patriotismus 2006 feiern können, dass wir den jetzt an andere delegieren, überstülpen und sagen, ach, das ist ja eigentlich das, was ich jetzt auch haben möchte. Auch mal so ein Heroismus haben.
Ich würde das gerne mal noch auf die Spitze treiben. Denn man hört ja raus, du bist gegen eine Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht oder auch nur die Diskussion darum.
Hast du richtig erkannt.
Ich würde gerne noch den Schritt weitergehen und sagen, ich würde es auch verbieten, dass Deutsche jetzt überhaupt in die Ukraine einreisen dürfen. So wie es den ukrainischen Männern gerade verboten ist, auszureißen, würde ich ein Einreiseverbot aussprechen. Das natürlich aufgehoben werden kann durch besondere Erklärungen oder so. Man hat da was zu tun, wie auch immer. Aber es ist jetzt, finde ich, zu rechtfertigen, warum man in die Ukraine einreist. Und die Schweiz, die wir ja als super neutrales Land, weshalb da auch recht viele Institutionen so ein bisschen die Mediatorrolle einnehmen, die dann halt von der Schweiz aus und so weiter ihre Pendeldiplomatie machen, verbietet ihren Staatsbürgern auch als einziges Land in Europa. Man darf nicht als Schweizer Söldner Tätigkeiten in der Ukraine annehmen. Und ich würde das als Prinzip mal festschreiben. Also während wir hier alle so eine Diskussion haben, sollten wir den wenigen Nachwuchs, den wir haben, jetzt nochmal schnell vor die Kanonen stellen, der russischen Kanonen. Da würde ich sagen, wir brauchen einen Diskurs, dass wir jetzt, wir kommen nachher ausführlich drauf bei der im Besprechen, da müssen wir eine Sicherheitskonferenz, dass wir jetzt mal abstrahieren von Schuldfragen, von überhaupt nur Beteiligungsfragen, von Protagonistenfragen, von historischen Fragen, von Verlaufsfragen, von politischen Fragen und grundsätzlich sagen, Krieg ist verboten. Und auf der Ebene, wo wir es verbieten können, machen wir es auch.
Das heißt, das beginnt mit dem Vorschlag, den du gerade gemacht hast.
Wäre es möglich, heute Soldat zu sein in der Ukraine oder Seldner, würde ich sagen, nö, sollte verboten werden. Sollten wir in Deutschland ein Gesetz machen, kein Deutschem, ist es erlaubt, an diesem Ukrainekrieg teilzunehmen. Und das ist eigentlich die Diskussion, die wir führen sollten.
Und nicht die Diskussion über Premium-Leute. Es sei, Deutsch sei überhaupt ein Ausweis von einem besonderen Menschsein. Das ist ja genau diesen Nationalismus, den wir eigentlich loswerden wollten. Und ich dachte auch, wir hatten ihn an Akter gelegt. Gut, dann blühte das da 2006 ein bisschen. Aber es war dann auch nicht viel anders als eine Party mit Jürgen Dreves und Micky Krause. Da dachte ich, okay, wird schon so stimmlich werden. Und jetzt aber sieht man, das ist nicht mehr der Partie-Patriotismus, der sich an Würstchenbuden abspielt, sondern jetzt kommt er so moralisch scheinbar geläutert daher, endlich mal historisch auf der richtigen Seite stehen. Und damit wird aber eigentlich nur der alte Patriotismus heraufbeschworen, der notwendig bedeutet dann, dass man auch bereit ist, sich für sein Land zu opfern, für das Land zu sterben. Und man muss doch mal erkennen, der Schlachthof der Geschichte besteht aus Leichen wie aus Lügen. Und ich würde auch mal jemanden wie Wolf Biermann zu seinen eigenen Texten befragen, weil Wolf Biermann ja jetzt auch unglaublich für diesen Krieg trommelt. Und er müsste doch eigentlich auch sich mal fragen, was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn Männer nicht ausreißen können aus der Ukraine, aus Russland. Er hat selbst die Antwort gegeben. Und zwar 1965 erinnerte mich da doch mal ein Gedicht gelesen zu haben. Ich habe es dann gefunden. 1965 schrieb Wolf Biermann ein kurzes Gedicht. Das geht so. Ich kann nur lieben, was ich die Freiheit habe, auch zu verlassen. Dieses Land, diese Stadt, diese Frau, dieses Leben. Eben darum lieben ja wenige ein Land, manche eine Stadt, viele eine Frau, aber alle das Leben.
Sehr gut, sehr klug. Und bei 65 war halt auch noch eine andere Zeit. Jetzt hast du gerade diese schöne Wortkombination Leichen und Lügen genannt und über die Leichen haben wir jetzt gesprochen. Also noch ist man Soldat, aber perspektivisch damit eine Leiche. Und jetzt tingeln wir ja auch um diesen Diskurs rum und haben ihn schon so ein bisschen abgeschoben, weil wir ja dann wirklich lesen wollen, was Kluge und Haber mal sagen. Aber die Lüge ist ja auch ohrinteressant. Dieser Spruch, das erste, was im Krieg stirbt, ist die Wahrheit. Geht ja immer für alle Kriege, die man so kennt, außer für den aktuellen jetzt gerade.
Genau, ist immer alles anders.
Also jetzt wissen wir wirklich alle genau Bescheid, was Sache ist. Die Wahrheit steht überall geschrieben. Wir müssen nur noch über sie diskutieren. Aber das Fundament ist sozusagen klar. Und jetzt gab es bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, der wir uns ja nähern, einen Wortbeitrag aus ukrainischer Richtung, der so ein bisschen fragwürdig war. Ich habe oder Matthias hat auf Twitter so eine sehr amüsante, kurzes Video-Ding von Tagesschau 24, wo so randommäßig irgendwie in der 11.05 Version der Tagesschau der Korrespondent gefragt wurde, ob es denn schon eine Reaktion auf die ukrainische Forderung nach Phosphor-Waffen, Phosphor-Brandwaffen, dieses Wort wurde verwendet. Es wirkt schon skurril, in so einer Tagesschau-Sendung, die so auf Hochglanz und leichte Verständlichkeit getrimmt ist, dann plötzlich das Wort Phosphor-Brandwaffen zu hören. Und naja, es gab kleine Turbulenzen zu diesem Begriff. Wir hören zuerst mal wie der Deutschlandfunk in seinem Politikpodcast, also in dem aufgenommenen Studiogespräch, so in der Küchenzeile oder so, ist das ja ungefähr gedacht, dass man da so ein bisschen freier abseits des Programms als Deutschlandfunkjournalist darüber redet. Und da hat man sich so über den Vorfall verständigt.
Letzter kurzer Aspekt. Wir haben hier ja keinen Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit. Das Konferenzbuch der Veranstaltung war hunderte von Seiten dick. Aber weil es für Schlagzeilen gesorgt hat gestern, die Bemerkung des Vizeregierungschefs hinsichtlich des Einsatzes von Streumunition und Phosphor völkerrechtlich, geächteter Waffen. Was war das für euch? War das ein Ausrutscher in der...
Auch interessant, hier sind es nicht die Phosphor-Brandwaffen, sondern die Phosphor-völkerrechtlich geächteten Waffen.
Diskussion war das ein gezielter Testballon, um zu sehen, wie weit die Ukraine gehen können. Aus dem Westen kam ja unmittelbar schnell die klare Botschaft. Also wir werden natürlich, weil wir die Oslo-Konventionen, in der diese Waffen geächtet sind, unterzeichnet haben, diese Waffen nicht liefern. Aber der Vizeregierungschef war sehr deutlich in seiner Ansage, wir haben diese Konvention nicht unterzeichnet. Wir sehen uns diesen Waffen ausgesetzt aus Russland. Und deshalb wird man uns den Einsatz nicht verweigern können.
Das ist ein dummer Ausrutscher. Und zwar von jemandem, der sich offensichtlich nicht auskennt. Ich habe noch nichts von Andrej Melnek dazu gehört. Das ist bezeichnend. Normalerweise würde man von ihm sofort einen heftigen Tweet der Befürwortung bekommen.
Melnek hat sich nicht geäußert. Selbst Melnek schweigt. Es gab das Gespräch. Ein Vizeregierungschef, also ein Zelensky-Vertreter, hat dort angemerkt, die Russen verwenden die ja auch auf unserem Boden. Warum dürfen wir nicht auf unserem Boden sie verwenden? Es war aber völlig klar, die Ukraine hat sie nicht. Und es steht völlig außer Frage, dass sie ihr geliefert werden können, weil sie verboten sind.
Warum nicht noch mal mit Landminen neu anfangen?
Genau, irgendwie so. Und jetzt steigen wir ins Diskursgeschehen drum herum ein, um diesen Vorfall. Und ich will das jetzt nur illustrieren im Sinne von, hier geht es darum, darüber sich zu verständigen, was mündlich in einer programmierten Veranstaltung auf deutschem Boden unter Aufsicht von Journalisten gesprochen wurde. So, wir sind also ganz weit weg von einem Kriegsgeschehen, das mit Absicht abseits von journalistischen Augen und auch, wie es halt Krieg so ist, ungeplant. Man guckt einfach mal, wie weit man mit seinen Möglichkeiten zu kommt und so. Wir sind also eigentlich bei dieser Diskussion über Phosphor-Brandwaffen auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz unter Aufsicht von Journalisten, die live dabei sind, wenn es besprochen wird, denken wir eigentlich, ja, das, okay, dann, weil das da gesagt wurde, reden wir mal kurz drüber. Das klingt dann aber in der deutschen Podcastlandschaft dann so, hier bei Micky Beisenherz im extra anberaunten Gespräch mit David Mortmann, auch ein Podcaster aus Deutschland, weil Micky Beisenherz sagt, ja, ich könnte zwar jetzt hier in meinem Podcast darüber reden, aber ich möchte gern nochmal, weil das so ein relevantes Thema ist, mit jemandem, der vor Ort war, darüber sprechen, was denn da vorgefallen ist. Und plötzlich sieht dieser Vorfall so aus.
Selensky hat ja nach Streumunition und Phosphorbomben gefragt oder sie verlangt. Wie wurde das aufgenommen beim Groh der Teilnehmenden?
Also beim Groh der Teilnehmenden ist da doch einige Skepsis zum Ausdruck gebracht worden. Der Grund, warum das Selensky gesagt hat, der weckt im Übrigen auch relativ müde in dieser Schalte, aber gut, ist auch nicht weiter verwunderlich, ist der Grund, warum natürlich viele jetzt sagen, das geht nicht, weil das natürlich auch Waffen sind und Munitionsarten sind, die eigentlich verboten sein sollten. Hochbleiben setzt diese Waffen allerdings aktuell ein und das ist auch der Grund, warum Selensky sie gerade fordert.
Ja, plötzlich hat Selensky Phosphor-Brandwaffen gefordert, wirkten dabei aber ziemlich müde, was ja aber wir alle verstehen können. Schließlich ist er ein hart beschäftigter Mann im Krieg, der eben relativ wenig Schlaf bekommt. Also man strickt sich so Geschichten darüber. Man ist auf einer Veranstaltung und redet über einen Vorfall, den es überhaupt nicht gab. Möchte aber in dem Moment nicht zeigen, dass man gar nicht genau weiß, weil man das jetzt nicht nach was Selensky zum Thema gefragt hat. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal, was so auf der Hand liegt. Was so ungefähr. Und da frage ich mich, wenn das das Gespräch über die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz ist, wie können wir ernsthaft behaupten, in deutschen Podcasts über das Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine zu reden? Das geht doch gar nicht. Das ist doch völlig ausgeschlossen. Und trotzdem findet es überall so statt. Und mit dieser Inbrunst und emotionalen Involviertheit und so, dass man sich wirklich fragen muss, Leute, ich kann ja nicht einfach sagen, ja, ist ein super relevantes Thema, aber wir können leider nichts darüber sagen. Wir sind hier darauf angewiesen, was eventuell nochmal die Deutschlandfunkleute oder die Tagesschau dazu sendet. Ansonsten gibt es von uns nichts beizutragen dazu.
Aber bei der Tagesschau müsste man vielleicht auch mitunter mal bei Wikipedia nachlesen, welche Waffe völkerrechtswidrig ist, welche geächtet wird und welche man nicht mehr anwendet. Und dass man da nicht immer so neue Euphemismen findet. Ich würde noch gerne, um das abzuschließen, einen Clip spielen von Roderich Kiesewetter, um zu zeigen, wie diese Eskalationsdynamiken entstehen können. Weil das ja immer so gesagt wurde, nein, nein, also das sind ja ganz, ganz merkwürdige Leute, die jetzt an so domino-Effekte glauben, dass wenn man Panzer liefert, dann auch das nächste kommt. Nein, das hat ja gar nichts mit unserer Wirklichkeit zu tun. Wir hören hier mal auch einen Ausschnitt aus einer Fernsehsendung von Mickey Beisenherz. Da sitzen sich gegenüber Kiesewetter und Eva Quartbeck, die Journalistin.
Sprechen. Und zwar mit dem Punkt, mit den Kampfjets könnten sie Russland angreifen. Ja, und warum nicht? Warum sollen sie nicht russische Versorgungslinien, die an die Grimm angrenzen, die nördlich von Scharkow sind, die nördlich von Kiew sind, angreifen?
Weil die NATO ein Verteidigungsbündnis ist und die NATO tatsächlich die Ukraine nur so ausstatten sollte, dass sie sich verteidigen kann.
Das sehe ich völlig anders.
Aber sie kämen dann aus NATO-Staaten.
Das sehe ich völlig anders, weil ich glaube, die Eskalation ging ja von Russland aus. Und Russland hat jeglichem Bemühen unserer Seite behutsam, die Ukraine zu unterstützen, mit weiteren Eskalationen begegnet. Und das bedeutet für mich, dass wir eigentlich keine Angst vor, ja, wie soll ich sagen, keine Angst davor haben, sollten Russland anzugreifen, die immer weiter eskalieren.
Wir sollten keine Angst davor haben, Russland anzugreifen.
Ja, weil die ja schon die ganze Zeit immer, wenn wir was geliefert haben, trotzdem eskaliert haben. Und deswegen sollten wir jetzt mal überlegen, ob man nicht auch Russland direkt angreifen kann.
Aber meinte er Russland angreifen? Weil eben ausgeführt war das ja noch russische Kräfte auf ukrainischem Boden.
Nein, nein, es soll dann die Ukraine auch die Möglichkeit bekommen, dass sie dann Russland auch angreifen kann. Und das sind dann genau diese Dynamiken, bei denen man immer wieder betonen muss, wir scheinen ein Glück zu haben, dass solch besonnene Gemüter wie Olaf Scholz und Joe Biden regieren. Es könnte alles wesentlich schlimmer sein. Das sollte man sich auch selbst, wenn die Lage sehr frustrierend ist, immer vergegenwärtigen. Und wir können noch immer daran denken, dass diese Frustrierten, die nicht die entsprechenden politischen Posten bekommen haben, oder gewisse Journalisten, wenn die jetzt in der Macht stünden zu entscheiden, es könnte alles sehr viel schlimmer sein, seid froh, hofft, dass Biden und Olaf Scholz noch 100 Jahre durchhalten.
Ja, es ist auch wirklich erstaunlich, diese Ausschussvorsitzenden im Bundestag, wie frei die drehen, wie sie sich aufspielen und überhaupt. Nun gut, also die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz ist eine Veranstaltung, die seit Ewigzeiten da stattfindet. Es ist ein bisschen unklar, wie sie überhaupt zustande kam, aber man hat halt Gesprächszusammenhänge. Es war ja immer so jenseits der eigentlichen Institutionen organisiert. Da kann man ja eigentlich so parallel zielen, wie man die Europäische Kohle- und Stahlunion so gegründet hat. Und dann haben sich halt auch mal die Staats- und Regierungschefs so getroffen. Aber das dauerte so ewig, bis die dann mal in das erste Vertragswerk reingerutscht sind, nämlich zum Beispiel im Vertrag von Maastricht 92, 93. Da war das schon ein politisch etabliertes Gremium, das wirklich die Entscheidungsgewalt über den Ministerrat, der schon viel vorher gefasst wurde, hatte. Und auch das Europäische Parlament war ja zuerst nur so ein, ja, wir entsenden halt so unsere Parlamentarier, damit die da so zusammenreden, ein reines Redeparlament. Dann hat man das irgendwann mal reingeschrieben, dass es das überhaupt gibt. Und dann hat es plötzlich Entscheidungsbefugnis bekommen. In deren Sicht ist diese Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz auch so in diesem Zwischenstadium, wo man sich bewusst dafür entschieden hat, wir machen jetzt keine politische Institution draus, keine Gremium. Es bleibt sozusagen total informal. Aber einer der großen Geldgeber ist dann trotzdem der deutsche Staat oder Bayern, die das da einfach klar sperren, wie für euch die ganze Stadt darf und so. Und Söder sitzt dann in der ersten Reihe und langweilt sich so ein bisschen, weil er nicht mit auf die Bühne darf und lauter solche Sachen.
Ich bin aber sehr stolz, wenn er fotografiert wird mit Mächtigen dieser Welt.
Also wir haben es mit so einer semiöffentlichen Veranstaltung zu tun, die aber am Ende dann doch relativ relevant ist, was so das eine oder andere, den einen oder anderen Tagesordnungspunkt angeht. Und es ist, und das muss man eben jetzt in diesen Zeiten ausdrücklich dazu sagen, keine Ukrainekonferenz. Nur weil überall dieser Ukrainekrieg so thematisiert wird und stattfindet, sondern es ist eine Konferenz zur Sicherheitspolitik, die sich ganz viele Probleme, Problemen stellt unter der Maßgabe. Wir schauen uns mal die besonders an, wo es auch so eine militärische Komponente gibt, wo man nicht einfach nur die Außenminister redet und dann findet sich schon im Geiste der Gemeinsamkeit irgendwas, sondern da wo auch Waffen entweder im Hintergrund oder halt mal in echter Anwendung so eine Rolle spielen. Und wir hören mal so in die Eröffnung rein. Christoph Heusgen, wir werden sein Buch erlesen im Salon. Er hat nach zehn Jahren Referatsleitung 6 im Kanzleramt unter Merkel, also Außenpolitik-Chef, wahrscheinlich wichtiger jemals, also zu jeder Zeit wichtiger, da Merkel ja sehr viel Außenpolitik gemacht hat, als irgendwie Sigmar Gabriel oder Steinmeier da im Amt. Die waren dann mehr so für die Fernsehgespräche da.
Genau, lass uns das gerade mal sagen, bevor wir jetzt mit den ganzen Clips anfangen, weil wir uns ja selber verhättert haben. Eigentlich wollten wir nur ankündigen, dass wir den Habermas-Essay und das Alexander-Kluge-Interview auch zusammen lesen und besprechen und sehr gespannt sind, was dann wirklich inhaltlich dort zu finden ist, jenseits all der Polemik, die wir eben schon referiert haben. Und wir werden dann als dritten, langeren Text hinzunehmen, das Buch von Christoph Heusgen, der jetzt die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz leitet und der Merkels Berater war. Sein neues Buch bei Siedler erschienen Führung und Verantwortung, Angela Merkels Außenpolitik und Deutschlands künftige Rolle in der Welt. Und daran können wir glaube ich dann sehr gut nochmal diese ganzen Beiträge jetzt auch von Habermas und Alexander abgleichen. Ich glaube, das wird eine sehr differenzierte Betrachtung werden, weil Heusgen natürlich jetzt als die Stimme der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hier spricht und so ein Buch vorlegt und eigentlich ein Programm damit vorlegt, in welche Richtung soll es gehen. Das ist also das, was wir beide im Salon vorhaben. Und wir wollen noch ankündigen, dass dieser Salon im März picke packe voll ist, weil wir ja auch unseren Live Salon in Frankfurt haben. Und diese Veranstaltung wird dann gleich am nächsten Tag auch für die, die den Salon abonniert haben, zu hören sein. Wir werden also zwei Stunden dort miteinander auf der Bühne vor Publikum agieren, suchen noch Themen, aber manches haben wir vielleicht auch schon gefunden. Wir machen es weiter. Wir werden aber noch nichts verraten, was wir machen. Es wird lustig. Ja, es wird lustig. Wir hoffen es. Und das ist dann auch im Salon zu hören. Das lohnt sich also doppelt quasi, den Salon zu abonnieren. Und weil immer mal die Frage bei Twitter kommt, wie lang ist denn eigentlich der Salon? Manche denken vielleicht, wir reden da nur so 30 Minuten. Hier sind noch drei schöne Bücher und Tschüss. Nein, der Salon ist auch, man kennt uns relativ lang. Und zwar ist er so zweieinhalb Stunden angepeilt. Und wir geben uns Mühe, unter drei Stunden immer zu bleiben. Bislang haben wir das auch gerade immer so geschafft. Und wir stellen ja dann neben den Texten, die wir gemeinsam lesen, noch jeweils fünf weitere Texte vor. Der Salon, das sagen wir nochmal dazu, ist buchbar über Apple. Er ist buchbar über Patreon. Aber wir präferieren Steady, weil dort die Kapitelmarken sind, weil dort alle alten Folgen auch hochgeladen sind. Aber jedem ist natürlich frei, wo er den Salon abonnieren möchte. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr auf diese Weise den Podcast unterstützt.
So ist es. Wenn die fünf Stunden ja gerade über euch durchgelaufen sind, gibt es eine Woche später nochmal drei Stunden extra. Dann hat man auch genug für den Monat. Also, Christoph Heusgen eröffnet die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz. Natürlich auch erstmal mit einem Blick auf die Ukraine und Vladimir Putin. Er war ja so mutig, sich danach im Fernsehen nochmal in den Tagesthemen zu zeigen, im Gespräch und zu sagen, ich hätte das damals nicht gedacht. Drei Tage vorher, dass es passiert.
Also der, der es, wenn es einer wissen kann, dann wissen müsste, nämlich Häusgen sagte noch, ich hätte es nicht gedacht.
Also kein Deutscher kennt Putin so gut wie Christoph Häusgen, denn er hat nicht nur die Außenpolitik beobachtet oder sowas, sondern er hat sie gemacht. Er hat die Gespräche geführt.
Und wir konnten jetzt gerade so ein Schwenk ins Publikum sehen und dort saßen auch Cem Özdemir und Annalena Baerbock, aber in den hinteren Reihen und das kann man vielleicht auch festhalten, es war im vergangenen Jahr noch so, dass Baerbock die erste Rede von deutscher Seite hielt und diesmal war es Scholz. Also man kann hier schon eine ganz klare Verschiebung hin zu Scholz feststellen. Also Außenpolitik wird jetzt von Scholz gemacht.
Genau, Annalena Baerbock ist sozusagen echt so ein bisschen kaltgestellt, insbesondere auch durch diesen Aufrücken von Pistorius. Sie hat sich selber abseits gestellt und zufällig kam dann auch noch Pistorius um die Ecke und hat ja nicht nur das Amt des Verteidigungsministers übernommen, sondern auch die Spitzenposition der beliebtesten deutschen Politiker, laut Politbarometer im ZDF. Also gleich in die Poolposition eingerückt. Gut, Heuskern zählt Kriege auf, die außenpolitisch relevant sind und die Konferenzteilnehmer beschäftigen.
Ein Jahr später sind über 14 Millionen Ukraineaner verletzt. Es gibt 10.000 Kinder, Frauen und Männer, die getötet, getötet, zerstört, verletzt und abgedeckt wurden. Aber Ukraine ist nicht der einzige Ort, wo Menschen verletzt werden. Wir haben Afghanistan, Syrien, Iran, Äthiopien, Haiti. Und ich erinnere mich an den anerkannten Report des High Commissioners for Human Rights, der Ex-Präsident Michel Bachelet, der über die Fähigkeit der Uygurs in Xinjiang vorgesehen hat.
Es ist auch relevant für den folgenden Tag, wo Heusgen das wichtigste Panel der Konferenz ankündigt, zum globalen Süden. Es ist nämlich nicht so, dass man hier denkt, oh in München ist eine Sicherheitskonferenz, also geht es da vor allem um die Ukraine. Die Ukraine war Top 3. Das wichtigste politische Thema bleibt der Klimawandel. Das hat man auch ganz unmissverständlich klar gemacht. Alle strategischen Überlegungen gehen darin, wie geht man mit dem künftigen Migrationsström um, wie geht man mit Wasserknappheit um und so weiter und so fort. Platz 2 ist die Anbindung Europas an den globalen Süden, weil man jetzt festgestellt hat, den hat man ganz schön verloren. Und erst Platz 3, wenn auch klar, wenn die Großen sprechen, Harris, Scholz, Macron und so weiter, da geht es um die Ukraine aus Aktualitätsgründen, aber in den strategischen Überlegungen, die hier angestellt werden und dann auch ins große Konferenzbuch einfließen und so, sind es eben die anderen Themen.
Und bei Macron hat der globale Süden schon auch eine Rolle gespielt. Und es ist auch doch eine Verschiebung, die man da feststellen kann, denn wenn ich mich erinnere, war das in den vergangenen Jahren nicht so, dass der globale Süden dort eine besondere Rolle spielt. Also klar, der kam auch vor, aber dass er so dominant war, das ist schon eine Neuerung.
Es ist ihm jetzt aufgefallen durch den Ukraine-Krieg, denn man will ja auch ihn als globalen Wirtschaftskrieg gewinnen. Und man stellt fest, man versaut sich ganz schön mit dem globalen Süden, wenn das Handeln und das Reden nicht zusammenfallen. Und dann Putin kommt und sagt, die haben euch ja das ganze Getreide weggekauft. Dann sagt der Europäer, aber du hast das Herz zurückgehalten. Und dann sagt Putin, na ja, aber das, was verfügbar war, habt ihr aufgekauft, oder? Ihr habt es doch den afrikanischen Ländern weggekauft. Und dann sehen die afrikanischen Länder stehen so da und sagen, das stimmt. Wir haben mitgeboten und wir wurden überboten. Und jetzt sind alle Schiffe mit dem Gas und alle Getreideschiffe nach Europa gefahren. Und in deren Sicht muss man sich halt überlegen, wie man jetzt mit dem globalen Süden umgeht, wurde auch von Heusgen gleich hier thematisiert.
Ladies and gentlemen, the many conflicts that I mentioned demonstrate that the UN Charter is under attack, that the Universal Declaration of Human Rights is under attack, that the rules-based international order is under attack. We witness in Ukraine, we witness in Ukraine not a battle between East and West, but not a battle between NATO and Russia, or European Union and Russia, but we witness a battle which is between the rule of law and the law of the strongest. This is a battle which concerns the whole world. To defend this global order, we of course need the transatlantic community. But we also need the global south.
So, das ist dann also sein großer Programmpunkt an Tag zwei. Heusgen begrüßt ja nochmal Vertreter der OSCE, das wird ja mal leicht vergessen. Ach ja, die gibt's ja auch noch.
We also, I also would like to welcome the representatives from international organizations, from the UN family, from the secretary general of the OSCE and the chairman in office of the OSCE, one of the last organizations where Russia is still participating.
Die OSCE hat ja eigentlich die interessanteste Geschichte überhaupt der letzten 30 Jahre, denn Macron ist ja kein Vorreiter oder Pionier in dem Ansinnen Europa, mal so ein bisschen zu integrieren, auf eigene Füße zu stellen, unabhängig von Amerika. Das war ja immer das Programm der OSCE, quasi NATO auch zu sein, ohne amerikanische Dominanz. Die Amerikaner gucken schon gar nicht mehr auf uns, die machen schon nie auf pazifisches Jahrhundert und so weiter. Die Amerikaner, denen ist es immer noch ganz wichtig, in Europa so präsent zu sein. Das ist keine Nachlässigkeit von uns, sondern das ist sozusagen deren Erfolg.
Was man ja auch sieht, wie mit dem Austritt England aus der EU, nun plötzlich da wieder ein ganz enges Bann zwischen USA und England ist eigentlich noch stärker und Großbritannien ja sehr mit diesem transatlantischen Bündnis froh zu sein scheint bzw. es ja soweit geht, dass es auch gar nicht mehr diese übliche Kritik gibt. Also es gab ja durchaus von der Labour Party immer wieder Kritik an der NATO. Das ist ja geradezu verboten jetzt.
Ja, man ist in die Lücke gerne reingesprungen. Also England war ja dann auch erlegen sehr auf der Suche.
Frankreich natürlich immer diese besondere Distanzhaltung hatte. De Gaulle war derjenige, der auch fremdelte, wenn Europa dort England aufnimmt, also in die EU oder WG aufnimmt damals, dann könnte es damit eine zu große Nähe zu den USA geben. Und deswegen war ja Frankreich da auch erst sehr skeptisch, ob man überhaupt England mit dazu lassen soll in den erlauchten Club, ob man damit nicht eine zu große US Nähe herstellt.
Und Frankreich und die NATO ist ja eine interessante Hop-On-Hop-Off-Geschichte. Soweit ich weiß, ist ja Frankreich mal ausgetreten aus der NATO, oder? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber das sollte man sich auch noch mal genau anschauen. Also in Frankreich hat man immer anders geschaut als jetzt England oder insbesondere wir, Kriegsverlierer, die Deutschen. Aber Klimawandel, Klimawandel, Klimawandel. Also George Soros ist ein eigenes Programm gefahren. Du hast ja darauf hingewiesen. Er hat sich nicht in Davos blicken lassen, sondern gesagt, ich fahr zur Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz und hat dort im Kontext, in Kulisse der militärischen Diskussion einen Klimawandel Vortrag vor Studenten gehalten, welcher nochmal thematisiert wurde. Ich habe gerade nochmal nachgeschaut, also die Franzosen sind erst, das ist wirklich erstaunlich, seit 2009 sind die erst wieder Vollmitglied der NATO. Die waren von 66 bis 2009 sozusagen nur peripher bei der NATO angebunden. Also diese Bande, das ein französischer Präsident hat irgendwie gesagt, die NATO ist doch hirntot und so. Das hat alles Geschichte. Gut, auf Macron kommen wir ja gleich. Häusken, ganz nah am Wasser gebaut. Es war eine ganz erstaunliche Szene.
I would now ask for your attention. Please listen to Samson Tsui, a British pianist of Russian and Korean origin. He will play for us Schubert's Impromptu No.
Du hast ein kleines Pianointernet, so. Also wirklich interessant, zusammengebaut so als Programm. Heuskind, der plötzlich 10 Uhr morgens seinen Tränen ausbricht. Weil er sich auf diese Musik so freut oder so.
Naja, das ist auch eine der berühmtesten Stücke von Schubert, ist ja dann auch, naja.
Ist das so bewegend, dass man da so mitgerissen wird?
Nee, ich weiß nicht, es ist eine merkwürdige Atmosphäre, dass man dann so ein Schubert da mal reinbringt und dann auch noch so diese Bekanntheit. Das ist natürlich ein Stück, das sehr schnell rührt und das häufig als Zugabe gegeben wird. Oder es gibt ja auch die Verkitschung dann im Schlager.
Okay, also dann verstehen wir alle, warum Mäusken das noch mal mitnehmen. Das ist das richtige Alter, in dem er ist, um diese Musik entsprechend zu leben. Es wird also oben auf der Empore Flügel gespielt. Wir überspringen das jetzt, kommen die letzten Töne rein, hören dann den Applaus und dann geht einfach die Veranstaltung weiter.
This panel discussion is called David on the Dnipro. I consider it as a rightful respect to Ukraine and to everything our people are doing.
Das ist nicht schlecht. Zelensky macht dann hier mal die eine oder andere Ansage. Es ist schon, ich weiß nicht, ja, es gibt jetzt auch noch mal dieses Buch, Die Gesammelten Reden Zelenskys und auch die deutsche Podcastlandschaft hat den einzelnen Vertretern das noch mal betont, wie wichtig das ist, dass man jetzt noch mal den eigenen Worten der Ukraine nachliest und so.
Aber ich finde, wie da gibt es heute, die lesen noch mal die Reden, die schon gehalten wurden und die wir doch auch kennen.
Und machen dann Instagram-Stories zum Thema, schau dir das doch noch mal genau an. Und ich finde es, also so langsam finde ich es fragwürdig, denn ja, die Ukraine hat natürlich ihr Recht der Verteidigung und wir unterstützen sie ja auch dabei. Und ich finde, man sollte es auch langsam aufhören zu übertreiben, dass man beim Thema Ukraine-Krieg gar nicht mehr Ukraine-Krieg sagen darf, sondern immer gleich der brutale Angriffskrieg Russland gegen die Ukraine. Da frage ich mich so langsam auch, wie weit wollen wir es treiben?
Das haben wir ja verstanden. Das ist doch eigentlich zwischen jedem vernünftigen Menschen. Und da klammern wir diese drei Verrückten, die irgendwie sagen, Putin rette uns, die klammern wir mal aus. Aber wenn wir generell von diesem Krieg reden, dann müssen wir nicht jedes Mal noch mal benennen, wer den angefangen hat. Das müsste uns ja inzwischen klar sein. Und dass Angriffskriege völkerrechtswidrig sind, sollte auch klar sein. Und ich kenne auch keinen unbrutalen Krieg.
Ja, manchmal, das ist nur eine Spielerei als Gedanke, wenn Serdar Zemuncu oder diese AD-Comedians, Dieter Nuhr und so über Cancel Culture reden, dann betonen sie ja immer, und das ist ja auch mittlerweile so ein Running Gag, wenn irgendwie die Amerikaner darüber reden, dass man immer heute nicht genau weiß, was vielleicht in zehn Jahren unter das fällt, weil die ja heute leiden darunter, dass ihnen Sachen von vor zehn Jahren plötzlich krumm gehört werden, aus dem Kontext heraus oder wie auch immer, oder dass halt manche Worte heute nicht mehr gehen, die damals aber noch total normal waren. Und irgendwie habe ich hier immer das Gefühl, es kommt so eine Zeit, in der man auch nicht einfach mehr sagen kann, zweiter Weltkrieg, sondern immer dazu sagen muss, dass man sich auch nochmal bekennt, der brutale Angriffskrieg Adolf Hitlers gegen den Rest der Welt, der sogenannte Zweite Weltkrieg. Dass das irgendwann, dass man es überhaupt nicht mehr schafft, einfach mal ein Substantiv zu verwenden, ohne Bekenntnis.
Ich glaube, dass man diese vielen Attribute braucht und die alle gemacht werden, die werden ja von Leuten gemacht, die ja überhaupt nicht im Verdacht stehen, irgendwie Putin-art zu sein. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man denkt, ja, aber vielleicht finden die das doch gar nicht so schlecht. Ohnehin habe ich noch niemanden getroffen, der sagt, es ist aber richtig, was der Putin da macht. Also, ja, es wird irgendwo Leute geben, wie es auch Leute gibt, die glauben, dass Bill Gates uns schippen will. Aber ich kenne die persönlich auch nicht. Na ja, aber man sieht eigentlich daran, dass selbst diese Leute, die gar nicht im Verdacht stehen, irgendeine Putin-Nähe zu haben, eine gewisse Furcht haben, dass, wenn sie eine Äußerung treffen, dass die in irgendeiner Weise missverstanden werden könnte und dass man dann durch den Fleischwolf, der sich Twitter nennt, gedreht wird. Und deswegen versucht man alles abzusichern, damit man ja nicht irgendwie in den Verdacht gerät, dass vielleicht doch gemeint sein könnte, dass dies und das und das führt ja dann auch dazu, dass Fragen wie, ist es wirklich sinnvoll, jetzt noch Panzer zu liefern, verlängert das den Krieg, verlängert das das Leid, gleich aufgebauscht werden, wie könnt ihr den Aggresse unterstützen und so weiter. Und dann hat man ja wirklich ganz absurde Diskussionen bei Twitter, wer jetzt von welcher Seite das unterstützt, jetzt haben die Rechten das auch retweetet oder so etwas, wo ich sagen muss, ja, es gibt auch AfD-Mitglieder, die beim Christopher-Street-Day irgendwie mitlaufen. Was soll ich jetzt mit dem Christopher-Street-Day machen? Abschaffen, verbieten, müssen die vorher Ausweise zeigen. Also man wird auch generell immer merkwürdige Leute irgendwo finden. Und ja, ich gebe zu, manche ziehen es an. Aber es ist eine ganz, ganz stark polarisierte Diskussion, die nur noch einen Schwarz und Weiß kennt. Und man muss auch dann vielleicht sich mal sagen, mithabermaßen aus einem ersten Essay, wir sind in der Zuschauerloge. Und als Zuschauer sollte man dann wenigstens, und das meinte er, das ist ja unser Dilemma, unser moralisches Dilemma, liefern wir. Ja, dann können wir damit tun, aber wir tun eigentlich nicht mit, weil wir ja alle hier bleiben und so weiter. Aber man sollte diese Zuschauerposition auch mal ernst nehmen im Sinne von, was kann eigentlich ein Zuschauer tun? Er kann Distanz zu dem Gesehenen wahren. Während natürlich Leute, die direkt involviert sind, also wie zum Beispiel Anselensky oder ukrainische Soldaten, natürlich diese Distanz nicht herstellen können, weil sie mittendrin sind. Aber wenn das dann von den Medien auch nicht mehr geleistet wird, dann kommt man eben an so einen Punkt, wo man gar nicht mehr weiß, in welche Richtung kann man denn jetzt. Und dann gibt es diese große Furcht. Also ich glaube, das ist schon sehr stark da, die Furcht, sich missverständlich ausgedrückt zu haben. Und deswegen sagt man es lieber dreimal mal.
Ja, und das schwingt halt immer mit, dass auch nach 300.000 Toten und zwar ermordeten Menschen, auch in dem Krieg wird man ja, wenn man stirbt, ermordet, man stirbt dann ja einfach so passiv. Man weiterhin nicht nur dabei bleibt, es kann nur eine militärische Lösung geben, weil nämlich Putin ja nicht nachlässt. Sobald man militärisch nicht dagegen hält, gewinnt ja Putin. Und man hat damit diesen Friedensbegriff so in die Ecke gedrängt, dass ich glaube, und das unterstelle ich jetzt nicht als Spielerei oder Spaß, sondern das unterstelle ich wirklich sehr vielen, denen ich so einen Diskurs sehe, dass sehr viele sehr dankbar sind, dass der Friedensbegriff jetzt mit Sarah Wagenknecht verknüpft ist, weil es ihnen dann umso einfacher fällt, den einfach weiter zu diskreditieren.
Das ist doch die Wiederholung des Corona-Diskurses. Wenn man natürlich dort Reichsbürger hat, die sagen, Bill Gates will uns schippen oder George Soros steigt hinter allem, dann will man ja auf keinen Fall mit denen in ein Lager gebracht werden, möchte nicht mit denen zusammen eine Ecke gestellt werden. Und dann heißt es aber auch jetzt besser, keine Kritik nach der dritten Impfung an der FFP2-Maske, denn sonst könntest du jetzt zum Querdenkerlager zu gehören. Und genauso auch bei dieser Wagenknecht-Sache. Ich bin nicht hier, um Wagenknecht oder Schwarz oder so zu verteidigen. Ich würde aber da auch für eine Differenzierung doch plädieren, wenn man sieht, wer das dort unterzeichnet hat. Da mögen Leute darunter sein, die einem nicht gefallen. Ich muss nicht erwähnen, dass ich todenhöflich verschrecklich finde. Das habe ich mal in einer Stunde Politik-Analyse ausgeführt, warum das so ist. Aber ich würde auch sagen, es sind andere Menschen, die sich darunter finden. Es ist ein Reinhard May. Es ist eine Jutta Speidel, die sich im Übrigen im vergangenen Jahr für ukrainische Flüchtlinge eingesetzt hat. Es ist mein guter Freund Christian Baron, der Schriftsteller. Es ist der Vorsitzende des Zentralrats, der Sinti und Roma. Es ist Hajo Funke, der sein halbes Leben damit zugebracht hat, den Rechtsextremismus zu erklären und zu analysieren und zu bekämpfen. Und jetzt kann man alles, was sich da anschließt und welche Verlautbarungen da so kommen in Einzelreden, all das kann man kritisieren. Aber diese Leute alle über einen Kamm zu scheren, bis hin dann zu anderen Friedenskundgebungen, die es gibt von Seiten der katholischen oder evangelischen Kirche. Das finde ich wirklich eine völlig verzogene Diskussion und spiegelt auch nicht das wieder, was die Menschen im Herzen tragen. Das ist nicht irgendeine komische Poutine, sondern es ist zum Teil eine wirklich existenzielle Angst vor dem, was da kommen könnte.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr dafür und will auch noch mal ermutigen, man darf für den Frieden sein, auch wenn man nicht genau erklären kann, wie er zustande kommen soll.
Genau, denn die anderen könnten auch nicht genau erklären, wie sie das mit ihren Waffen hinbekommen wollen.
Dass automatisch der Krieg jetzt zum Frieden führen soll, das muss auch erst mal bewiesen werden. Gerade, wir werden ja nachher über China reden, wenn China da oder sei es Belarus, jetzt eine Million Menschen da irgendwie mobilisiert, die da auch teilnehmen, dann wird es nämlich heikel, brenzlig und sehr eng. Ich finde jedenfalls, in dieser Gemengelage, die wir haben, muss man auch Zelensky mal kritisieren dürfen, für Sachen, die er so sagt. Und da fällt mir zum Beispiel dieser Satz hier, der fällt damit darunter.
Können die Freiheit das Thema Kompromisse sein? Und es ist ein Rocksolid. Ich bin sicher, dass wir nicht nur über Putin, sondern auch über Putin gewinnen können.
Was will er uns jetzt damit sagen?
Er möchte den Friedensbegriff so ein bisschen hyper aufladen. Ich meine, das Ziel, das jetzt alle haben sollten, ist Frieden in der Ukraine. Und damit ist erst mal gemeint, eine grundlegende Abwesenheit von Gewalt. Dass dann irgendwelche Ideologien, Ideen und so weiter dahinter, dass man vielleicht Putin selbst besiegen muss. Das hören wir bei Macron auch gleich nochmal anders. Ob es jetzt wirklich darum geht, Putin aus dem Weg zu räumen oder Frieden auch so hergestellt werden kann. Und damit ist wirklich erst mal nur die Abwesenheit von Krieg gemeint. Hier jetzt das alles aufzuladen mit, wir kämpfen ja nicht nur gegen diesen Putin, sondern auch gegen die Putins auf der ganzen Welt. Das finde ich so ein bisschen, wenn westliche... Also wenn jetzt so westliche Politiker, die aus dieser Zuschauer- und Unterstützerseite irgendwie sagen, ja, es ist relativ wichtig, dass jetzt Putin da zurückgeschlagen wird, damit auch die Chinesen nicht auf falsche Ideen kommen oder so weiter. Okay, diese Art von Abstraktion zugestanden, aber dass man jetzt als Kriegspartei plötzlich anfängt, nicht kämpfe nicht nur gegen Putin, sondern gegen die Putins der ganzen Welt. Also das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu viel.
Ja, dann hat man einen permanenten Interventionismus. Dann kann man sagen, dann gehen wir jetzt überall rein. Und überall ist ein Putin zu verhindern und Putin ist wie Hitler. Und das muss sowieso unser Bestreben sein. Und dann Hitler zu verhindern und dann können wir alles machen. Also dann aber, in welcher Welt leben wir dann? In einer des permanenten Krieges.
Genau, also man sollte hier erst mal niemanden überfordern. Und man braucht auch einen Benchmark dafür, was jetzt das Ziel ist. Also das Ziel muss erreichbar sein.
Jetzt werden manche sagen, ja, aber man kann ja nicht einfach zuschauen. Aber das ist ja leider das Problem mit der Weltpolitik, dass man in vielen Dingen machtlos ist und nicht intervenieren kann. Und das tun wir ja auch nicht. Wir helfen ja noch nicht mal da, wo wir helfen könnten. Also das ist ja auch interessant. Man könnte ja in ganz vielen Ländern ganz ohne Militär Leid verhindern, nämlich zum Beispiel durch Spenden. Und das tun wir auch nicht. Wir könnten ganz anders mit den Menschen in Afghanistan umgehen und tun es nicht. Wir müssen das nicht alles wieder aufzählen. Aber das tun wir da auch nicht. Aber jetzt glaubt man mit so Absolutheitsforderungen zu sagen, jetzt machen wir so eine permanente Intervention gegen alle Putinisten dieser Welt. Das kann nicht gehen. Dann müsste man wirklich mal lieber eine Utopie ausformulieren. Offenbar gibt es ja schon ein Problem mit dem Nationalstaat an sich, dass die Nationalstaaten sich in Konkurrenz gegenüberstehen. Da müssen wir überlegen, wie kommen wir in eine andere Ordnung hin, wo der Nationalstaat überwunden wird oder was auch immer. Aber wir können nicht sagen, na ja, jetzt den einen Krieg gewinnen wir und dann gewinnen wir noch die anderen 50, die zu kämpfen sind.
Ja, und was das Zuschauergespräch von uns aus angeht, also hier die ganze deutsche Diskurslandschaft und so, ich finde, sehr viele machen sich das auch viel zu leicht. Sie nehmen nämlich auf, das ist aber What about Tissen, wenn man jetzt anfängt mit Jemen. Wie sehr uns die schlimmste, vom Menschen verursachte, Hungerskatastrophe aller Zeiten, immer wieder ausgewiesen durch die UN, als diese Art von Problemlage, wie legal uns das war. Und dass wir da noch Waffen hingeliefert haben und dass Baerbock noch im Bundestag verteidigt hat, noch während der Ukraine-Krieg läuft, warum das geschehen musste und so. Warum wir den Saudi-Arabien unterstützen mussten. Also wer über die Ukraine redet, finde ich, sollte auf einer Ebene darüber reden, nämlich dass es da um Menschenleben und Leid und Verhinderungen und so weiter geht, muss auch über Jemen reden. Da kann er nicht einfach sagen, nee, ich interessiere mich gerade nur für die Ukraine und nicht für die Jemen. Und sonst machen wir aber historische Vergleiche.
Also sonst machen wir historische Vergleiche und vergleichen Putin mit Hitler und verhindern Auschwitz. Aber wir vergleichen jetzt nicht aktuelle Konflikte.
Richtig, sehr guter Punkt.
Denn ich würde sagen, historische Vergleiche sind ohnehin hoch problematisch. Man kann sie mitunter machen, um vielleicht ein bisschen Distanz zur Gegenwart zu bekommen. Aber das eine ist nicht das andere. Und das ist, gerade wenn man die Diktatoren des 20. Jahrhunderts und Putin sich ansehen, ziemlich klar. Und wenn wir aber sehen, welche Konflikte, welche Kriege und welches Elend haben wir aktuell, dann ist das eher miteinander zu vergleichbar. Aus dem Grund, dass wir die Regierungen haben, die jetzt dafür zuständig sind. Und mit diesen Vergleichen kann man dann überlegen, wo müsste dann ein konsequentes Regierungshandeln auch in diese oder jene Richtung gehen? Wir werden ja hier in diesem Podcast heute mal ganz groß über Migration sprechen. Und dann können wir da auch mit einem gewissen Whataboutism mal da rangehen, um zu sagen, wir machen da gerade in Europa richtig viel Schlimmes.
Ja, das hast du mich gerade noch inspiriert. Ich will diesen einen Satz noch sagen. Wer jetzt einen Habermas-Text nicht zulässt, weil Historiker-Streik, muss auch zugestehen, auch über Jemen sprechen zu müssen, obwohl Ukraine. Diese Bogenschläge sind dann zwingend. Zelenskis Gespräch klingt aus, Houskin stellt dann noch die drei typischen Anschlussfragen, unter anderem diese.
Du hast in der ukrainischen Gesellschaft viel interne Solidarität gezeigt. Meine Frage ist, wird diese Unität, die ich glaube, sehr wichtig ist, nach dem Krieg fortgeschrieben werden?
So, endemische Korruption, Korruption als Krankheitsbild. Okay, vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, was die Semantik angeht, aber Korruption ist ja ein echtes Problem. Man hat es ja erst an dieser Regierungsumstellung und so weiter da gesehen. Da wurden ja relativ viele sehr hohe Funktionäre entlassen. Korruption ist ja nun ein ganz spezielles Problem oder Phänomen, sagen wir mal soziologisch, neu ein bisschen neutraler, weil du ja eine Profit-Logik hast, wo sie eigentlich nicht hingehört. Und nicht nur das, sondern da, wo sie greift, nämlich zum Beispiel hier in der politischen Sphäre. Hast du ja jetzt gerade eine Situation, in der alle mit besonderer Innenbrunst an Projekten arbeiten sollten und plötzlich korrumpiert aber ein Profitinteresse darein. Das gestehen wir uns gerade nicht zu. Wir diskutieren nur ideologisch aufgeladen. Wir lassen das durch gar nichts torpedieren, erst recht nicht durch Profitinteresse. Wenn jetzt in der Ukraine, wo wir doch irgendwie hoffen, dass die doch mindestens genauso ideologisch gerade an diesem Kampf gegen die Russen beteiligt sind wie wir, semantisch und dort eben dann strukturell, wenn da Korruption ein Problem ist, also wenn die durch Geldversprechen aus der Bahn geworfen werden, abgetrieben werden von ihren ideologischen Überzeugungen, dass sie nämlich als Ukrainer gegen die Russen nicht nur den Putin, sondern die Putins der Welt bekämpfen, dann sollte uns das doch ernsthaft zu denken geben. Insbesondere weil der ukrainische Haushalt gerade fast vollständig von der EU-Kommission bezahlt wird und so. Und wir so viel Geld da reinpumpen, ohne genau zu klären, wo kommt man das eigentlich an und überhaupt. Das ist wirklich ein ernsthaftes Problem.
Und das wäre schön, wenn man da jetzt ein Auge drauf wirft und nicht in acht Jahren so schöne Longreads bekommt. Die können wir dann immer noch im Salon besprechen. Den Salon wird es ja auch dann noch geben, wo man dann nochmal erklärt bekommt, wo manche Millionen oder so hingeflossen sind. Sondern ich glaube, man sollte da von Anfang an mit Klarheit draufblicken und sich auch sowieso diese ökonomische Situation der Ukrainer vergegenwärtigen. Wir haben es mit einem Pro-Kopf-BEP. In der Ukraine von durchschnittlich 5000 Euro zu tun. Das heißt, das ist weniger Geld als vier Empfänger im Jahr zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen. Das ist in Deutschland mehr als zehnmal mehr Pro-Kopf-BEP. Da gibt es einige, die können sich dann bereichern. Klar, es gibt auch Eliten, die nicht korrupt sind, die aber gut Geld verdienen. Und ja, es gibt auch Subsistenzwirtschaften in der Ukraine, wodurch das ein bisschen relativiert wird mit diesem Pro-Kopf-BEP. Aber das ist ja auch nicht das, wie wir ein modernes Land verstehen. Und auch das ist nicht so viel an Subsistenzwirtschaft, dass das Pro-Kopf-BEP gar keine Rolle spielt. Aber wir haben da einen ganz klaren Ausweis dafür, wie arm dieses Land ist und wie arm es dann auch von solchen korrupten Eliten gemacht wurde. Denn tatsächlich gibt es ja unglaublich viel technischen Fortschritt, IT-Branche und alles mögliche. Es wird ja auch Geld verdient in der Ukraine. Aber man kann daran doch auch sehen, dass dann viel Geld ins Ausland fließt und so weiter. Deswegen würde ich auch sagen, wir müssen diesen ökonomischen Faktor dringend jetzt schon Mitte einführen in der Betrachtung des Krieges und der Situation in der Ukraine, damit nicht, wenn der Krieg einmal endet, die EU und viele ausländische Investoren dort einen Laden vorfinden, wo man sich auch nochmal dann vielleicht bedienen kann oder beziehungsweise jemand für seine Zwecke ausnutzen kann, sodass das pro Kopf-BP sich dann auch in den nächsten Jahren nicht verbessern wird.
Ja, vielleicht ist Heuskens Wortwahl, das endemisch zu nennen, gar nicht so verkehrt, obwohl das so ein sehr biologischer Begriff ist, weil am Ende ist es ja eine Dysfunktionalität, wie so eine Autoimmunerkrankung oder so ein Krebs, wo sich die biologischen Prinzipien gegen den Wirt selbst rechten, gegen den Körper selbst. Und in deren Sicht haben wir es hier, also nicht nur weil, ach ja, Korruption ist echtes Problem, sondern Korruption ist strukturell gesehen jetzt das schlechteste Problem, mit dem die Ukraine gerade kämpfen sollte. Also das ungünstigste Problemfall, den man da gerade hat. Auf Siedlinski, Volk, Scholz gleich als nächster Redner. Man hat am Anfang gleich mal die Headliner abgefeuert.
Sehr geehrter Herr Botschafter Heusken, meine Damen und Herren.
Ich spreche auf der Seite von allen, wenn ich nach diesem Sitz des Siedlinski für Vladimir Volodymyr aufrufe. Wir würden es lieben, euch heute mit uns zu haben, denn die Ukraine gehört hier, an unserem Sitz, in einer freien und uniteren Europa.
Ich muss gerade lachen, dass du uns offenbar nur einen einzigen Clip von Scholz mitbringst. Deswegen habe ich die Rede auch komplett gehört und hätte aber auch keinen zweiten gefunden.
Ich habe ihn auch nicht extra noch mal rausgesucht auf Deutsch, sondern ich habe jetzt einfach den Live-Stream auf Englisch gelassen. Denn mir geht es nur um diese eine Pointe. Wir hätten sie sehr gerne hier gehabt. In München, nee, er kommt dann gleich mit dem Halbsatz im Kreise unserer Westlichen und so weiter Welt. Denn es ist ja schon erstaunlich, dass Zelensky, der in Paris war und dann nach London weiter, also der war ja überall, ne in Straßburg war er, nicht in Paris, in Straßburg, also in der EU, aber auf französischen Boden und dann ist er weiter nach London und dann wieder zurück und er war noch nicht auf deutschen Boden. Jetzt sagt Scholz ja so, er hätte nie auf deutschen Boden gehabt. Ich würde sagen, nee, hätte er nicht so gerne. Also wenn er wirklich gehabt hätte, hätte man ihn einfach eingeladen. Dann wäre er zur Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gekommen, hat man nicht. Die Russen waren ja alle schon ausgeladen. Also es wäre auch kein jetzt Fauxpas oder so gewesen oder ein Eclat oder sonst irgendwie, sondern Zelensky wäre einfach da gewesen. Klar, es hätte die Situation dort ein bisschen aufgestört, es ist ja eben schon sehr eng und so, wird ja immer betont, aber fand ich irgendwie witzig, dass er so einsteigt mit diesem, mit dieser klaren Lüge. Wir hätten sie gerne hier gehabt, denn vielleicht wäre ihm das auch zu viel.
Oder ist es, weil der beiden Besuch dann noch anstand, vielleicht wäre das alles ein bisschen knapp geworden. Na ja, man weiß es nicht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Deutschen das jetzt irgendwie cool fänden, wenn auch nur das Gerücht aufkäme. Zelensky würde auf deutschem Boden irgendwo in Berlin plötzlich zu sehen sein und so. Nun gut, kommen wir mal zu Macron. Macron hat dort eine sehr gute Rede gehalten und eine sehr gute Aussprache im Anschluss. Und es sind so ein paar Evergreens dabei, aber eben auch noch mal so aktualisiert.
Es war eine unglaublich interessante, vorwiegend frei gehaltene Rede.
Man hat so gesehen, er wollte was. Es war nicht nur diese Standardverurteilung der Chinesen, wie von Kamala Harris oder, dass man Putin nochmal die roten Linien aufzeigt und so, sondern er ist immer ein bisschen ins Eingemachte gegangen. Und wir schneiden mal in seine Öffnung ein.
Natürlich, in meinen Begegnungen heute möchte ich auf die Kriegspartnerung in der Ukraine konzentrieren. Aber gleichzeitig müssen wir nicht vergessen, dass es andere Kriege gibt, die in der Mittelfestlande in der Koalitionsregion gegründet werden. Aber heute ist die Ukraine am Herzen.
So mein Eindruck ist, wir hören es ja hier auf Englisch. Macron spricht auf Französisch. Macron kann sehr gut Englisch reden, wählt aber trotzdem Französisch. Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, das Team Macron hat auch die Rede vorher selber auf Englisch übersetzt und dann ins Synchro Studio gegeben, damit die lesen, was Elisee wirklich sagen möchte.
Aber er formuliert ja zum Teil völlig frei.
Genau, er bleibt an seinem Skript liegen. Aber es ist ihm auch sehr wichtig, was die internationale Community von der Rede mitnimmt. Dass man hier nicht einfach nur so eine Synchronübersetzung, die so spontan entsteht, sondern dass man da so ein bisschen wortgetreu ist. Also ja, es geht um den Ukraine-Krieg, aber große Kriegen und Krise. Und da kommt auf Putin zu sprechen.
The second defeat is the defeat of the colonial mentality.
Also sehr interessant ist, dass Macron hier überhaupt mal unterschiedliche Ebenen des Krieges betont. Ja, militärisch findet es statt, aber eben auch ideell. Jetzt kommt er erst mal nur auf die Ideen, die eben Putin damit so verbindet, nämlich dass man das einfach könnte überhaupt noch mal Grenzen verschieben und dann auch noch mal ein Land unter Jochen, eine Bevölkerung ins eigene BIP so einpreisen. Wir sind zu wenig, wir brauchen jetzt noch 40 Millionen ukrainische Arbeiter und so nicht solchen Kram. Und das kommt ja dieser Diskussion, die wir auch schon hatten, dass Baerbock, der irgendwie im Europa-Radar steht und sagt, wir führen ein Krieg gegen Russland und nicht untereinander und dann alle und zwar völlig zurecht sagen, ja das darf sie aber in der Rolle nicht sagen, obwohl sie Recht hat und so. Und wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass der Ukraine-Krieg ökonomischen Weltkrieg ist. Also dass wir in gewissen Ebenen hier schon auf Weltkrieg sind.
Auf digitaler Ebene vermutlich auch. Da sehen wir ganz viel gar nicht, was da noch alles passiert. Aber wir hören immer wieder von den verschiedenen Informationskriegen, die stattfinden, von Hacker-Angriffen. Das ist ja auch ganz interessant, wie sich das verschubt. Also wir können hier auf dem Schlachtfeld noch sehr schnell sagen, naja, wenn die Rakete über das Land Ukraine hinaus auf Russland geht, dann haben wir es da mit einer Eskalation zu tun oder so. Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich bei Hacker-Angriffen, die von irgendwelchen Ländern aus dem Westen herausgehen, da ist man doch in einer Situation, wo man sich eigentlich wie auf einem Meer befindet. Ja, und auf den Wellen gibt es nur Wellen.
Ja, also der Zweite Weltkrieg fand auch nicht überall militärisch statt, aber er hat eben auf der ganzen Welt seine Folgen und so, allein durch Migrationsströme. Und jetzt macht er hier dieses interessante Bild auf, wo man eh schon über mehrere Ebenen und Facetten des Krieges spricht. 2014 steht man auf der Krim, aber wer eigentlich? Alle wundern sich, die haben ja gar keine Abzeichen, die Soldaten und so. Wer sind denn die? Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt hat ja der Westen im Irak auch schon mit mehr Contractors als eigenen Soldaten, Amerika zum Beispiel, Krieg gemacht. So, die hatten dann alle ihre Relizenz zum Töten und haben da irgendwie fünfstellig im Monat Gehälter dafür gekriegt, dass sie am Ende eben nicht abgerechnet wurden, als der Präsident muss dann anrufen bei der Familie, wenn jemand gestorben ist, sondern es hat irgendwer von so einer Firma gestorben. Also da sind sie ein bisschen außen vor. Und das haben wir ja in Russland auch mit dieser Wagner-Gruppe, die da einfach rumrennt. Und wo halt Putin auch sagen kann, ja, sie sind nicht meine Leute. Das ist so ein Typ, der fühlt sich da halt so ein Warlord. Keine Ahnung, der macht da so ein paar Sachen. Aber das ist doch in deinem Interesse, Putin, oder?
Ich kenne das ja auch aus Hollywood-Filmen, die Expendables.
Zum Beispiel. Genau, diese ganzen Superheldenriegen, die es so gibt, die immer so beauftragt werden.
Ja, und die Expendables werden ja immer dahin geschickt, wo man jetzt nicht die normalen Soldaten hinschicken kann, ist ein bisschen blöd, wenn da was in die Medien kommt. Also nimmt man diese ausrangierten und in gewisser Weise kann man das dann auch bei der Gruppe Wagner oder bei anderen Soldnern erleben.
Genau, und dieses Phänomen greift Macron jetzt auf und unterstellt Putin oder ich unterstelle Macron, dass er so meinte, du wolltest es nicht, aber jetzt ist es einfach mal wie es ist. Das sind jetzt alles deine Soldaten. Ja, warum nicht mal ernsthaft über so einen Krieg reden? Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal ein paar sehr tolle Sachen zu sagen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennen.
Zusammen mit dem UK sind wir für die Sicherheit der Alli-en und natürlich spielen die Amerikaner einen wichtigen Teil in diesem Bereich. Ich wünsche, dass wir die nukleare Fähigkeit unserer Alli-en wiederholen und dass wir wieder einmal das bezeichnen.
So, ehrlicherweise muss man ja sagen, ja, Putin macht immer so eine Andeutung mit Atomwaffen, dann sagen alle, ja, der blöfft ja nur und so, lasst euch davon nicht verunsichern. Auf der anderen Seite, dieser Krieg findet überhaupt nur, nur innerhalb der ukrainischen Grenzen statt, weil alles andere mit atomarer Abschreckung und Bedrohung. Also spielt das eine zentrale Rolle, dass es Atomwaffen gibt. Wir haben es also auch mit einem und Atomwaffen haben wir ja, das ist ja sozusagen Stand der historischen Aufarbeitung, sind vor allem Waffen, mit denen man droht. Wenn man sie einsetzt, ist zu spät. Aber sie spielen auch schon eine Rolle, wenn man nur mit ihnen droht. In der Hinsicht führen wir auch schon einen Atomkrieg gerade, weil wir mit Atomwaffen drohen. Putin kann nicht Raketen auf die, auf polnisches Gebiet abschießen, weil dann greifen da Abschreppungsszenarien mit Atomwaffen involviert. Und dann macht er dieses Jahr, wir haben eine französische Abschreckung, aber wie wäre es eigentlich mal mit einer europäischen? Immer gleich aufgemacht.
Das ist wieder dieses Thema europäische Souveränität.
Genau, muss es eine NATO-Abschreckung sein? Nein, es kann ja eine europäische Abschreckung sein. Also da gibt es ja, da gab es ja auch noch ein ganz ausführliches Panel, da waren auch noch Clips, vielleicht kommen wir dazu.
Was auch dann bedeutet, dass man, wenn man das jetzt mal nachvollzieht, wir hätten eine europäische atomare Abschreckungsmöglichkeit, man ganz anders verhandeln könnte, mit Putin zum Beispiel. Und man könnte auch eigene Wege gehen, weil man sagt, ja wir sind ja auch abgesichert dadurch, wir müssen uns also nicht in diese Richtung abstimmen. Das heißt, wir könnten beispielsweise auch sagen, wir treten eher in Verhandlungen ein, was auch immer.
Also Macron hat das ja immer wieder vorgeschlagen, nicht nur in Sachen Atomwaffen, sondern Frankreich hat ja auch einen ständigen Sitz im Sicherheitsrat, dass man den europäisiert. Die Deutschen immer so, ja keine Ahnung, wir verlassen uns mal auf die Amerikaner, die haben ja auch so einen Sitz. Die haben das Angebot nie angenommen, bei den Atomwaffen auch.
Das merkt man ja jetzt auch in den Diskussionen derjenigen, die unglaublich für Aufrüstung sind, klammern dieses Thema auch meist aus. Wir hatten das bei AKK, da hat ja Macron gesagt, konfrontiert mit ihren Aussagen, ich halte das für eine historische Fehleinschätzung. Wir haben also alle diese Diskussionen. Und was wir aber in Deutschland erleben, ist eigentlich dieses America is back. Und da fragt ja dann ein Macron, ja, aber wie lang, was ist dann, wenn da der Republikaner gewinnt?
Wir springen mal nur für einen Clip aus dieser Rede von Macron raus. Ein Tag später wird über Atomwaffen oder über die europäischen Dimensionen und so weiter geredet und da sitzt Lars Klingbeil mit dem Plenum, der sich jetzt hier nochmal zu Macron äußert.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir hier in Deutschland diese Antwort von den USA haben, bei der Frage der Nuklear-Fürsicht und Nuklear-Verbrechen. Ich habe einige Fragen zu der französischen Seite. Wenn ich sehe, wie stark die Position des Präsidenten in Frankreich ist für eine Nuklear-Fürsicht, zum Beispiel, dann verstehe ich nicht, ob Macron diese Macht mit den europäischen Partnern oder den Sadeiris-A-Fraktionen zusammenführen möchte. Wir müssen auch in den nächsten Monaten in der europäischen strategischen Debatte darüber reden.
Das ist aber total, ich will nicht verlogen sagen, sondern so bescheuert. Auf der einen Seite, nein, also ich übersetze jetzt mal, was ich höre, was Klingmer sagt. Nein, wir wollen uns nicht von Frankreich abhängig machen. Wir sind das coolere Land in Europa. Wir können jetzt nicht nur weil die Atomwaffen haben und wir aus historischen Gründen nicht sagen, okay, dann sind wir jetzt in Sachen Atomwaffen von euch abhängig. Außerdem haben wir da eh noch 1000 Fragen am Macron. Wir können ja mal drüber reden, aber...
Will er die allen zur Verfügung stellen oder machen wir nochmal extra Waffen?
Genau, wir wollen nicht als Junior-Partner in so eine Verteidigungsunion gehen, in der die Franzosen, weil sie Atomwaffen haben, uns irgendwie sagen, was Sache ist. Gleichzeitig betonen wir aber, Macron, hier, er, die Amerikaner, das transatlantische Bündnis ist uns ganz wichtig. Wir haben eine nukleare Abschreckung im Sinne von nukleärer Teilhabe. Ja, wir lagern die auch auf deutschen Boden. Und ja, wir haben auch deutsche Soldaten, die deutsche Flugzeuge fliegen können, die dann auch diese Atomwaffen transportieren können. Also man unterwirft sich komplett dieser Amerikanischen. Wir machen das so, wir lagern die in Büschel, hier und so weiter. Alles ist geregelt.
Bei Frankreich lieber mal nicht.
Genau, bei Frankreich nee, das wäre ja blöd. Wir haben keine Lust da der kleine Bruder zu sein. Wir wollen Frankreich immer dominieren in allem. Wir können ja nicht im Wirtschaftskrieg die komplett übernehmen, also hier Krieg der Nation, dieses Buch über die Autobranche, wie man in Frankreich alles platt macht und gleichzeitig dann leider bei Atomwaffen so unterwirflich. Also das ist so verlogen, wie die SPD da an diese Sache rangeht. Also wirklich bescheuert. Okay, zurück zu Macron. Er betont hier nochmal, und zwar mit Bewusstsein, was klingt, weil er so zur transatlantischen Verpflichtung und Bündnissen überhaupt sagen, wie leicht wäre es doch mal so sinnvoll, eine europäische Dimension in Sachen Verteidigungsfähigkeit zu haben.
Ich denke an medium range rockets and missiles. In einem der neuesten NATO-Meetungen, die ich unterliegen habe, und Sie können erinnern, wie wichtig diese Waffen sind. Wir waren nicht hier involviert. Wir waren also eine geopolitische Minorität. Das muss enden.
Die europäische Dimension. Ich will jetzt mal einen Punkt machen, den habe ich schon ein paar Mal in privaten Gesprächen. Und der war immer lustig. Mal gucken, was unsere Hörer dazu sagen. Oder du? Also, wenn wir jetzt, ich habe mal Macron, der sagt einfach, Europa sollte sich selbst mal ernst nehmen in Sachen Verteidigung. Wir brauchen Amerika da nicht. Die Amerikaner machen viel Quatsch in Abu Ghraib und in Afghanistan, Irak und so. Da wollen wir gar nicht mit involviert sein. Wir finden es auch nicht so gut, dass da Quantanomo noch offen ist und lauter solche Sachen. Das kann man ja alles mal abschütteln und sagen, das ist dann Amerikas Sache. Wie in Europa regeln es anders. Wir verteidigen uns jetzt selbst. Und dann haben wir in Deutschland zwei Diskurse. Zum einen nukleare Teilhabe. Jetzt haben wir die amerikanischen Atomwaffen. Oder wir beteiligen uns an der Abträgungsfähigkeit der Franzosen oder vielleicht auch der Briten, die in Sachen Verteidigung sind ja immer noch mitten in Europa und sagen, okay, ein nukleare Schutzschirm über Europa.
Obwohl das mit Großbritannien nicht sein wird. Großbritannien ist näher an den USA herangerückt, wenn je.
Aber in Sachen Verteidigung gibt es immer noch sehr viel Arbeitsebene.
Es gibt Arbeitsebene, aber es gibt keine Ausrichtung zur Europa.
Also Macron macht in Deutschland das Angebot, wir nehmen euch unter unseren Atomwaffenschutzschirm. Plus, dass man natürlich mit Patriot und so weiter Verteidigung hat. Und dann gibt es in Deutschland parallel dazu, die Diskussion eine Wehrpflicht wieder einzuführen. Oder so einen Pflichtdienst, der auch eine militärische Komponente hat. Und dann, finde ich, muss man sich entscheiden. Denn klar ist ja, wenn man Leuten verpflichtend zur Bundeswehr holt, können die nur zur Landesverteidigung gedacht sein. Die fliegen jetzt nicht nach Mali oder so. Das müssen dann Berufssoldaten sein. Sondern es geht um Verteidigung auf deutschen Boden. Wenn man es jetzt wirklich ernst meint, muss man sich ja die Frage stellen, welche Gefahr droht denn Deutschland? Also droht wirklich in Deutschland auf deutschen Boden eine Auseinandersetzung. Das heißt, jetzt brauchen wir dich, damit du unser Land verteidigst.
Das ist so der Tenor von Tobias Rapp vom Spiegel, der sagt, ich hätte damals gar nicht verweigern sollen und jetzt bin ich zwar über 50, auch eigentlich unbrauchbar, wahrscheinlich mit einem nassen Handtuch totzuschlagen. Aber jetzt will ich noch mal.
Genau, weil die Opportunitätskosten dafür sind ja sehr hoch. Wir verweigern ja der deutschen Volkswirtschaft ein Jahr lang komplett ihren Nachwuchs, um das Szenario vorzubereiten. Dafür sollte es dann auch realistisch sein, also dass wirklich auf deutschem Boden was stattfindet. Und ich finde, jetzt muss man sich entscheiden, wird Deutschland entweder mit jungen deutschen Soldaten verteidigt oder mit Atomwaffen, aber nicht beides. Sondern man muss sich dann für einen Weg entscheiden.
Und das bedeutet dann einfach, wir haben eine Drohkulisse geschaffen und diese Drohkulisse ist so groß, dass schon keiner auf die Idee kommen wird, wie wir das erleben und wir haben sonst diese Waffen. Aber klar, es wird ja ohnehin nicht dazu jetzt kommen, dass wir einen Landkrieg jetzt erleben würden, sondern das würde ja einfach bedeuten, wenn es jetzt einen Übertritt gäbe seitens Russlands, wenn die jetzt sagen, Berlin würde uns auch interessieren, dann würde es ja diese Eskalation geben. Das ist ja genau das, was verhindert werden soll. Man kann natürlich dann fragen, will man über den Weg der Wehrpflicht eigentlich das Berufssoldatentum stärken und möchte dann bald haben, dass deutsche Soldaten nicht nur in Mali rumrennen, sondern vielleicht auch Taiwan verteidigen? Und sollte das in unserem Interesse sein, uns in all diese Konflikte da hineinzubegeben? Und wer möchte sich gerne dafür opfern? Ich finde, das ist alles eine ganz bedrohliche Lage. Also diese Opposition, die du aufdust, ist jetzt auch nicht gerade herrlich, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine ziemlich ehrlich geführte, wenn man in dieser Dichotomie einmal denkt. Denn beides zusammen würde ja tatsächlich keinen Sinn ergeben.
Ja, genau. Also beides macht keinen Sinn. Man kann sich für einen Weg entscheiden. Und das heißt aber auch ganz konkret, wenn jemand fordert, dass wir die Wehrpflicht wieder einführen, müssen wir dafür aus der nuklearen Teilhabe aussteigen und die Atomwaffen auf deutschem Boden rausräumen, weil wir uns dann dafür entschieden haben, sonst wäre es ja sinnlos, Berlin mit einem Maschinengewehr zu verteidigen, wenn wir gleichzeitig Atomwaffen haben, die wir dann nicht einsetzen, ist ja Quatsch. Oder, also das wäre dann sozusagen eine Argumentation für, es gibt ja viele, die sagen, wir wollen keine Atomwaffen, also Atomwaffen nein, dass man dann sagt, ja, aber dann Wehrpflicht oder wir sagen, wir haben Atomwaffen, aber die haben wir dann eben auch. Also nicht so ein deutsches, ja, ist ja nur eine Teilhabe. Nee, wir hätten dann wirklich eigene Atomwaffen. Also es sind deutsche Soldaten in deutschen Flugzeugen, die deutsche Atomwaffen fliegen, um zu vergelten, was irgendwo in Dresden passiert. Und ich schlage mich auf die Seite derer, die sagen Atomwaffen. Denn wenn Atomkrieg geführt wird, ist es egal. Also bleibt es bei einer Drohung. Und die Abstreckung ist dann so gewaltig, dass einfach immer klar ist, also dass man wirklich sieht, die Deutschen haben gar keine Soldaten, die können sich gar nicht verteidigen. Dem bleibt gar nichts anderes übrig, als Atomwaffen einzusetzen, wenn wir da einfallen. Weil das deren einziger Weg ist, sich also zumindest zu vergelten, wenn schon nicht verteidigen, dann wenigstens vergelten. Und das ist ja ein Abstreckungsszenario, das ich sehr überzeugend finde eigentlich für alle Aggressoren.
Ich überlege, ob ich aus Pragmatismus dem zustimmen könnte, denn es ist natürlich eine bestechende Logik, die du hier uns präsentiert.
Man kennt gleichzeitig um Kriegsdienst herum.
Ich bin ja dafür, dass man um den Kriegsdienst herumkommt und bin zugleich Pazifist und kann deshalb für Atomwaffen schwierig plädieren. Ich kann jetzt sagen, Gott sei Dank muss ich das ja nicht entscheiden, dann ziehe ich mich raus. Aber es ist natürlich noch mal die Frage zu stellen, gibt es dann überhaupt eine Bedrohung für Deutschland? Also wären jetzt Deutschland unbewaffnet und ohne Soldaten, würde man davon ausgehen können? Also plennen wir mal ganz kurz, weil das so erhitzt ist jetzt diese Putin-Diskussion aus, also muss ein Land sich verteidigen können? Also von welcher Weltordnung gehen wir dann immer aus? Und was ist das eigentlich für eine Perspektive? Wir sind ja beide noch jung genug, um noch einige Jahre hier aushalten zu müssen. Was ist das eigentlich für eine Perspektive, wenn wir immer nur Staaten als Gegner begreifen, mit denen man sich dann in irgendeine Pappsituation bewegen kann, damit das Schlimmste verhindert wird? Aber man ist ja nicht in dieser Idee einer gemeinschaftlichen Solidarität von Menschen oder von Menschheit, könnte man sagen. Und man hat aber zugleich so einen ganz starken Klimadiskurs, geht uns alle an und wir sind auch verantwortlich für bla bla bla. Das passt ja alles nicht so richtig zusammen. Dann gehen wir ja eigentlich von widerstreitenden Interessen, die zur Not militärisch ausgetragen werden, aus. Und das ist die Grundkonstellation, die die Weltgeschichte bislang durchzogen hat. Und das wird doch so von uns dann fortgesetzt durch die Maßnahmen, die wir ergreifen.
Deswegen Atomwaffen?
Das ist eine fatale Situation.
Atomwaffen heißt entweder der absolute Vernichtungskrieg oder gar kein Krieg.
Aber bei dir gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit, dass einfach gar kein Krieg, gar keine Waffen. Die Idee bei der Abrüstung, es gibt ja immer wieder Abrüstungsverträge und da geht es ja ganz primär um Atomwaffen, ist ja tatsächlich mit kleinen Schritten, die dann immer zu klein bleiben, zu einer Welt ohne Vernichtungswaffen dieser Art zugelangen.
Das halte ich für sehr unrealistisch. Wir werden auf die Atomwaffen nicht mehr verzichten.
Ich sehe da auch keine Bestrebungen. Ich finde diese Bestrebungen gut, aber ich sehe da nicht jetzt ein wirkliches Engagement.
Also man kann die Ausbreitung verhindern, die Deprofilerazione, wie es auch mal heißt. Steckt ja auch im Titel vieler Verträge drin. Aber die Atomwaffen sind erst mal da und dann sollten wir sie auch nutzen, im Sinne von nicht nutzen. Also abschreckend.
Also es ist jedenfalls eine sehr viel intelligentere Diskussion als jetzt auf die Idee zu kommen, ich habe meine Zeit damit verbracht, irgendwelche Artikel zu schreiben und glaube, dass ich mich jetzt noch mal heroisch irgendwie nützlich machen kann. Das glaube ich, die Leute sollten vielleicht doch mal gucken, ob sie mal eine Therapie machen.
So Macron wirft jetzt das wichtigste Thema überhaupt auf. Auch für Europa, aber es ist auch im Ukrainekrieg das wichtigste Thema. Wurde ja auch so thematisiert, also sowohl Lloyd, wie heißt er, der amerikanische Verteidigungsminister, als auch Austin, als auch Bisturus haben das ja betont. Wenn die Politiker zusammensitzen und über die Ukraine reden, geht es um Luftverteidigung. Und etwas unterbelichtet bleibt bei uns, dass es die Ukraine derzeit schafft, teilweise 100 Prozent aller Angriffsraketen in einer Nacht abzuschießen. Also dass einfach gar keine russische Rakete den Boden erreicht. Ich habe kürzlich, wo habe ich das gelesen? Eine sehr gute Berichterstattung von vor Ort. Na vielleicht fällt es mir gleich wieder ein. Macron betont hier, das brauchen wir auch in Europa ganz dringend oder würde ich auch sagen, das stimmt.
Und das auch mit einem mehr genauen Thema, den Bundeschef Scholz gerade erbracht hat, welches die Luftfeuerung hier auf dem europäischen Kontinent ist. Und ich denke, es war richtig, dass Präsident Scholz die Luftfeuerung aufgerufen hat. Wir sollten eine Konferenz mit Industrie-Repräsentativen haben, die alle, die hier Lösungen haben, aber auch von einem strategischen Sichtpunkt her, müssen wir das besonders von einem strategischen Sichtpunkt her kümmern.
Ja, wir brauchen einfach Air Defense. Wir wollen nicht, dass irgendwelche Raketen überraschungsmäßig irgendwie aufkreuzen. Alles andere kann man sehen. Flugzeuge, Panzer, bis so ein Panzer rübergefahren ist, hat man wahrscheinlich Gegenmaßnahmen getroffen haben. Aber so eine Rakete, die irgendwie nach Europa fliegt, warum nicht?
Aber besteht die Gefahr?
Keine Ahnung. Das ist ja die Frage. Aber Air Defense, also in der Ukraine spielt Air Defense gerade die Maßgäste.
Ja, das ist mir klar. Das würde ich ja auch nicht leugnen. Aber gehen wir also einfach von einer Konstellation aus, dass ich das nun mal so grundsätzlich abstecken will, für das Jahrhundert, in dem wir uns nun befinden, dass das eines sein wird, das von Kriegen durchzogen ist und von potenziellen Gefahren. Denn wir sind ja eine Generation, die Krieg in dem Sinne nicht erlebt hat. Klar, es gibt Afghanistan oder so. Und dann hat man auch vielleicht aus der Klasse oder so jemanden, der da im Einsatz war. Aber vielmehr ist es da noch nicht. Das heißt also, der Krieg ist nicht in dem Sinne eine bedrohliche Geschichte für uns geworden.
Mal sehen, Griechenland, Türkei.
Jetzt sind wir an einem Punkt angedanken, aber das ist doch eine ganz fatale Situation. Und ich will noch ein Argument gegen diese Atomwaffen bringen. Wir gehen jetzt gerade von diesen herrschenden politischen Verhältnissen aus und wir sehen da einen sehr besonnenen Scholz, der Gott sei Dank zaudert. Zaudern ist eigentlich etwas sehr Gutes. Dann überlegt man nämlich, was man tut und macht nicht irgendwelche Schnellschlüsse bei Twitter. Stell dir vor, besprochene Personen heute, die nicht zaudern, sondern die ganz genau wissen, was zu tun ist, wären am Hebel. Will man das? Wir haben das doch schon in den USA gesehen, dass Mark Milley mit Nancy Pelosi sich abstimmt. Was tun wir eigentlich, wenn Trump mal auf den roten Knopf drücken will?
Ja, das ist ja sowieso die ganzen militärischen Überlegungen überhaupt. Denen ist halt Politik vorgebaut. Dagegen kann man gar nichts machen. Es braucht ja auch vernünftige Politik. Grundlagen, für die der gegenwärtige Lauf der Dinge nicht selbst sorgen kann, im Sinne von festschreiben. Es muss immer alles fluide bleiben. Man muss sich immer flexibel anpassen können. An der einen Sicht braucht man immer ein lebendiges politisches System mit möglichst viel Teilhabe.
Du sagst das wunderschön. Ich möchte mir auch nicht zu sehr in die Karten blicken lassen, aber ich will es vielleicht so formulieren. Im Zuge des vergangenen Jahres ist mein Vertrauen in die Vernunft der Politiker, der Medien und generell der Gesellschaft nicht unbedingt gestiegen.
Also in der DDR ging ja die...
Wie gesagt, ich nehme immer noch Heiratsangebote aus der Schweiz gerne an.
In der DDR ging ja die Ertüchtigung aller Nachwuchskräfte für Wehrtätigkeiten in der Schule einher mit politischer Indoktrination. Vielleicht sollten wir jede Diskussion zum Thema kann nicht der junge Mensch auch mal was für den Staat tun, Klammer auf, sich an der Waffe ausbilden lassen, muss auch einhergehen mit einer politischen Bildung, die im Sinne des Problems, das du jetzt aufgeworfen hast, das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöder, dass wir eine Bundeswehr haben, die die ganze Zeit immer wieder mit Rechtsradikalität und irgendwelchen Suborganisationen aufhält, die sich so auf eigene Faust und dann wird Lauterbach entführt und der deutsche Staat übernommen. Das müsste man dann mal ernsthaft und anders diskutieren im Lichte dieser Entwicklung. Und dann wirft Macron natürlich das große Thema auf.
Aber wir müssen uns vorbereitet sein und die Konditionen für diese Art und Weise kreieren. Sagen wir in Asien, im Inneren Süden, im Mittelfen, in Lateinamerika und Afrika. Wir müssen in Kontakt mit unseren Partnern in diesen Regionen sein, die vielleicht nicht alle unsere Wünsche teilen, die ich gerade ausgedacht habe. Wir müssen diese Wünsche hören. Wir müssen in diesen Ländern und in diesen Regionen hören. Und zusammen mit diesen Ländern, mit diesen Regionen müssen wir zusammen steigen, die Druck auf Russland erwerben und eine lange Weile in der Zeit schaffen. Ich will die G20 und die G7 anrufen, uns zu stehen, ein Koalitionspartner zu schaffen, das Süd und Norden, um Solidarität auf der internationalen.
Um die Hilfe der Gesundheit, der Bildung, der Kampf der Futterstärkheit und die Bedeutung für rückgrößere Länder zu schaffen. Ihnen betrübt das Bild, das man abgibt im globalen Süden. Und klar, er hat ja selber als Land so eine große Kolonialgeschichte. Auf der anderen Seite markiert er eben diesen Zeitpunkt. Wir können uns diese Verlogenheit jetzt nicht mehr länger leisten. Also wir können nicht 50 Sklaven für uns arbeiten lassen und gleichzeitig war jede Investitionsentscheidung immer nur mit irgendeinem Katalog an und so weiter verbinden. Und hier hat er schon freigesprochen, sich dem Plenum zugewandt. Das macht er dann in der Fragerunde natürlich erst recht. Ihm werden die Fragen zugeworfen. Auch da äußert er sich nochmal zum erschütternden Bild des globalen Südens auf uns.
Wir hatten ein wunderbares Sommit.
Wir haben sie letztes Jahr noch am Stich gelassen. Und jetzt wundern wir uns, dass sie nicht unserer Linie gegen Putin folgen. Kein Wunder. Also in der Ansicht ein sehr ehrlicher Beitrag. Und während er oben schon die Dialogbereitschaft des Westens anmahnte, zumindest die Gelegenheiten nutzen, wenn sie sich auf russischer Seite bieten, hat er hier noch mal allen widersprochen, die jetzt irgendwie kommen mit Na, mit Putin fanden wir eh nicht. Wir warten auf den Nachfolger und so.
Let's be clear, I don't believe one sec in a regime change. And when I hear a lot of people advocating for a regime change, I would just ask them for which change. Who is your leader? And we experienced several times during the past decade, a lot of regime change in a lot of countries. It's total failure. So just you have this regime with its obsessions, these people. And I think the question is how to twist and create an imperfect balance, allowing them to present something sustainable for Russia itself. At the end of the day, it will be something like that. It's too early to formulate it. Now the question is how to resist, how to help the Ukrainians to make on the ground something which will force Russia to come back at the table at the conditions of Ukraine. I think in the back of their mind, this regime, these people will have the same dream. The question is how to make the new normal acceptable for them and sustainable for all of us. They are quite complicated. Definitely not the right time to formulate them. But we have to work on that.
Perfekter Antwort. Wäre er ein deutscher Politiker, würde er in einer Talkshow sitzen und dies sagen, wäre die Hölle los. Aber er hat natürlich absolut recht mit dem, was er dort formuliert. Die Geografie ist nicht zu ändern. Regime-Change, wer soll da als nächstes kommen? Wir hören immer mal wieder so ganz irre Stimmen hinten aus dem Office da von Putin, wer ihnen da noch so alles umgibt. Und es gab ja tatsächlich irgendwie so in Russland Stimmen, die sagten, ja, aber wenn doch Biden in der Ukraine war, da hätte doch Putin den mal abschließen können oder so. Also da sieht man, was da für Leute im Hintergrund sind.
Hat man auch bei Baerbock schon. Baerbock war ja im Kriegsgebiet im Osten, da hat man sich auch gefragt, wieso haben wir sie nicht einfach getötet? Wir wussten doch, dass sie da ist.
Und da sieht man dann, dass diese Frage absolut berechtigt ist, wer ist dann der nächste, der dort regieren würde?
Also Macron hat hier ausdrücklich gesagt, ich will es nochmal in unserer deutschen Sprache sagen, eine imperfekte Balance muss gefunden werden, die wir nicht gut finden werden, weil auch die Russen mit Zugeständnissen, die wir ihnen geben, nach Hause gehen, um dort zu präsentieren, was wir dann erst mal als mittelbar bis dauerhaft als Realität anerkennen müssen. Mit diesem hat er dann sehr grinsend am Ende, wir können darüber noch nicht öffentlich reden, aber es gibt schon so ein paar Ideen. Also mal sehen, das würde mit dem deutschen Publikum noch lange zu tun haben. Erst mal muss dieses Interesse auch runtergefahren werden in Deutschland. Also das ist ja, alle diskutieren immer stundenlang darüber. Und ich frage mich dann auch mal, wohin führt so viele Gespräche? Also das 20 Minuten von 30 Minuten Abendnachrichten zum Thema, dann die ganzen Talkshows. Vorher hieß es ja immer, ja, wenn viel politisch diskutiert wird, öffentlich, dann kommt auch eine qualitativ hochwertige Meinung darum. Und dann habe ich den österreichischen Wahlkampf gesehen, wo ja vor jeder Bundestagswahl und dann der anschließenden Kanzlerwahl mindestens 50 Duelle stattfinden. Duelle, Trielle, jeder trifft jeden und so in jedem Sender. Alle stehen sich quasi auf den Füßen. Und sind wir wirklich der Meinung, Merkel hat es falsch gemacht, indem sie nur ein Duell zugestanden hat und sich dann raushielt. Weil in Österreich hat man halt eine zweidrittelrechtsnationale Mehrheit gehabt nach 50 Fernsehduellen. Gut, dass man darüber gesprochen hat. Genau, gut, dass man darüber gesprochen hat. Und ja, da muss man ernsthaft drüber nachdenken, ob diese intensive, extensive mediale Thematisierung überhaupt zu irgendwas bringt.
Das ist definitiv so, dass es der deutschen Demokratie wahnsinnig viel besser geben würde, wenn es keine Talkshows gäbe. Wenn es diese Sendungen nicht geben würde und man würde stattdessen sagen so, wir berichten jetzt zwei Stunden von der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz oder wir zeigen irgendwas ganz anderes, wegen mir auch André Rieu in Macht. Ich wäre dafür, ich wäre dafür, dass man, ich würde sofort, wenn ich, wenn ich an der Macht wäre, würde ich sofort dafür sorgen, dass eh nochmal eine Talkshow gezeigt wird im deutschen Fernsehen, lieber jeden Abend André Rieu kommt.
Das habe ich gerade Friedhof gesagt, weil in Deutschland heißt der Friedhof der Todesplatz. Dort ist es aber der Maastrichter Freiheitsplatz oder sowas, dieser zentrale große. Klingt nur so in Deutsch lustig. Friedhof, hier auf dem Friedhof. Letzter Clip zu Macron. Klingbeil antwortet aus dieser Runde tagsdrauf und so weiter. Wir haben ja eben schon mal gehört, wie er da das transatlantische Bündnis noch mal. Es ist sozusagen beispielhaft für Macron, redet sich um Kopf und Kragen, stellt alle Themen in den Raum, blendet alle Dimensionen einmal ein und dann kommt die deutsche Antwort.
Wie ich vorhin erwähnt habe, ist die Voraussetzung eines der wichtigsten Themen. Es ist sehr gut, dass Macron hier ein paar Proposale auf der Tafel gelegt hat. In dieser Konferenz. Olaf Scholz hat ein paar Proposale auf der Tafel gelegt. Jetzt müssen wir eine gemeinsame Strategie und eine gemeinsame Art und Weise finden.
Vielen Dank nochmal Macron, dass du viele Themen hier an der Tafel geputtert hast. Mehr gibt es da irgendwie nicht zu sagen. Gut, wir durchstreiten mal kurz diese Diskussion zum globalen Süden, nur um so ein paar Punkte zu machen. Es wird gar nicht viel zu diskutieren sein. Christoph Häusgen, wie gesagt, tags drauf.
Wenn wir sehen, wie die internationale regelswerte Ordnung, der UN-Kartell, die Universaler Deklaration der Menschenrechte unter Angriff sind, müssen wir sehen, wie wir sie befinden. Wir müssen für die Munich Security Conference für viele Jahre verlassen. Für uns ist es sehr wichtig, dass wir die Familie der Munich Security Conference verlassen. Wir haben hier die größten Anträge von Repräsentativen von Lateinamerika, Afrika und Asien in der Munich Security Conference.
Man sieht einen leeren Saal. Alle hängen noch beim Frühstück rum.
Aber das ist das wichtigste Panel.
Und das ist das wichtigste Panel. Und ist ja auch ganz überzeugt. Er sagt es nicht im Anfang, wir uns auch am Ende nachher noch malen.
In this room yesterday we have been discussing between Europeans, Europeans and Americans. We have been discussing and we have been preoccupied with Russia's war in Ukraine. It's it's effect on on Europe and beyond. But we sometimes when we are so fixed, focused on on this conflict, we forget about where how the situation in other countries are.
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Beschreibung. Wir sind so fixed, focused an unsere eigenen Sachen, dass wir die anderen nur brauchen, um unsere Probleme zu lösen.
Und wenn die das dann nicht tun, dann sind wir denen böse.
Genau, und wenn die mal eigene Probleme haben, ja, ist doch nur ein Krieg im Sudan, ist doch nicht entscheidend. Die gucken dann auf Europa, ist da nur ein Krieg in Europa. Und wir so, nee, ist ein Weltkrieg.
Ich finde es ja erstaunlich. Wir haben zum einen einen Diskurs darüber, wir müssen unseren Blick dekolonialisieren. Das ist gerade so in der Kunsttheaterszene um Wog. Wir erleben, dass ständig irgendwelche Kunstwerke, die geraubt worden sind, zurückgegeben werden an die entsprechenden Länder. Man will die koloniale Schuld abtragen. Aber der aktuelle Kolonialismus oder unser kolonialer Blick oder unser Blick, den wir nicht dekolonialisieren, weil wir glauben, dass das jetzt der allerwichtigste Konflikt ist und alles andere zählt nicht und soll sich dem unterwerfen, das wenden wir merkwürdigerweise nicht an.
Genau, sowas findet dann einfach nicht statt. Und da macht sich Heusgen jetzt hier so ein bisschen verdient. Er hat zusammengesucht, zum einen Franschia Francia Marques, die Vizepräsidentin Kolumbiens, Kolumbien, also vor allem durch diese Drogenkriege, große Bürgerkriegsausseinandersetzungen, über viele Generationen hinweg, inklusive Friedensschlüssen und so jetzt in der jüngsten Vergangenheit. Und sie betont mal was aus dieser südlichen, wenn wir mit diesem Global South in Ernst nehmen, was aus dieser von außen nach Europa hereingetragenen Sicht wichtig ist.
Heute in Lateinamerika, in Brasilien, in Kolumbien, versuchen wir, das Amazon-Wild zu schützen, das die Lunge der Welt ist und das die Balance behält. Das ist einer der Herausforderungen, die wir in unserem Regierung betreiben. Wir sind ein alternativer Regierung, wir sind ein Grasthofsverwaltungsverwaltungs- Wir wollen nicht weiter darüber reden, wer der Winn oder der Verlänger des Krieges ist.
So, wir brauchen eine Weltordnung fürs Leben. Und nein, ich rede mit Ihnen nicht über den Ukraine-Krieg im Sinne von ja, Putin hat angefangen, ja, die Ukraine haben ein Selbstverteidigungsrecht. Irgendwer wird gewinnen, irgendwer wird verlieren oder sowas. Es ist ein brutaler Angriffsieg, sondern ja, es ist halt ein Krieg. So und irgendwann werden auch Sie vergessen, wer hier angefangen hat. Afghanistan ging auch 20 Jahre. Wer sagt denn, dass das jetzt in der Ukraine nicht ein paar Jahre geht und so? Irgendwann vergisst man einfach, was genau im Detail und so weiter, dann sieht man nur noch die einen und die anderen, schlägt sich auf eine Seite. Und diese Beobachtung von Krieg aus südamerikanischer und afrikanischer Richtung ist hier wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Wir hören nochmal sie.
Jeder einzelne Familie in Kolumbien hat in diesem Krieg verloren. Ich bin 41 und habe in meinem Leben in diesem Armkampf verwendet.
Wir haben Millionen von Töchtern gehabt.
Das bedeutet nicht Impunität.
Wir hatten nur Mühe, Hunger, Verwaltungen.
Und du hattest ja eben diese Zahl gesagt, 300.000 Tote jetzt schon in dem Krieg. Und das kann man ja dann mal sehen, wie viele Menschen da noch so dranhängen. Also das sind ja alles vorwiegend junge Männer, die haben Familien, die haben vielleicht auch schon Ehepartner, was auch immer. Und die haben Freunde und die haben jetzt alle auch jemanden verloren. Also wenn wir das jetzt mal hochrechnen, also wie viele Leute schon betroffen sind jetzt, also davon abgesehen, dass die alle die ganze Zeit betroffen sind von dem Krieg, aber so wirklich dem Ganzen emotional. Ich habe jetzt einen direkten Verlust. Und wenn wir das mal vergleichen mit unserem Diskurs über Corona, wo wir uns geschützt haben, damit wir nicht Menschen verlieren, die uns nahestehen. Und hier werden Menschen wirklich aus dem Leben gerissen, junge Menschen ja hier, also nicht vulnerable Alte, die vor allem von Corona betroffen waren, sondern junge Menschen aus dem Leben gerissen sind tot. Und dann sieht man, was eigentlich da Krieg bedeutet. Und sie spricht natürlich aus einer Erfahrungswelt heraus, wo ihr das ganz klar ist, um wie sehr das Land dadurch traumatisiert ist und was das eigentlich bedeutet. Deswegen würde ich ja sagen, sind diese ganzen Diskurse, die wir da im Moment haben, vom Heroischen und so, diese Leute sollten sich immer mit einer solchen Person mal zusammensetzen und mal erfahren, was heroisch war und was nicht.
Genau. Und sie legt ja auch diesen Fokus auf die Opfer, sollten uns mal um die Opfer kümmern. Das machen wir ja gar nicht. Wir überlegen uns ja ganz heroisch, klar schicken wir ein Panzer, damit die denen dann die Front fahren. Also fährt dann Katrin Eigendorf hinterher und interviewt dann so eine Haubitzensteuerer und fragt ihnen, sind sie denn auch sehr dankbar an den Deutschen, dass sie das geschickt haben? Ja, wir können jetzt viel besser schießen. Und so verstrickt sich dann noch in so Sachen, das hat Friedrich Kuiperbusch in so 5 Minuten mal kurz gezeigt, wie Katrin Eigendorf so ein Typ interviewt und dann steht einfach in der Bauchbinde, wie der heißt. Einen Tag später taucht er einfach in einem anderen öffentlich-rechtlichen deutschen Programm auf mit einem ganz anderen Bauchbinde, der heißt ganz anders und trägt wieder den Dank für die Deutschen vor.
Wir wollen das ja nicht hören. Ich meine, es gab einen Journalisten, mir fällt gerade der Name nicht ein, der das gemacht hat, war mir auch unbekannt, vom Deutschlandfunk. Der hatte sich gedacht, wir haben diese Panzerdiskussion, wir interviewen einen Wehrmachtsoldaten, der in so einem Panzer gefahren ist. Dann war die Reaktion darauf auf Twitter, wir interviewen jetzt Nazis, was in der Ukraine zu tun ist. Darum ging es überhaupt nicht in dem Beitrag. Dieser Mann war auch nicht ein Nazi, mit 18 ist er dort in die Panzer reingekommen. Zwangserpflichtet worden, Panzer zu verreihen. Ja, 1944 nämlich. Dann sagte nachher noch erklärend dieser Journalist auf Twitter, was er von Putin hält und Russland. Ich kann sagen, er ist da naiv. Der Mann ist 94 oder 96 und hat ein stark Marxistisch-Leninistisches Weltbild. Also wir haben es hier nicht immer noch fest an das Nazitum Glaubenden zu tun. Aber worum es eigentlich in diesem Beitrag ging, war, dass wir hier einen Mann gesucht haben, also einen Zeitzeugen, der kurz beschrieben hat, wie ist es eigentlich, in so einem Panzer zu liegen? Und was bedeutet das eigentlich? Und wie sieht das aus, wenn man getroffen wird und man stirbt in einem solchen Panzer? Das schildert er in wenigen Worten sehr, sehr bildhaft. Und wenn eine solche Diskussion aber nicht geführt werden kann, weil sofort alle hyperventilieren, dann sieht man einfach, die Leute wollen zum einen die ganze Zeit über den Krieg reden, aber sie wollen eigentlich vom Krieg nichts sehen, nichts wissen.
Da der gleiche Journalist auch über Habermas, Yamata und so weiter. Ich finde auch, man muss sich irgendwann fragen, wenn man Habermannstexte ablehnt, wenn man in deutscher Sprache vorgetragene impressionistische Schilderungen, wie es ist, in einer komischen Wanne von so einem Panzer zu liegen und wissend, ich fahre gerade eine riesige Zielscheibe durch ein Kriegsgebiet.
Und da wird ihm vorgeworfen, er hätte da in diesem Interview, dass eine Stunde dann geht und wird in fünf Minuten oder drei Tagen nicht gesagt, dass sie damals die Bösen waren, die Nazis. Ja klar.
Ja, also irgendwann muss man seine Maßstäbe wirklich nochmal hinterfragen. Man kann nicht die ganze Zeit so auf dieser Linie bleiben.
Und der Deutschlandfunk hat nicht versucht, den zweiten Weltkrieg nochmal umzuschreiben.
Die nächste Gesprächspartnerin ist hier nach Marquez Sara Kugongelva Amadila. Sie ist die Premierministerin von Namibia, auch einem gebeutelten Land. Und das aber jetzt gerade sehr unter Klima leitet. Und sich als eins der recht modernen Länder dort sieht, wahrscheinlich zurecht. Robert Habeck war kürzlich da. Er hat auch berichtet auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz um ein Solarwasserstoff, also die wollen Hydrolyse machen und nutzen dafür Solarenergie. Und diese Anlage, die sie bauen, produziert perspektivisch so viel Strom, dass sie ihr BIP damit einmal verdoppeln. Also die wollen so viel Strom erzeugen und exportieren, dass sie ihr ganzes Land, was die Wirtschaftskraft angeht, einmal verdoppeln. Also hoch interessant. Und warum machen die das? Und warum brauchen die da europäische Partner? Klar, aus eigener Kraft schafft man das nicht. Da braucht man dann sowohl Investitionen als auch ein paar technische Know-Hows und Gerätschaften und so weiter. Also gibt es diesen Versuch, das jetzt mit Deutschland zusammen zu machen. So eine Art Partnerschaft, wie ich es auch häufiger mal betont habe, dass man sich so ein Land sucht, Deutschland und Namibia. Ich würde ja sagen Nigeria, aber jetzt nimmt man sich Namibia hier in diesem Fall und baut an diesen Projekten. Und das kann eine Win-win-win-Situation für alle sein, insbesondere für Namibia, denn dort quält man sich jetzt nun wirklich sehr mit Klimawandelfolgen.
Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Verhältnis, ich muss sagen, für Namibia, wie ich sehe, ist es für Deutschland und für Europa generell. Und wir erleben alle Sorten der klimaeinhalten Schäden.
Es ist ein bisschen wie in Pakistan, da kommt eine Flut und direkt danach ist Dürre. Also da werden erst die Felder überflutet und danach wächst nichts mehr, weil einfach gar kein Regen mehr fällt und dort hat man es einfach gleichzeitig. Die Hälfte des Landes steht unter Wasser und die andere Hälfte hat halt Dürre und deswegen jetzt diese große Energiepartnerschaft hoffentlich auf Augenhöhe. Man weiß ja mal nicht, sie formuliert den Wunsch. So Namibia sieht sich also gerade in Pionier Positionen, um mit Deutschland auf Augenhöhe ein für alle und dann auch exportrechtiges Business aufzuziehen. Ein Modell für die Welt hat sie betont. Wir müssen also jetzt auch so ein bisschen hoffen, dass Habeck das nicht komplett in den Sand setzt, weil irgendwelche Christian Lindner Investoren hier wieder privater Rendite daraus ziehen wollen und deutsche Energiekonzerne auch nochmal eigene Ideen haben. Zum Beispiel, und man sich an den namibianischen Anteil da nochmal bereichert, statt das auch für die dort zum Erfolgsprojekt machen zu lassen. Und jetzt redet sie aus namibianischer Sicht auch über Krieg. Wir haben es ja eben schon von der Marquez gehört. Jeder im Land war betroffen. Jeder kennt irgendwen. Und am Ende geht es darum, sich erstmal um die Opfer zu kümmern, grundsätzlich Argumente fürs Leben zu formulieren, Gewalt zurückzudrängen und sich nicht ewig mit den Fragen der politischen Dimensionen, die wir uns halt hier die ganze Zeit stellen. Und das ist bei ihr auch sehr trifftig.
Unsere Krieg für nationale Liberation, die sehr blöd und betrachtet war, hat mit einem besiedelten Settlement endet. Und heute ist Namibia als einer der ruhigsten, stabilsten Länder in Afrika gehalten. Wir haben Genocide durchgeführt, wir haben ein System durchgeführt, in dem Afrikaner getroffen wurden, wir haben eine Situation durchgeführt, in der 80% der ganze Tribe ausgewischt wurde. Und das ist jetzt, warum wir heute hoffen, dass wir zusammen mit Ländern mit denen wir heute Gegner sind, aber heute Partner sind, mit denen wir in den frühen Zukunft für alle unsere Länder arbeiten. Wie ich es gesagt habe, ist unser Fokus auf die Lösung des Problems. Es geht nicht um die Veränderung von Blödsinn.
Das ist so wichtig. Wir befassen uns nicht mehr mit Schuldfragen. Alle wissen, wer angefangen hat. Alle wissen, wer schuld ist. Wir müssen es nicht mehr thematisieren. Wir können uns jetzt mit der Problemlösung befassen. Und wie wir bei Macron gehört haben, wenn die Problemlösung ist, Putin muss weg. Also dann hat man noch zehn Jahre Krieg jetzt vor sich. Wenn man die kolumbianische Problemlage, nämlich wir schaffen jetzt eine Welteordnung fürs Leben, das bedeutet wir beschützen Menschen, wir beschützen den Urwald usw. Und jeder, der hier nicht mit beschützt oder die Sachen gefährdet, der wird dann halt politisch angegangen. Das ist ja ein ganz anderer Fokus, als wir den in Deutschland. Wenn immer erst mal dieses Bekenntnis, wir können gerne über den Krieg reden, aber erst mal sagen wir alle noch mal, wer schuld ist. Und das ist genau dieses Shifting Blame, was man als erstes ausradieren muss. Ich stelle mir so vor, wie die einfach da sitzen, jetzt diese Anfragen aus Europa bekommen und sagen, ja, aber wir hatten ja auch Krieg, das hat euch nicht interessiert. Und jetzt habt ihr ja Krieg und wir sitzen halt hier und können euch so Tipps geben und so weiter, dass sie dann wirklich so sagen, ja, ihr seid jetzt gerade auf Stufe 1 von 15. Wir haben das auch als sehr grausame Lehre alles lernen müssen, da dann drüber zu stehen. Sachen to put it away, seht ihr richtig, die Handbewegung noch gemacht. Manche Sachen muss man einfach beiseiteschieben, Schuldfragen zum Beispiel. Und dann ist bei, also all diese Wogen, die jetzt immer, wie man den Krieg mit Putin gegen Putin führt, wissen ja ganz genau aus ihren eigenen und anderen Podcasts, dass in der elementaren sozialen Beziehungsgestaltung, wenn sie therapeutisch notwendig wird, Schuldfragen keine Rolle spielen dürfen. So, aber diese Übertragungsleistung auf die Politik, ne, erst mal muss das Bekenntnis her. Und so, da wird er, also diese ganzen Fehler. Man kann jetzt sozusagen auf 100 Jahre afrikanische Fehlerkultur gucken und was man daraus lernte. Und jetzt machen wir das alles nochmal durch. Es ist schon wirklich wahnsinnig düster und traurig, das zu sehen.
Aber das ist die interessante andere Perspektive, die reinkommt. Also das ist nicht eine, die einfach sagt, naja, rühren wir mal alles zusammen. Sondern es ist eigentlich eine ganz andere Perspektive, von der aus man dann auf Europa blicken kann. Also man kann sich wirklich mal mit dieser Perspektive aus Europa heraus bewegen. Ich will auch im Salon einen Text vorstellen, warum afrikanische Staaten sich gerade so zögerlich verhalten, bei der Vorurteilung von Putins Krieg. Und dann merkt man schon, dass diese Perspektive einen weiterhelfen kann, wenn es einem darum geht, Frieden zu finden, im Sinne von wir müssen jetzt aufhören, dass sich bekämpft wird, das Sterben muss aufhören. Und das ist ja erst mal das humanitäre Gebot, das an erster Stelle stehen muss, so wie sie das jetzt auch gerade skizziert hat.
Ja, wir haben ja Grappers Anfänge gelesen mit dem Wahnsinnsargument. Die europäische Aufklärung war eigentlich ein Kulturimport aus den kolonial mächtig übernommenen Staaten. Also all die Ideen, die wir hier in Deutschland oder in Europa immer so als das ist unser Aufklärungsmoment, der Augenaufschlag der europäischen Kultur, war da schon präsent. Und wir haben es dann halt so importiert und einmal durchlebt. Und das können wir jetzt wieder machen, dass wir einfach ausschwärmen in diese afrikanischen Länder, die genau wissen, was ein 30-jähriger, 40-jähriger, 100-jähriger Bürgerkrieg ist oder sowas. Und dann einfach mal zuhören, wie die das so sehen, was die uns für Tipps geben und das dann wieder importieren. Und dann so eine Art, wie sie das eben meinte, hier Weltordnung fürs Leben formulieren, in der man dann auch sozusagen alle Klimawandelsdiskussionen auch fruchtbar macht für und so verhalten wir uns nicht nur der Natur gegenüber, sondern auch unserer Kultur gegenüber, unseren Mitmenschen gegenüber und so, dass man da mal so ein paar Anschlussdinger findet. Heusgen jedenfalls, der das hier organisiert hat, betont dann nochmal zum Ausklang.
Wie ich gesagt habe am Anfang, für mich war das der wichtigste Panel der Munich-Sicherheitskonferenz, weil wir wollen genau das tun, was du gesagt hast, Herr Präsident, wir wollen diese Sorgen ernst nehmen, die du für uns angehen möchtest, und wir müssen zusammenbleiben. So, danke, dass du da bist.
So, und wir hören nur ganz kurz bei Habeck rein, der ja auch eine Rede hielt zum Thema. Ich war in Namibia, ich habe da diese große Wasserhydrolyseanlage gesehen und so. Das ist das Projekt, was wir jetzt angehen mit denen auf Augenhöhe. Es ist in unserem Interesse, es ist in deren Interesse. Und dieser Vorschlag, wir brauchen jetzt diese neue Globalisierung auf Augenhöhe. Und da, während man das hört, muss man dran denken, wenn wir da in afrikanischen Ländern aufschlagen, bringen wir halt Geschichte mit. Die müssen uns erstmal vertrauen. Wir müssen eigentlich erstmal vor Leistung gehen und so. Aber zumindest ist der Anspruch formuliert.
Ich bin eigentlich nicht so ein Staatsmann im Anzug, sondern bin eigentlich jemand, der gleich mit der Funktionsjacke nochmal einen Baum umarmen geht.
Also Humann, Mary und Niklas werden demnächst einen Podcast zum Thema der Anzug und der Dresscode veröffentlichen. Und soweit ich aus Gesprächen rund um dieses Gespräch gehört oder beigetragen hab, ist es glaube ich ein wichtiger Punkt nochmal zu sagen, es gibt einen Dresscode, an den hält man sich. Der heißt Schulterpolster, Kragen, Krawatte. Darüber hinaus zeigt man aber, dass man Robert Habeck ist. Und ich glaube, das sehen wir hier vorgeführt.
Und das heißt einfach, dass der Kragen so ein bisschen da nicht so ordentlich verpackt ist.
Das ist die Person zum Dresscode. Er hält sich an alle Dresscodes, das kann man sagen.
Ja, das ist so wie bei Bernie Sanders, er hat auch einen Anzug an. Genau. Das ist natürlich ein Ding, dass man ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit, das er da trägt.
Genau. Es gibt die Kür und also das ist ein Pflichtprogramm und dann halt die Kür für die einen und den Robert Habeck für den anderen.
Ja, vielleicht doch auch da mal sich von Macron beraten lassen, nicht nur in Sachen Außenpolitik.
Schließen wir die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz ab mit Beobachtungen von zwei Themen. Was ist mit der Atombombe und was ist mit China? Passt ja beides zusammen. Bei dem Atomwaffen-Panel saß der britische, ist es der Verteidigungsminister Wallace, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, jedenfalls ein sehr wichtiger. Von amerikanischer Seite niemand aus der Regierung, aber wir kriegen die amerikanische Sicht geboten. Und von China aus eine ehemalige Generälin, die aber jetzt in so einem universitären Think-Tank-Kontext irgendwie arbeitet. Und welche Sicht auf Atomwaffen-Nichteinsatz haben die Länder, die Atomwaffen haben? Das ist ganz interessant hier. Wir gehen mal bei der britischen Sicht.
Ich bin unter keinem Verständnis, die Nuklear-Tabu nach 1945 zu verwendet zu haben, ist absolut paramant. Man kann es nicht ein wenig verwenden und dann erwarten, dass die Welt wieder normal wird.
Also die nukleare Absteckung geht mit dem nuklearen Tabu einher. Man kann Atomwaffen nicht ein bisschen einsetzen, sondern wenn sie eingesetzt werden, werden sie eingesetzt. Diese Idee, keine Ahnung, die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hat ja auch so eine Umfrage gemacht und dann haben irgendwie 60 Prozent der Ukrainer gesagt, sie würden auch nach einem Atomangriff weiter kämpfen. Und ich denke, okay, was für ein Szenario ist das hier gerade, das uns dargeboten werden soll? Die amerikanische Sicht.
Are we doing enough? We are doing much more than is publicly known to assemble a coherent immediate prompt forceful NATO response and global response. Should Putin cross that God willing uncrossable line? And I'll agree with Ben that the contribution being made by China and India in repeatedly publicly calling out Putin and saying, you should not be threatening the use of nuclear weapons whether tactical or strategic, is an important contribution.
Man freut sich, dass die Inder und vor allem die Chinesen immer wieder sagen, wir werden keine Atomwaffen eingesetzt, denn es gibt kein Szenario, in dem nur ein Land Atomwaffen einsetzt. Jedes Land, das Atomwaffen einsetzt, muss damit rechnen, dass auch gegen es Atomwaffen eingesetzt werden.
den chinesischen Präsident Xi Jinping, in seiner Sitzung mit Präsident Putin, mit Chancellor Scholz und mit Präsident Biden, und es hat funktioniert. Und persönlich denke ich nicht, dass der Militärverlust auf dem Waffen von Nuklearen den Kosten der 80 Jahre Nuklear-Tabu ausbreiten kann.
Das wäre ausformuliert die Prämisse aufgrund der du eben deine Überlegungen angestellt hast, warum Europa Atomwaffen braucht und braucht aber dann sonst nichts mehr.
Genau.
Eigentlich dann auch sonst gar nichts mehr, das ganze Gedöns, was man sonst noch hat. Das ist ja Quatsch.
Hier findet kein Krieg statt, außer ein Atomkrieg. Und der findet dann aber überall statt, also dann nicht mal viel mit Deutschland zu tun, sondern die Vergeltung ist dann da. Dieses Statement von ihr ist ganz interessant, weil ja gerade sehr viele Rätseln man kriegt zu Botschaften hier. Und es steht bei Spiegel Online irgendwie, ja die Chinesen distanzieren sich von Putin. Und gleichzeitig liest man aber in der amerikanischen Medien genau das Gegenteil und alle Rätsel. Und niemand weiß so richtig, was jetzt Sache ist. Aber zumindest in Sachen Atomwaffen würde ich sagen, würde sie jetzt nicht so öffentlich auftreten, wenn da irgendwie anders gedacht würde. Also diese Botschaft der Chinesen an die Russen, es werden keine Atomwaffen eingesetzt, scheint wohl dauerhaft und gleich zu sein.
Ich will das nochmal gerade Rahmen mit dieser globalen Perspektive, über die wir vorher gesprochen haben. Wir haben es jetzt mit Ländern zu tun wie Indien, China, mit lateinamerikanischen Ländern, mit afrikanischen Ländern, die jetzt gerade einen Aufstieg erleben oder bald erleben werden. Wir haben es also mit Ländern zu tun, in denen Armut sinkt, in denen Armut abnimmt und stattdessen mehr Wohlstand entsteht. Das heißt, diese Länder können jetzt zum ersten Mal ihrer Bevölkerung etwas ermöglichen, was zuvor nie möglich war. Und natürlich haben diese Länder wenig Interesse daran, dass dies jetzt torpediert wird durch zum Beispiel einen Weltkrieg. Und das sollten wir mal ganz pragmatisch so betrachten, also dass es einfach eine Möglichkeit für diese Länder gibt, dass das für die vielleicht ein relativ gutes Jahrhundert wird, trotz all der Wiedrigkeiten, Klima und so weiter, wovon dann besonders lateinamerikanische Länder und afrikanische Länder, aber China ja im Prinzip auch, also alle sind davon erbrochen. Gerade China. Wir haben ja auch schon Zahlen gehört, aber trotzdem besteht auch die Möglichkeit, dass man jetzt aufgrund des Fortschritts, den man schon erreicht hat, aufgrund neuer Kooperationen einen Wohlstand schaffen kann, der ein besseres Jahrhundert schafft als das vorangegangene für sie, weil in dem vorangegangenen sind sie ziemlich vergessen worden. Und das kann auch sehr dafür sorgen, dass sowohl Russland unter Druck gesetzt wird, als immer auch der Westen unter Druck gesetzt wird, dass man sagt, wir wollen nicht das hier größer machen, denn wir würden jetzt gerne auch mal ein bisschen was vom Kuchen abhaben. Das kann sehr, sehr gut sein, dass wir diese Art der Multipolarität gerade haben, nämlich eine des Wohlstands.
Ja, also sie hat es ja eben auch noch mal auf die Kosten bezogen. Das sollte man im Hinterkopf haben. So, Ischinger hat dann Wang Yi, heißt er, glaube ich, begrüßt. Da das nicht wirklich so im Sinne von das ist der Außenminister, hören wir uns mal kurz diese Begrüßung an.
Wir werden jetzt, was ich finde, ein der Heiligkeiten dieses Morgen, Tag zwei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, China haben. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir jetzt, als wir Mr. Wang Yi auf dem Bild hatten, weil die Pandemie ein Jahr vorgegangen ist, ihn jetzt in Person haben.
So, also große Freude. Genau. Und jeder hat so nochmal seinen Vlog eingeschlagen. Also für Ischinger ist das jetzt das wichtigste Gespräch, das er führt mit Wang Yi. Und für Heusgen war es der globale Süden. Wang kam aus einem Grund überhaupt nur, nämlich um in 50 Sekunden zu markieren, dass China jetzt den Ton angibt in allen möglichen Belangen, insbesondere auf welche internationalen Institutionen kommt es eigentlich an und wer sorgt hier für die Initiativen?
Sobald es jetzt mehr als 100 Länder und internationale Organisationen, z.B. die UN, haben die zwei Initiative zu unterstützen.
Also sehr bemerkenswerter Auftritt, sehr selbstbewusst. Und er steht jetzt auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, also wo man sich quasi so vernetzen will, um Bündnisse zu schmieren und er sagt, kommt aber nicht und sagt, ich schließe mich eurem Bündnis an. Wir machen hier gerade Bündnisse, aber wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr auch mal hier mal gerne mitmachen.
Das auch auf die Frage hin, ist die Globalisierung vorbei oder so? Nein, es ist jetzt eine chinesische Globalisierung. Ja, es ist halt jetzt nicht mehr der internationale Währungsfonds und die Weltbank und die EU oder so, sondern ja, wir haben ja diese 70 Länder binden es und hier und da und seien sie gerne dabei.
Sehr ungewöhnlich, im Nadelstreifen ist er dort. Das ist eher bei solchen Konferenzen nicht so häufig zu sehen. Er ist im Nadelstreifen anzuhören und hat aber dann, ja, also dunkler, sehr dunkel. Ich würde fast sagen, ja schwarz, aber ist wahrscheinlich so ein vielleicht ganz dunkles Blau. Ich kann es nicht so richtig erkennen, denn er trägt dann eine sehr blaue Krawatte darauf. Fast nicht so ganz. Aber dass er im Nadelstreifen ist, ist ungewöhnlich für solche Konferenzen.
Und eine extrem aufwändige Frisur. Also da liegt jedes Haar, man hat sich sehr viele Gedanken gemacht.
Ich finde die Frisur toll.
Wir schauen Ihnen vor allem wegen diesen zwei Clips, die wir jetzt noch zum Abschluss hören. Nein.
Da wir auch einen Podcast machen, da kann man sie nicht sehen.
Wang möchte zum einen mal einen Punkt machen.
Over the past 70 plus years, China has never initiated a war or occupied an inch of foreign land. It is the only country that has put peaceful development in its constitution and the only country among the five nuclear weapon states to pledge no first use of nuclear weapons. China's track record on peace can stand the scrutiny of history and its peaceful rise is an unprecedented miracle in human history.
China bislang kein Land angegriffen hat.
Wir müssen uns das ganz ernsthaft vor Augen führen, wenn die irgendwo auftreten. Dass das eben nicht Amerika ist, mit Track Record, Korea, Vietnam, Kosovo, Irak.
Ja, und es ist auch nicht fragreich in Deutschland mit Kolonialvergangenheit, mit Deutschland dann mit den ganz anderen Dingen noch im 20. Jahrhundert.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, aber Ichhinger traut sich, am Ende ihn nochmal direkt zu fragen. Er hat es auch vorher schon in seiner Rede drin, in sich der Ukraine. Also wer China Taiwan ausreden möchte, bedroht den Frieden der ganzen Region und so weiter. Denn den Separatismus Taivans kann man nicht durchgehen lassen. Und so weiter und so fort. Und Ichhinger wird es vielleicht bereut haben, am Ende ihn nochmal. Aber mittlerweile trauen sich die Chinesen hier auch außerhalb ihres Staatsgebiets und außerhalb der Parteitagsreden sozusagen Ansagen zu machen.
I don't think, sir, that this discussion would be complete if we didn't have at least one final minute, we don't have more time than that, for you to reassure this audience that a military escalation over the Taiwan issue is not.
Das ist die Status Quo der Taiwan-Fraktion. Es ist nicht China, die die Status Quo ändern will, sondern die Taiwanse Sepizist-Förder auf der Insel. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch, aber ich bin auch ein sehr guter Mensch.
Germany will help Ukraine for as long as it takes. Together with our European and transatlantic allies.
Ja, soweit die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz aus unserer Sicht.
Thema Migration, Flüchtlinge in Europa. Wir hören erst einen Tagesschau-Bericht. Und zwar ist das ein Tagesschau-Bericht von gestern. Ich hatte die Clips schon sortiert. Und dann kam dies hier noch. Und damit beginnen wir dann.
Das Unglück hat sich in Sichtweite zur Küste ereignet vor dem süditalienischen Kalabrien in der Nähe der Stadt Crotone. Ein Fischerboot mit zahlreichen Migranten an Bord lief nach bisherigen Erkenntnissen auf einen Felsen und ging unter. Mindestens 40 Menschen sind bei dem Unglück ums Leben gekommen. Ihre Leichen wurden von Hilfskräften aus der Rauen See geborgen. Rund 50 Personen konnten sich dagegen ans Ufer retten. Nach weiteren Überlebenden wird gesucht. Die Zahl der Opfer könnte sich aber noch deutlich erhöhen. Nach Angaben von Geretteten, berichtete italienische Nachrichten an Thor Anza, waren rund 250 Menschen an Bord. Die Migrantinnen und Migranten, unter ihnen auch Kinder, sollen unter anderem aus Pakistan, dem Iran und Afghanistan stammen. Im vergangenen Jahr sind im Mittelmeer über 2.500 Migrantinnen und Migranten getrunken oder gelten als vermisst. Das geht aus einem Bericht der Internationalen Organisation für Migration der feinden Nationen hervor.
Eine Meldung von vielen Meldungen, die wir täglich erleben. Und wir können aber jetzt auch sehen, Europa baut kräftig an der Festung. Und wir hören jetzt Ursula von der Leyen, die im Parlament spricht und versucht mal zu zeigen, wohin die Reise geht.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass Sie da sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass Sie da sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass Sie da sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass Sie da sind.
Also man hat eine hohe Zahl von illegal kommenden, aber wir müssen jetzt hier direkt bei dieser Differenzierung natürlich Obacht geben, denn was hier jetzt gemacht wird, ist unterschieden wird in Migration, die gerechtfertigt ist, die gut ist oder auch Migration, die wir dann wollen in Form von Arbeitskräften. Und dann gibt es dann die illegale Migration. Damit ist aber auch gemeint, dass da Leute vor Not in vielerlei Art fliehen, denn in der Regel ist es ja nicht so, dass man zum Spaß sich einen Schlepper oder sowas andient oder dass man lange Marschrouten in Kauf nimmt, was auch immer. Aber die EU versucht jetzt besonders, diese starke Unterscheidung zu machen und dass man immer wieder betont, das ist illegal. Also damit zeigt man natürlich, man selbst ist legal, indem man jetzt auf Frontex sich beruft. Und von der Line will jetzt erst mal uns zeigen, wofür die EU in ihren Augen steht.
Es gibt ohne Zweifel unverdienliche Druck auf unseren externen Bordern.
Ist nur die Frage, wer braucht es denn? Und es ist ja so, dass wir immer noch nicht festgelegt haben, dass es so etwas wie Klimaflüchtlinge gibt. Also wir können sagen ja Leute, die bedroht werden aufgrund ihrer Sexualität zum Teil, aufgrund von Krieg, obwohl wir ja auch wieder abschieben in Kriegsgebieten. Auch das gibt es ja. Aber da gibt es ja zumindest so ein paar Dinge, die festgelegt sind. Aber wie ist das eigentlich mit dem Klima? Das ist etwas, was wir in dem Sinne immer noch nicht festgelegt haben. Es gibt hier einige Artikel natürlich zu dem Thema. Ich will aus Politico einen zitieren, da heißt es. Am wichtigsten ist jedoch, dass das internationale Recht auch derzeit keinen Schutz für Klimaflüchtlinge vorsieht. Wir können uns nicht einmal darauf einigen, wer als Klimaflüchtling gilt.
Ich meine, dass sie diese Rede hält, ist ja eh schon bezeichnend. Denn damit erklärt sie es ja zur Chefsache. Sie greift also dieses große Thema auf und entreißt es so ein bisschen dem Ministerrat, der dann Beschlüsse fassen muss und holt es so ein bisschen zur EU-Kommission. Und das macht sie natürlich nicht, um jetzt irgendwie eine Lockerung, eine Liberalisierung oder irgendwas, sondern so eine, wir sind jetzt Empfänger, wir stellen uns der Welt zur Verfügung, sondern natürlich nur, um den restriktiven Kurs zu betonen.
Ja, denn wofür die EU dann wirklich steht, führt sie gleich danach aus. Also viele, die kommen, unterstellt sie, haben überhaupt kein Anrecht darauf, hier bleiben zu können und die Return rates, also die Rückführungen fallen viel zu gering aus.
Wir haben einen gemeinsamen Interesse in starken externen Bordern. Die größte Forderung ist jetzt die Lande, zwischen Bulgarien und Türkiye. Wir können die Bordern stärken mit der Managemangst. Wir können auch Infrastruktur und Equipment, wie Drones, Raider und andere Mittel für die Überraschung, wie wir es letztes Jahr in den letzten Jahren in Romagna, in Spanien, in Griechenland und in Polen gemacht haben.
Wenn man sich diese ganze Migrationsdebatte im Januar, im Februar ansieht, dann war es ja so, dass sehr viele Länder jetzt die Chance ergreifen, vehement sich für eine Festung in Europa einzusetzen. Also da war eine Allianz zum Beispiel zwischen Österreich, Italien, Griechenland. Dann hat man sowieso Ungarn und so. Da kennt man die Töne entsprechend. Dann hat Schweden jetzt die Ratsmitgliedschaft. Schweden ist auch nicht gerade ein migrationsfreundliches Land ganz im Gegenteil. Das heißt, man hat jetzt da sehr gut eine Allianz geschmiedet. Wir werden noch gleich sehen, was das in Bezug auf Deutschland bedeutet. Wir hören nochmal von der Line jetzt über die Schmuggler reden.
Behind all this, they are criminal networks. They are organising ruthlessly the cheby life vests, the boats, they are robbing the migrants, they are trading in human life. We have to intensify our fight against those smugglers and we will launch a new anti-smuggling partnership with key third countries. These will bring together prosecutors and law enforcement authorities supported by Europol and supported by Eurojust. Together we have to stop this business of exploitation.
Aber sie betont erst mal nur die Sachen, die es schon gibt und so weiter. Diese neuen, dass man dann wirklich Zäune und Mauern baut.
Es geht dann weiter.
My second point is focusing on faster and dignified returns. Every year there are around 300,000 return decisions taken by member states. But only around 70,000 people are actually returned. We have to get better. Some of the shortcomings we can act on now. For instance, a return decision that is taken in one member state should be valid in all member states. So if a person with a return decision by Italy is found in France, that person can be directly returned to its country of origin. This will become possible now with the Schengen Information System that enters into force, into operation in March. And we want member states to make use of this possibility.
Das heißt, man hat die Rückführungen beschleunigt und hat sie optimiert. In Politico war zu lesen am 10. Februar 2023, vor allem Grenzzäune waren früher in weiten Teilen Europas ein Kreu. Sie wurden als stumpfes Instrument betrachtet, das mehr der Show als den praktischen Nutzen diente. Doch eine wachsende Koalition von EU-Ländern hat nun solche Zäune errichtet und einige wollen, dass Brüssel für weitere Zäune zahlt. Und obwohl die EU-Beamten die rote Linie bei der Finanzierung von Zäunen nicht überschreiten wollen, stimmen sie in der Regel der Finanzierung von Überwachungstechnologie und Grenzschutz zu. Und weiter heißt es dann, während sich die EU-Staats- und Regierungschefs hin und her bewegten, drängte Österreich an vorderster Front auf mehr Grenzschutzmittel aus Brüssel. Das Land hat einen Anstieg der Migranten erlebt, die über den Westbalkan kommen und oft von Serbien nach Ungarn und dann nach Österreich gelangen. Vor allem hervorgetan hat sich dann Bundeskanzler Karl Nehammer, also der österreichische Bundeskanzler, der dann sagte, die EU-Kommission hat nun zugestimmt, substanzielle Unterstützung zu leisten, um den Grenzzaun zu verstärken. Also so hat er es dann interpretiert. Man versucht immer dem, wir bauen Zäune ein bisschen zum Gehen. Wir kennen ja noch die Debatte, was Trump will eine Mauer bauen. Wir machen im Prinzip jetzt eine sehr ähnliche Politik. Und dann hört man jemanden wie Manfred Weber, also Parteifreund von von der Leyen, der sagt dann im Parlament Folgendes.
Ressources are limited in Belgium. Citizens are losing trust in our system and wondering if it still works. I just wanted to mention a couple of points on the basis of what Sula von der Leyen just said. First of all, we need to secure Europe's external borders. We need to implement European law at the border. We need technical measures for that.
Ja, sind sie ja sowieso nicht, aber bisher mussten die Länder das eben selber finanzieren, konnten sich da nicht in der EU bedienen. Dass er hier diese Ansage so klar macht, geht ja auch reinher mit seinem neuen Ansinnen, dann doch mehr auf diese rechteren Gruppen in der EVP zuzugehen, damit es da nicht so ein Zerfleddere wird und dann Orban vielleicht noch so eine eigene Fraktion da schmiedet und so.
Naja, und es bedeutet jetzt auch, dass er die NGOs anders an die Brust nehmen will, an die Kandare nehmen will. Und das wird jetzt wirklich absurd. Also jetzt achten wir mal auf die Logik. Wir kennen ja NGOs, Seenotrettung, die versuchen, Menschen zu helfen. Und oft gelingt ihnen das dann auch, wenn sie entsprechend ausgestattet sind. Aber Manfred Weber, ist das so nicht recht?
Dann haben wir das Thema der NGO-Search-and-Rescue-Boote in der Meditranen. Saving lives is a key principle. Civil society involvement is welcome in the Mediterranean, provided they are helping people. So it's right, good and welcome. We need a common understanding that is shared by everyone who's active in the Mediterranean. There needs to be a code of conduct as to how we deal with the measures in the Mediterranean. Not all refugees that are picked up or migrants that are picked up in the Mediterranean have to be brought straight to Italy.
Das heißt, was er eigentlich da möchte, ist, dass die Seenotrettung jetzt die Flüchtlinge zurückbringt an den Ort, wo sie hergekommen sind.
Also in Australien, wo das ja auch so extrem bescheuert ist, doch das wenigstens die Armee selber, die auf irgendwelchen Inseln aussitzen. Wenn das jetzt hier noch Auftrag für die privat organisierten Seenotrettung sein soll, dann hat das natürlich…
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Wir müssen uns auf das globale Ausmaß von Flüchtlingsströmen ansehen. Ibrahim Östemir ist Berater für das Umweltprogramm der Vereinten Nationen, hat im Politico einen Beitrag geschrieben. Und dieser Beitrag ist erst zehn Tage alt. Da heißt es, weltweit haben sich die Migrationsströme in den letzten zehn Jahren verdoppelt und rund 1, 2 Milliarden Menschen sind gefährdet, bis 2050 durch Klimakatastrophen vertrieben zu werden. Diese Klimaflüchtlinge kommen vor allem aus Afrika südlich der Sahara und der Mena-Region, wo die Länder bereits mit Klimakatastrophen zu kämpfen haben und von extremen Dürreperioden heimgesucht werden. Im Jahr 2015 wurde der Massenzusturm von Flüchtlingen und Migranten durch eine beispiellose politische Krise ausgelöst. Die Reibungen zwischen den europäischen Hauptstädten eskalierten, während der Block um seine Bewältigung kämpfte. Seine Institutionen waren zerbrochen. Und jetzt, acht Jahre später, sieht sich die EU mit einem Anstieg der unerlaubten Grenzübertritte um fast 64 Prozent konfrontiert. Eine Zahl, in der die fast acht Millionen ukrainischen Flüchtlinge, die jetzt über den Kontinent verstreut sind, nicht enthalten sind. Das ist also die Situation. Und die Antwort ist, dann müssen wir Mauern, Zäune und so weiter bauen. Und wir hören dann im Parlament natürlich wahnsinnig viele Stimmen dazu. Aber ich habe jetzt mal so ein paar rausgeprägt. Also ein paar Stimmen der Vernunft und ein paar Stimmen der Idiotie. Wir hören jetzt erstmal eine Stimme der Vernunft, wenn man so möchte. Also Garcia Perez aus Spanien, Sozialdemokratin, spricht über Arbeitskräfte, die fehlen.
Migration kann als Lösung zu unseren demografischen Problemen und unseren Arbeitsschrottungen in Europa.
Und ich bin auch sehr gespannt, dass sie sich mit dem Thema der Migranten beschäftigen. Und ich bin auch sehr gespannt, dass sie sich mit dem Thema der Migranten beschäftigen.
Ja, und sie kommt aus Spanien, also in Spanien arbeiten eine Million Nordafrikaner und zwar um Obst zu pflücken. Da ist nun jeder, wir brauchen aber Fachkräfte, die müssen zu irgendwas ausgebildet sein, völlig daneben. Also diese Motivation aus Spanien heraus das zu machen, ist auf ihre eigene Art dann nochmal so, naja, nicht ganz sauber im Sinne, weil man sucht da im Grunde Arbeitsklaven.
Terry Reintke von den Grünen spricht auch über Arbeitskräfte.
Nicht einmal war es eine Erinnerung an Menschenrechte, nicht einmal war es eine Erinnerung auf das Schweren von denen, die versuchen, Schelter zu finden, in der Europäischen Union. Und nicht einmal war es eine Erinnerung auf internationale Ziele, internationale Ziele, die die Europäische.
Union in die Einrichtung der Einrichtung der Europäischen Union in die Einrichtung der Europäischen Union in die Einrichtung der Europäischen Union in die Einrichtung.
Und nicht nur wir helfen den Menschen, sondern wir hätten doch vielleicht was davon.
Geht es erstaunlich schnell, dass man jetzt 2023 das schon drin hat und so. Das war letztes Jahr alles noch völlig undenkbar.
Ja, da war das eine reine Flüchtlingsdebatte und dann hätte man noch mal eine Arbeitskräftedebatte gehabt. Aber das ist nun sehr stark miteinander vermischt. Aber ich meine, wir haben ja die Zahlen. Also Schweden hat die Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen radikal reduziert. Also die nehmen nur noch 20 Prozent der Flüchtlinge, die sie früher aufgenommen haben. Also das ist dann schon ein Regierungswechsel, der ganz erheblich ist. Gewinner des Ganzen ist natürlich die Sicherheitsindustrie, wenn man sie so nennen möchte. Wir hören jetzt hier Malik Asmani ist, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, aus den Niederlanden. Sein Vater ist marokkanischer Herkunft. Das hindert aber ihn nicht daran, so etwas zu sagen.
Our focus should be on concrete results for our citizens to provide immediate relief to our external borders. And we must do everything in our.
Das heißt also, hier soll auch die Handelspolitik daran angepasst werden. Das heißt, man soll also Länder auch unter Druck setzen, dass sie wieder Leute aufnehmen, also dass die Rückführungen besser laufen. Und da soll man auch nochmal von Seiten der Handelsunion, die man ja auch ist, Druck ausüben. Und es ist ganz interessant, dass wir immer mal wieder Protagonisten mit einem Migrations- bzw. Flüchtlings- Hintergrund haben, die dann im Parlament plötzlich solche Reden schwingen und eine konservative Politikkarriere machen. Und das ist ja gerade das auch, was die AfD am liebsten immer mal hätte. Also jemanden, der es noch geschafft hat und dann aber die Türen hinter sich zumacht und sagt, so, jetzt ist aber auch wirklich mal das Wunsch vor.
Aber man bietet denen eben auch besondere, also die werden besonders hofiert in dieser Partei. Wenn du da einmal auffällst als, ach so, du hast Migrationshintergrund und redest aber jetzt in unserem, cool, dann können wir dich besonders gut verwenden, als dann bist du plötzlich Vortragsredner überall und so. Und dann machst du da so Karrieren.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich eine ganz perfide Strategie. Wir hören jetzt hier Paolo Rangel, der auch zwischen guten und schlechten Migranten unterscheiden will.
Die Frage, die wir vor uns haben, ist, wie wir besser die Rechte der Menschen, die die meisten zwingend sind, und die genügend zwingend sind, und nicht die Rechte derjenigen, die in vielen Fällen einfach illegal und unvergleichlich in die Insel gehen wollen. Wir wollen bessere, sichere Borderte, die wir gut kontrollieren. Das würde uns in eine viel bessere Position setzen, die Rechte der meisten zwingend zu verhindern, um legalen Migrationen zu organisieren, für gute Qualitätsarbeit, die uns helfen würden, unsere demokratischen Probleme zu handeln.
Also das hilft den Ländern, wenn wir denen, die hochqualifizierten, dann mal abnehmen, weil die brauchen wir für unsere demografischen Probleme, aber bitte die anderen wollen wir alle nicht haben.
Umso schärfer dieser Unterschied zwischen Arbeitsmigration und Fluchtmigration ist, umso klarer ist, dass diese Menschen keinen Kontakt zu diesem echten Problem haben. Also die kennen die Fluchtlingsaufnahme nicht, die kennen die Rahmendaten nicht, die kennen diese Schicksale nicht, weil sobald die vor dir stehen, fragst du dich, du kommst jetzt aus Syrien, hast aber diese Ausbildung, was bist du jetzt eigentlich? Und da verschwimmt ja alles. Also da sieht man dann immer, das ist ja dieser typische Chrupalla sagt, nur noch deutsche Gedichte. Und dann kommt so ein Kinderreporter und fragt, welches ist dein deutsches Lippenens Gedicht? Und er kennt keins. Er redet die ganze Zeit zu einem Thema, von dem er keine Ahnung hat und so ist das ja auch.
Wir hören noch was Schlimmes, und zwar Nicolas Bay. Er war der ehemalige Pressesprecher von Lippen und ist jetzt zu Zimmour übergegangen. Er sieht natürlich das Ende der europäischen Zivilisation kommen.
Es werden 2, 5 Millionen Afrikaner im Jahr 2050 sein. Und 52 Prozent der jungen Menschen wollen in Europa kommen. Wenn wir alle von Afrika und der Mittelfest willkommen, helfen wir niemanden.
Ja, also da kann man ja interessante Parallelen machen, wie zum Beispiel bei diesem in Neukölln findet Silvester statt und 50 Prozent derjenigen, die da rumgeböllert haben und sich sozusagen über die Stränge schlugen, haben Migrationshintergrund. Ja, weil in der Köln eben zu 50 Prozent oder sogar noch mehr in diesen Art von Migrationshintergrund mitbringt. Das ist also statistisch nicht auffällig, sondern man kann es nur medial strapazieren. Und jetzt kann man ja sagen, die Welt hat acht Milliarden Einwohner und sie schafft vielleicht nochmal neun Milliarden, so 2060. Genau, dann ist irgendwann Schluss. Also die absolute Zahl der Menschheit, also der gleichzeitig lebenden Menschen, wird so bei acht, neun Milliarden sind. Ändert aber nichts daran, dass sich der afrikanische Anteil von derzeit mit 1, 5 Milliarden sind sie also so ungefähr so ein Viertel oder ein Fünftel oder sowas, keine Ahnung, dass sie aber irgendwann 4, 5 Milliarden sind. Also irgendwann ist fast jeder zweite Mensch auf der Welt ein Afrikaner. So und jetzt kann man sich natürlich in Europa sagen, wir wollen aber unseren Anteil auf 10 Prozent halten. Wir lassen das nicht zu, dass hier einfach die Weltentwicklung auch bei uns stattfindet. Aber ja, es wird halt so kommen, dass jeder zweite Mensch auf der Welt irgendwann mal afrikanischen Ursprungs ist. Und es wird dann auch in Europa so sein. In der Ernsticht ist das halt der Lauf der Dinge, wie der Lauf der Dinge in einer globalen Wirtschaft halt allgemein so ist.
Das ist ja nicht mehr 20. Jahrhundert, das ist ja schon 19. Jahrhundert, wohin er da zurück will. Und dann können wir das so alles machen. Gut, dann weiß ich nicht, was wir da machen. Vielleicht Verhütungsmittel verbieten oder so. Dann kann man darüber nochmal reden. Nun, wir hören jetzt aber nochmal eine vernünftige Stimme von den Grünen, Tineke Strick.
Aber die EU scheint, dass ein Flüchtling ein Flüchtling ist, egal, ob er aus der Region kommt. Und die meisten Flüchtlinge in Europa kommen von Syrien, Afghanistan, Irak, Türken. Und was ist die Antwort der EU auf diese Schutzgröße? Deterrence and shifting responsibility instead of respecting the rights of all refugees. But there is no space for selective morality.
Ja, keine selektive Moral, das ist genau das, was...
Da gibt es auch ein schönes Gleichnis. Wir akzeptieren ja eine Migrationsbewegung, ganz, sind wir total aufgeschlossen, für Tourismus. Menschen gehen, kommen nur für einen kurzen Moment und bringen sehr viel Geld mit. Das hat also einen volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen, die zu haben und dann ist es auch egal woher. Die haben halt gebucht, kommen halt vom Flughafen. So, oder das Flugzeug, da kann man es egal. Und der volkswirtschaftliche Nutzen, diese Art von Migration, wie wir sie hier besprechen, ist ja genau so groß anzumessen wie der von Tourismus. Plus, dass sie nicht nur Geld mitbringen, sondern auch noch Know-how und so weiter. Und eigentlich bräuchten wir mal echt so einen Zustand, in dem wir wie bei Touristen sagen, es ist eigentlich egal, wo du herkommst. Jetzt bist du da, jetzt gucken wir uns halt an, wer du bist und jetzt kannst du uns was erzählen. Was ist der Wünsche? Wir haben Angebote, keine Ahnung. Dann matchen wir das mal. Aber das wäre im Grunde die Zielvorstellung. Denn für Touristen haben wir längst offene Grenzen. Jeder darf kommen und so weiter. Und das könnte man ja dann eigentlich hier auf diesem Gebiet auch mal. Also sozusagen einfach diese Art, von wie wir darüber reden, dass wir über Migration allgemein reden und gar nicht unterscheiden zwischen Fluchtmigration, Arbeitsmigration, dauerhafter Migration aus persönlichen Gründen oder halt temporärer Migration wie Tourismus. Das ist alles unter einem Hut.
Keine selektive Moral, hat sie gesagt. Und wir springen mal gerade zu einem Frontalbeitrag, nämlich handelte der von Flüchtlingen aus Russland, also von jungen Männern, die vor dem Krieg fliehen, die nicht auch Kanonenfutter für Putin werden wollen.
Der 21. September 2022. Ein Schock für viele junge Russen. Putin verkündet die Talmobilmachung. Hunderttausende junge Männer rekrutiert für den blutigen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine. Davor sind sie geflüchtet. Nikolai Goryachev aus Moskau und Arseny Shipkov aus Yekaterinburg. Sie haben es bis nach Berlin geschafft, weit weg vom Zugriff der russischen Armee.
Also eigentlich wunderbar. Die können schon nicht mehr verheizt werden. Die können auch zugleich nicht mehr Ukraine erschießen.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch in diesem afrikanischen Diskurs erstmal auf die Opfer schauen. Also wenn jemand nicht zum Opfer werden will, auf Befehls Sinne, weil einmal mobilisiert, geht ja jeder Befehl angegeben, auch an die Zivilisten.
Also wir haben sie geschützt vom Opfer sein und vom Väter sein. Vor beiden Dingen haben wir sie geschützt, aber wir hören auch, naja, was bedeutet das denn jetzt für diese jungen Männer, die hier angekommen sind?
In Russland gelten alle Männer ab 18 Jahren als Reservisten und bekommen diesen roten Militärpass. Weil sie beide schon vor der Teilmobilmachung ein Touristenvisum für die EU hatten, konnten sie nach Deutschland einreisen. Hier haben sie politisches Asyl beantragt. Doch ihre Chancen stehen schlecht, weiß Rudi Friedrich, der mit seinem Verein viele Kriegsverweigerer berät.
Die deutsche Bundesregierung hat im Mai zugesagt, dass Deserteure aus der russischen Armee einen Flüchtlingsschutz bekommen sollen. Die große Frage ist aber für all diejenigen, die klug genug waren, sich rechtzeitig den Rekrutierung zu entziehen und die es überhaupt nach Deutschland geschafft haben. Was schwierig genug ist, für die gibt es keine Regelung, keinen Schutz.
Das heißt, Deserteure ja, aber die sollen dann schon beim Militär gewesen sein, die sollen schon einberufen worden sein. Wenn man sagt, da kommt jetzt bald der Einberufungsbefehl, ich haue lieber schon mal ab, da sagt natürlich der deutsche Staat, nein, das muss alles seinen korrekten Weg gehen.
Das Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge hat Asylanträge von russischen Kriegsverweigerern abgelehnt.
Eine der Begründungen lautet, es sei Zitat Nicht mit beachtlicher Wahrscheinlichkeit davon auszugehen, dass der Antragsteller, der nicht über militärische Vorkenntnisse und auch sonst nicht über Spezialkenntnisse verfügt, überhaupt gegen seinen Willen zwangsweise zu den Streitkräften eingezogen würde.
Da wird mit Argumenten abgelehnt, Argumente, die gar nicht mehr stimmen. In Russland gab es verstärkt Rekrutierung und die haben auch so stattgefunden, dass ganze Häuserblöcke abgesperrt worden sind und kontrolliert wurde, dass in U-Bahnen, Busen und dergleichen rekrutiert wurde und alle Männer, die in dem Alter waren, wurden einfach mitgenommen.
Das bestätigen auch Berichte des unabhängigen russischen Nachrichtenmagazins Medusa.
Zum einen sagen wir, der Putin verheizt alle, der ist völlig skrupellos und zum anderen sagen wir, nein, der wird jetzt auch nicht einfach irgendwelche jungen Männer verfeuern, wenn die noch gar nicht richtig ausgebildet sind. Na, erstmal können die ja ausgebildet werden und wenn der Krieg noch eine Weile dauert, wovon ja viele ausgehen, dann werden aus denen natürlich auch Soldaten gemacht und dann haben die keine Möglichkeit mehr zu fliehen. Und es ist eine Schande, anders ist es nicht zu sagen, dass man überhaupt da noch zögert, diese aufzunehmen. Denn es ist ja völlig logisch, dass diejenigen, die jetzt fliehen, die jetzt das Leben hier in Deutschland sehen, dass die für Putins Weltanschauung und für seine imperialistischen Fantasien verloren sind.
Das müssen wir dann halt in Kolumbien und Namibien nochmal lernen, diese konsequente Opferperspektive und dieser Zuspruch zum Leben und so.
Und dann kann man den jetzt nicht nochmal abverlangen, nochmal offen zu legen. Und ihre Eltern, haben die dann vielleicht mal Putin gewählt? Oder wollen wir noch alles wissen? Es ist unglaublich und zugleich haben wir die Ukraine, wo junge Männer nicht ausreißen dürfen. Was heißt junge Männer? Also Männer bis über 50 nicht ausreißen dürfen. Und das ist unglaublich, dass das zusammengeht jetzt gerade. Na ja, wir springen jetzt also wieder zurück ins Parlament und hören Claire Daly. Sie ist eine Linke aus Irland und sie findet sehr gute Worte für das, was hier eigentlich geschieht.
Danke, Herr Präsident.
Ende 2021 war die Mehrheit der Refugee in der EU 0, 6% als die totalen Population.
0, 6%.
Das ist kein schwieriges Problem.
Es ist eigentlich kein Problem.
Aber hast du das jetzt so ausgewählt oder ist das gefühlt, ist ja jeder zweite Redebeitrag aus der sozialen, wir könnten jetzt auch 100 Beiträge spielen von Leuten, die sagen wir müssen Zäune und jetzt gilt es aber. Genau, auf der rechten Seite. Aber so die.
Ja, aber auch bürgerlich. Also wir haben diese Stimmen. Es gibt diese Stimmen und vielleicht werden die auch mal mehr gehört werden und wahrscheinlich hast du recht, dass man das so eng miteinander verknüpft, ist wahrscheinlich etwas Neues und es ist sehr clever, ist eigentlich das, was wir anempfohlen haben. Hier scheint es ja fast so zu sein, als hätte sie ein Buch gelesen und das wird vielleicht auch zunehmen. Aber wenn man sieht, was die konservative Mehrheit will und wenn wir auch sehen, was aus den ganzen anderen Ländern kommen, ich meine, wir haben da ja so viele rechte Regierungen, wir haben Meloni und all das. Da sind das hier vereinzelte Stimmen der Vernunft. Aber wir können sagen, Europa entwickelt sich nach rechts, das heißt schottet sich ab.
Ja, Pension-Time-Bomb, das können wir uns doch mal merken. Und die droht in Deutschland wirklich. Wir haben doppelt so viele Pensionäre wie arbeitende Beamte. Zunehmend. Und das sind halt Kosten, die wir nicht einfach abschütteln können. Bei der Rentenzahlung kann man einfach im Haushalt sagen, wir wollen jetzt mal ein bisschen senken und so. Aber das sind ja richtige Verträge. Vorher geht Deutschland pleite, bevor wir Pensionisten ihr Geld nicht zahlen. Und diese Last ist so hoch, dass der Bundesbankpräsident Weidmann, Jörg Weidmann, ja schon auf europäischer Ebene auftrat und sagt, wir würden uns gerne mehr investieren, können es aber nicht. Denn ja, wir sind ein reiches Land, aber alle Gelder sind gebunden, weil wir Pensionsversprechen haben.
Jens, heißt der Komplex.
Jens Weidmann, richtig.
Ja, wir springen zum EU2GO Podcast und bekommen das ein bisschen eingeordnet, warum jetzt die Debatte so heftig und so polemisch geführt wird.
Es gab vor dem Europäischen Rat einen Brief von insgesamt acht EU-Mitgliedsstaaten, die sich eben sehr explizit zum Beispiel für den Ausbau von Zäunen entlang der EU-Außengrenze stark gemacht haben. Und auch beim Thema Rückkehr gab es vor dem Rat schon die Forderungen, zum Beispiel im Bereich Visa-Politik eben stärker auf negative Anreize, auf Sanktionen zu setzen, um eben dann die herkommenden Staaten dazu zu bewegen, ihre Bürger zurückzunehmen.
Welche Rolle spielt also Deutschland? Und ich würde jetzt mal empfehlen, wir versuchen mal einen Diskurs mit hinzuzunehmen. Deutschland ist isoliert, Scholz ist zu zögerlich, wir müssten doch unsere europäischen Nachbarn. Es war ja im Übrigen auch sehr erstaunlich, vor dem Krieg haben die links-siberalen Polen mit der Kneifzange nicht angefasst. Und inzwischen zitieren sie laufend die Spitzenpolitiker. Und dann guckt man immer so Wikipedia, wofür die noch so stehen und ist dann doch etwas verdutzt. Ob das jetzt hier unsere neuen Verbündeten sind?
Ja, in Polen ist Wahlkampf und die tanzen den deutschen Twitter-Leuten auf der Nase rum.
Ja, noch mehr Forderungen und noch was Neues.
Wir hassen Deutschland so wie ihr.
Lukas Rasche bei EU2GO beschreibt die Lage Deutschlands.
Ich glaube insgesamt, was die Beschlüsse jetzt vom Europäischen Rat zeigen, ist, dass es einen großen politischen Willen gibt zu mehr Grenzsicherung, zu mehr Abschottung und dass Länder zum Beispiel wie Deutschland zunehmend isoliert sind mit ihrer eher ausgewogenen Position unter den Staats- und Regierungschefs. Portugal und Luxemburg sind dort vielleicht auch mitzurechnen, aber auch das deutsch-französische Tandem ist dort vielleicht weniger beisammen als man das im ersten Moment erwarten könnte.
Also Deutschland wieder isoliert könnte man jetzt auch noch mal groß spielen, aber jetzt im ganz positiven Sinne. Also schaut doch mal hier, Deutschland isoliert sich. Wir müssen jetzt auch nicht glorifizieren, Deutschland ist schon auch mit beteiligt an diesen ganzen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gegen Flüchtlinge. Es ist nicht so, als hätten wir die Weiße Weste an, aber im Vergleich zu dem, was da von einigen Ländern gefordert wird, ist Deutschland immer noch auf der sehr ruhigen.
Also in Merkels ersten Jahren war das die Europäer wollen, die Migrationspolitik. Deutschland so, wieso, ist doch kein Ding und so. Dann kommt 2015, alle strömen nach Deutschland. Deutschland so, wir brauchen jetzt ganz dringend eine europäische Lösung, alle anderen Länder so. Ja, haben wir auch die letzten zehn Jahre gesagt, aber jetzt ist gerade nicht so der Richtige, jetzt macht das mehr jedes Land selber. Und dann gab es gar keine europäische Lösung und jetzt sind sie halt wieder. Es gibt wieder diesen Druck von an der Ostseite und dann sagen halt Portugal und Deutschland, nee und so. Also ich meine, klar, Portugal kann das alles egal sein. Die sind ja noch weiter weg als Spanien, die wenigstens noch das Mittelmeer da angeraumt haben. Aber naja, wie die Diskurser zu laufen.
Wir hören nochmal rasch zum Thema Zäune.
Tatsächlich wird es wohl darauf hinauslaufen, dass die Kommission am Ende alles finanziert, was kein direkter Zaun oder eine Mauer ist. Also in dem Statement von von der Leiden ist die Rede zum Beispiel von Kameras, von Türmen, von mobiler Infrastruktur, also Fahrzeugen zum Beispiel.
Ja, und das ist ja eh total verlogen, wenn man bisher sagt, naja, die EU hat ja noch keine Zäune selbst bezahlt, das mussten die Mitglieder selber machen. Ja, aber dadurch, dass die EU schon relativ viel anderes Kram bezahlt hat, war Budget frei für die Zäune. Den haben dann noch die Länder abgerechnet, aber das sind ja nur noch so wuchhalterische Tricks eigentlich.
Ja, wir hören weiter.
Mittelfristig muss man aber sagen, dass Grenzanlagen, ob das jetzt Zäune oder Mauern sind, vor allem dazu führen, dass sich Migrationsbewegungen ändern, dass sie meistens gefährlicher werden, dass auch die Menschen, die eben diese Grenzen versuchen zu überqueren, öfter auf die Hilfe von Schleusern und Schleppern angewiesen sind. Also genau das, was die EU eigentlich versucht zu verhindern, wird eben durch diesen Mauer- und Zaunbau herbeigeführt. Und letzter ganz kurzer Punkt dazu noch ist der finanzielle Aspekt. Und genau deshalb, glaube ich, stand das jetzt beim Europäischen Rat auch wieder im Mittelpunkt. Es ist einfach unglaublich teuer, Zäune und Grenzen zu bauen. Ich habe mal geschaut, es gibt in Polen einen Grenzzaun, der 186 Kilometer lang ist und der etwa 353 Millionen Euro gekostet hat.
Und wenig bringt.
Ja, aber man hat eine gewisse Symbolpolitik. Das ist ja auch eine These im Übrigen von Wendy Brown. Die hat ja ein Buch über Mauern geschrieben, damals im Zuge von Trumps Wahl. Und da hat sie auch gesagt, dass die Zäunemauern eigentlich in dem Sinne nichts bringen, dass es natürlich Abschottungen gibt. Aber diese Art der Politik ist eigentlich eine reine Symbolpolitik, die betrieben wird. Und das ist der Diskurs, der aber wahnsinnig gut ankommt. Wir hören jetzt vom Politikpodcast Peter Kapan, der ein bisschen zeigt, wie sich die Debatte verschoben hat.
Vor zehn Jahren wäre wahrscheinlich ein EU-Politiker, der gesagt hätte, wir machen das so, wir fahren in die Herkunftsländer und sagen, wenn ihr eure abgelehnten Asylbewerber nicht zurücknehmt, dann streichen wir euch die Entwicklungshilfe. Da wäre wahrscheinlich niedergebrüllt worden im Sitzungssaal der Staats- und Regierungschefs. Heute verständigen sie sich darauf.
Klaus Remme spricht über die Rolle Schwedens und Italiens.
Die interne Bewegung in der Europäischen Union der letzten Monate ist eben die wachsende Zahl von Staaten, die bereit sind, dort nach Taten zu rufen in Richtung Zäune und Mauern. Reden wir bestimmt gleich drüber. Wir haben eine wachsende Zahl von Regierungen, und ich nenne Italien und Schweden, wo einfach rechtslastige Kräfte am Werke sind, die den Chor natürlich erheblich verstärken. Und das sind keine unbedeutenden Länder. Italien schon aufgrund seiner Größe nicht, Schweden, weil es im Moment die aktuelle Ratspräsidentschaft hat. Diese beiden Bewegungen, glaube ich, verstärken sich. Und so muss man dann erklären, und so wird es vielleicht verständlich, warum ein Sondergipfel anberaumt wurde, um über diese Fragen zu sprechen.
Und Peter Kappern versucht jetzt mal einzuordnen, warum sind denn jetzt auch Länder, die nicht dezidiert recht sind, dafür?
Ich glaube, man kann das noch ergänzen, Klaus, um den Mindset derjenigen, wo noch keine Rechtspopulisten regieren. Die sind im Panikmodus. Oder um es ganz, ganz profan zu sagen, denen geht der Arsch auf Grundeis, wenn man sich anschaut, was sich da in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern abgespielt hat, mit Protesten. Die haben Angst, dass das um sich greift. Die haben Angst, dass das Migrationsthema wieder benutzt wird von Rechtsextremen, um die Macht zu erobern bei kommenden Wahlen. Das gilt für die Niederlande, das gilt für Frankreich, das gilt auch für Deutschland. Da ist auch noch nicht jeder Politiker sicher, dass die AfD für immer und ewig im Tal zwischen 8 und 14 Prozent endet. Das ist der eigentliche Antrieb dieser Staats- und Regierungschefs, zu sagen, wir müssen jetzt wirklich die Reißleine ziehen. Die haben Angst, dass ihre Länder von Rechtspopulisten übernommen werden.
Ich glaube, dass das zum Teil stimmt und ich glaube, dass es zum Teil nicht stimmt. Ich glaube, dass wir es schon auch mit Politikern zu tun haben, die aus dem bürgerlichen Lager sind, die tatsächlich gegen zu viel Migration sind. Die sind dann nicht gleich bei der AfD gut aufgehoben, aber die kommen mit ihrem Kurs schon sehr gut klar und sagen dann ja ein bisschen Fachkräfte, ein paar Chefärzte aus sonst wo wären gut, aber sonst eher nicht. Also ich glaube, dass es eher so ein allgemeiner Diskurs ist. Ich glaube, es ist auch eine falsche Antwort darauf zu sagen, es gibt die Gefahr von rechts und deswegen machen wir auch rechte Politik jetzt. Das ist ja diese Ideologie, die Basso und Brock mal so schön beschrieben hat, die wir vorfinden eigentlich seitdem die AfD in Deutschland ist, dass wir Politik erleben, die genauso ist wie AfD Politik, nur wird sie von anderen ausgeführt und dann sagt Basso und Brock und wenn zwei dasselbe tun, dann ist es doch nicht das gleiche, weil sie ja nicht das Ansinn haben, die AfD zu sein. Und das finde ich ist natürlich verlogen und da hat Basso und Brock völlig recht. Und deswegen müsste man ja eher mal darüber nachdenken und das sind ja hier Beispiele gewesen, also von Grünen und Linken im Parlament, wie man diese Debatte einmal anders führt, indem man auf Demografie, Arbeitskräfte, Wohlstand, all das verweist, dass man vielleicht sieht, es gibt offenbar ein großes Interesse daran, ja in der Gesamtbevölkerung, dass das erhalten bleibt, der Wohlstand. Also würde Migration helfen und wenn das aber natürlich nie zum Mainstream-Diskurs wird, sondern nur hier einzelne Stimmen mal sind, dann sorgt man natürlich dafür, dass sozialer Abstieg immer mit mehr Migration verbunden ist. Dabei ist eigentlich das Gegenteil der Fall. Dies wird aber nicht von den meisten Medien und dies wird auch von den meisten bürgerlichen Politikern nicht geleistet. Wahrscheinlich, weil sie es auch nicht verstanden haben oder weil sie auch ideologisch versperrt sind dort. Und das führt dann dazu, dass es immer diese Reflexreaktionen gibt. Oh, die AfD droht und so weiter. Und ich würde aber da auch noch mal zumindest für den deutschen Fall ganz klar machen. Man hat jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren ganz viel Scheißpolitik gerechtfertigt dadurch, dass die AfD als Gefahr ja da ist. Und da müssen man reagieren. Wo ist die AfD? Die AfD hat mal 8 Prozent, mal 10 Prozent, mal 12 Prozent. Und jedes Mal sagt mir irgendjemand, es ist schon fünf vor zwölf. Und dann stellt sich heraus, na ja, aber komischerweise ist es jetzt doch 11 Prozent. Ich will das nicht kleinreden und mir wäre auch lieber niemand, würde die AfD wählen. Aber es ist nicht so, als würde morgen die AfD die absolute Mehrheit haben. Das ist einfach nicht wahr. Und das ist inzwischen auch ein rhetorisches Mittel, oder es ist zu einem solchen Mittel verkommen, dass man alle Politik immer rechtfertigen kann mit, ja, wir müssen ja aufpassen, sonst übernimmt morgen die AfD das Land. Ich sehe das nicht.
Ist ein bisschen wie diese jungen Grünen, die sich ausreden, dass ja die RWE einfach so ein mächtiges Unternehmen ist, weil sie selber die Tagesordnung nicht richtig gelesen haben im Bundestag, so was sie abgestimmt haben. Und da muss da halt ein Sündenbock her. Ich finde es aber sowieso, Kapellen und Remme reden ja hier so darüber, ja ja, und der Populismus und die Regierenden haben dann Angst, dass ihre Opposition da übernimmt und vielleicht so einen rechten Schlag dann plötzlich drin hat. Nur, wo wird denn dieser Kampf zwischen Regierung und Opposition ausgetragen? Doch in den Medien, die eine gewisse Mitverantwortung haben. Und da finde ich es doch erstaunlich, dass wir noch keine Reflektion darüber haben, dass 2015 Menschen nach Deutschland kommen und wir alle außer Rand und Band und nicht mal einen noch aus und wie überlaufen Passau ist und so. 2022 kommen viel mehr Menschen nach Deutschland und niemand redet darüber. Wir bekommen das so als statistisches Bundesamt. Snippet mal mit, dass zwei Millionen Menschen die Grenze übertreten haben. Und da sieht man doch auch, wenn der mediale Diskurs anders ist, wenn die Öffentlichkeit gefesselt ist durch Anne Will redet natürlich über den Krieg und Mayburt Illner auch und Maysperger sowieso und da redet keiner über Migration, dann wird dieses kommunale Drängen, wir brauchen jetzt hier mal eine neue Bundländer Runde und so weiter einfach nicht thematisiert und damit wird auch niemand aufgewickelt und dann ist die AfD unter Fernhalifen.
Und auch haben wir ja selbst bei der Ukraine den Diskurs, also bei den ukrainischen Flüchtlingen, dass alle dem positiv gegenüberstehen. Also die vereinzelten Stimmen, die sich da kritisch äußern, die bekommen aber dann wirklich Gegendruck. Und selbst die AfD hält sich ja, was ukrainische Flüchtlinge anbelangt, zurück in den Äußerungen. Und das aber wird nicht reflektiert. Und man kann es ja nur über die Medien spielen, also über was denn sonst. Man kann ja jetzt nicht an Haustüren klingeln gehen, sondern nur über die Massenmedien ist es möglich. Und das würde eigentlich bedeuten, dass wir jetzt diesen Diskurs, den wir da in Einzelstimmen gehört haben vom Europäischen Parlament, benötigen, um die Migrationsfrage mit der Wohlstandsfrage zu verquicken. Und dann natürlich auch Schwächen einzugestehen. Also es geht ja jetzt auch nicht darum zu sagen, ja läuft ja alles super, sondern dass natürlich Integration oft nicht funktioniert, dass überall Personal für die Integration fehlt, dass es bürokratische Hürden gibt. Und dass es natürlich auch mitunter Menschen gibt, die schwerer hier in unserer Gesellschaft hineinpassen als andere, ist ja auch ganz logisch. Und da sollte man auch dann nicht in aller Menschenfreundlichkeit über alles hinweg sehen. Sonst hat man nämlich dann fünf Jahre später oder wann ein Problem. Aber das kann man ja mal sehr, sehr offen und ehrlich diskutieren.
Genau, ich habe in deinem Clip-Ablauf jetzt mal einen kleinen von Maria Loheide von der Diakonie, die im Deutschlandfunk zugeschaltet war am 16. Es kamen 2022 mehr Menschen als 2015. Aber wir haben ihnen auch gesagt, ihr dürft hier sofort arbeiten und für euch gibt es auch keine Residenzpflicht. Das waren ja ukrainische Flüchtlinge und keine syrischen. Plötzlich hat man ganz interessante Erfahrungen gemacht, die vielleicht auch im Umgang mit allen Flüchtlingen von Bedeutung sind.
Sie selbst haben ja kürzlich erklärt, dass es gerade mit Blick auf die Integration über den Arbeitsmarkt ganz entscheidend darauf ankommt, dass es zum Beispiel so etwas gibt, wie die freie Wohnortwahl, also Teilhabe auch, wo man das haben möchte. Und dass zum Beispiel bei den Menschen, die aus der Ukraine hierher gekommen sind nach Deutschland, dass das gegeben ist. Ist diese Gruppe in gewisser Weise ein Vorbild?
Ja, das, was für die ukrainischen Geflüchteten geregelt worden ist, ist deutlich ein Vorbild. Das müsste auch für Asylsuchende gelten. Und vor allen Dingen müsste sehr schnell geregelt werden, wie ist ihr Aufenthaltsstatus und können sie dann auch dauerhaft bleiben. Aber eben doch sehr schnelle Integration auch in überhaupt gesellschaftliche Teilhabe und dann eben auch in Arbeit.
Wenn man also Arbeit und Wohnen zusammen nimmt und nicht sagt, erstens du kriegst ein Arbeitsverbot und zweitens deine Residenzpflicht ist auf diese Region begrenzt, dann gelingt plötzlich so ein Matching. Leute kommen in arbeitsfähigem Alter und haben auch eine Ausbildung und die tragen dann einfach vor, diejenigen, die Arbeitsstellen zur Verfügung haben, was sie bieten können und dann finden die sich halt, dann klappt das plötzlich. Und dann lebt auch die Hälfte der Leute privat vermittelt und können das sogar schon mit eigenem Einkommen bezahlen. Während wir diese Syrische, also diese Erfahrung von 2015 mit syrischen Flüchtlingen, die erstmal alles verboten haben und nur der Staat durfte sie betreuen, einfach 24 Stunden am Tag und war damit dann überfordert. Ja, Herrgott, die Politik war überfordert damit. Hätte man das mal zu einer gesellschaftlichen Aufgabe gemacht und jetzt sagen die ja, da können wir ja mal davon lernen, wie wir mit den ukrainischen Flüchtlingen umgegangen sind. Die kommen einfach hierher, die wissen, was sie wollen, neben Angebote wahr und zwar überall, wo sie sich ihnen bieten. Also mal sehen.
Frankreich macht jetzt was ganz absurdes und zwar kommen Menschen, in deren Worten illegal, nach Frankreich und arbeiten dort. Also das ist ja auch etwas, es gibt ja schon in Europa ganz viele illegale Flüchtlinge, die hier sehr lange sind und die hier arbeiten, aber die machen das halt im Verborgenen sozusagen, weil sie sonst abgeschoben werden könnten oder was auch immer. Und nun hat man sich überlegt, ja gut, die arbeiten jetzt hier schon, vielleicht können wir das Visa-Verfahren ändern. Und wir hören jetzt mal Arno Petram von France 24, der mal beschreibt, wie eigenartig diese neue Visa-Politik ist.
So, die neue Proposalierung eines Visa-Verfahrens ist für unverdienliche Mitarbeiter in verletzten Industrien. Das sind Industrien, die einen Arbeitsschrottkurs erleben. Das sind die Industrien, wo man die meisten unverdienlichen Mitarbeiter findet.
Erst einmal eine ganz interessante Idee. Man hat viele, die ohne Papiere arbeiten, im Restaurant, Sicherheits- und Reinigungs-Service. Nun soll denen der Zugang zum Visum erleichtert werden. Aber jetzt kommt die verrückte Konstruktion.
Basically, to prove, to get that visa, you have to prove that you've been working for eight months undocumented. That means working illegally. And to do so, you need to go to your employer and say, hey, can you give me the placelifts for the past eight months where I've been working illegally for you? Which means that the employer would be like self-incriminating themselves. And the bill is actually planning to increase sanctions for employers who are making people work illegally.
Chef, kannst du bitte mal ausstellen, dass ich illegal bei dir ohne Papiere gearbeitet habe. Du bekommst dann zwar höhere Strafen, aber ich würde an so einen Visum gelangen.
Es ist einfach sehr gut. Aber das ist diese Art von... Man ist einfach nicht nah dran. Nicht nur in den Journalismushäusern, sondern auch nicht in den Amtsstuben und auch nicht in den Parteizentralen, wo man plötzlich auf solche Ideen kommt.
Offenbar auch nicht nah dran ist Sarah Bühler. Ich habe jetzt einen Ausend aus einer Landsendung vom Februar. Ich verstehe gar nicht, was sie uns hier eigentlich mitteilen will. Aber wir hören uns das mal an.
Aber wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise die Migration gerade aus der Sub-Sahara mir anschaue, wo viele in Marokko haben und nicht weiterkommen. Ich habe diese Flüchtlingscamp in Marokko besucht. Das sind junge Männer, 17, 18, 19, die keinerlei Qualifikationen mitbringen, keinerlei Ausbildungen oder sonst etwas, handwerklich begabt sind. Die werden mit den falschen Illusionen dorthin gelockt. Du kannst Fußballstar in Europa werden.
Vielleicht sind die handwerklich begabt und wir wissen es nicht.
Das kann sein. Das kann sein, aber wenn man... Ich war in dem Camp, hast du was gelernt? Nein. Hast du irgendetwas gemacht? Genau, kommst du aus seinem Dorf. Die trauen sich auch nicht mehr zurück, weil die Familie alles, was sie hatte, zusammengeschmissen hat, damit er da rüber kann. Diese werden auch an den Transitzentren abgewiesen werden und werden sich dann trotzdem in ein Schlauchboot setzen und es versuchen. Das werden wir nicht mit Transitzentren eindämmen können. Da müssen wir uns, glaube ich, ehrlich genug machen. Da kommen natürlich Frontex alles ins Spiel. Aber wir werden wie immer wieder Menschen haben, die sagen, ich schaffe es nicht auf einem regulären Arbeitsmarkt. Ich bin nicht verfolgt. Ich habe eigentlich auch kein Recht auf Asyl. Und deshalb bleibt mir nur der irreguläre Weg. Und deshalb, dass sich die Europäische Union, dass sich Brüssel damit beschäftigt hat, ist ja so falsch nicht. Nur die Lösungen und die Verteilung, wie man der humanitären Verantwortung einerseits gerecht wird, auf der anderen Seite mit denen, die hier sind, wer umgeht und das andere trotzdem verändert. Diese Antworten gibt es nicht.
Was möchte sie denn eigentlich jetzt uns sagen?
Sie möchte, der Subtext dieser Botschaft ist, lieber Friedrich Merz, jetzt sind Sie doch Chef geworden, wo ich mich so hart gegen Sie ausgesprochen habe.
Ich habe aber jetzt immer weiter diese CSU-Mitgliedschaft.
Ich fahre noch mal die ordentliche Linie durch, die hier ankommt, mit der ich auch in der CDU, in Nordrhein-Westfalen, sehr weit gekommen bin bisher, als junge Frau mit sichtbarem migrantischem Hintergrund mich in dem Altherrenverein immer wieder buchen zu lassen als Vortragsrednerin und so weiter. Und sie versucht einfach, ihre Karriere hier zu retten, indem sie noch mal hart blinkt. Das ist meine Unterstellung, aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum man sonst so einen Quatsch sagen sollte. Das ist doch bescheuert.
Also sie trifft auf 17-Jährige, die nicht ausgebildet sind.
Das ist erstaunlich.
Ich würde sagen, wenn man jetzt hier in Deutschland geht und ein 17-Jähriger anspricht uns, hast du eine Ausbildung? Nö, ich mache jetzt gerade Abi oder ich mache noch mal so. Also wovon redest du ja? Sind 17-Jährige, ist da das Leben vorbei? Kann man die nicht mehr ausbilden? Also haben wir das jetzt mit...
Das ist auch ganz...
Kann man nichts mehr mitmachen eigentlich? Also wenn man mit 17 noch keine Ausbildung fertig hat, dann ist eigentlich das Leben noch aus.
Sie hat sich einfach den falschen Kandidaten ausgesucht.
Was erzählen diese Leute da und sagen dann, ja, wir können es nicht stoppen, aber sie könnte schon verstehen das. Also das ist dann auch so, ja, irgendwie weiß man nicht. Und die haben dann aber auch keine Berechtigung zu kommen. Na ja, die ganze Familie wirft das Geld zusammen, dass der Junge dann aus der Familie, der der Älteste oder Stärkste, was auch immer, es da vielleicht treffen kann, mag sein. Da werden natürlich in einer solchen Schattenwirtschaft, wie dem Schmucklerwesen, mit allerlei falschen Versprechungen Leute angelockt, um damit Geld zu verdienen. Und ja, da wird auch denen gesagt werden, du kannst ein Fußballstar werden. Guck mal hier beim FC Bayern. Aber ich würde mal sagen, das wird jetzt nicht für die meisten, die in diesen Lagern da stecken, die nicht weiterkommen oder die auf dem Meer trinken, gelten, dass die alle hier hingekommen wollten, weil sie glaubten, sie werden Fußballstar.
Ja, das ist einfach...
Also das ist ja auch intellektuell so was von unredlich, so was zu behaupten. Naja, aber das ist der Stand der Debatte. Und dann hat man dann Markus Lanz, der sogar mal dazwischen geht und sagt...
Ja, aber das wäre ein guter Einwurf.
Ja, aber die könnte man ja... Das wissen wir ja gar nicht, ob die nicht handwerklich begabt sind.
Genau, sind die wirklich handwerklich nicht begabt. Wie haben sie denn die 17-Jährigen gesichtet, um dieses Urteil zu verhälen?
Ja, gut, damit beenden wir diese Migrationsdebatte, die sich natürlich nicht beenden lässt. Und das wird uns das ganze Jahrzehnt und weit darüber hinaus verfolgen. So viel können wir konstatieren auf jeden Fall schlimmer in Europa, also feindlicher. Auch da nochmal der Punkt, wenn wir jetzt die ganze Zeit mit unseren Werten durch die Gegend rennen, müssen wir auch sehen, dass wir uns an diesen Werten messen lassen. Denn sonst kann natürlich wieder passieren, dass irgendein Land, das uns dann gerade nicht so lieb ist, sagt, ja, ihr redet so viel von Werten, aber guckt mal, was ihr da im Mittelmeer veranstaltet. Auf diese Argumentation sollte man sich gefasst machen und dann ist das nicht böser What about-ism, sondern es ist ein korrekter Einwand.
Ich schließe mal daran an mit einem Hinweis auf, zum einen ich möchte unbedingt deine Besprechung von Tinder und der Parasozialen und so weiter.
Ja, ja, machen wir.
Deswegen schiebe ich wahrscheinlich mein Ernährungsthema nochmal so ein bisschen, ich sehe auf die Uhr, zu diesem Themenkomplex, Flucht und so weiter. Wir haben Fluchtgrundklima noch nicht eingepreist, selbst beim Krieg, der schon läuft und jemand sagt, wahrscheinlich werde ich nächstes Jahr eingezogen, reicht es ja nicht. Wenn man jetzt sagt, ich wohne aber in einer Region, die austrocknet, würde das ja auch nicht reichen heutzutage. Also können wir uns ja mal anschauen, wo es so austrocknet. Und keine Region trocknet derzeit so schnell aus wie Europa. Das sollte man so ein bisschen übersehen. Es gibt eine europäische Dürrebeobachtungsstelle, die natürlich bei der EU-Kommission, die ja viele solche interessanten Sachen hat, angegliedert ist. Und 2022 gilt dort als Katastrophenjahr. Das ist sozusagen das offizielle Wording. Wir haben ja jetzt mit einem Katastrophenjahr zu tun. Schlägt sich dann nieder bei Geo, dieser Zeitschrift in der Überschrift. Vermutlich schlimmste Dürre seit 500 Jahren. Man wird es nicht erst seit 30 Jahren beobachten, sondern man geht in alle historischen Daten und sagt, es war noch nie so heiß. Es gab 2022 7500 Quadratmeter Waldbrandfläche, also dreimal so viel wie der Jahresschnitt zuvor. Und 20.000 Hitzetote, die man über Übersterblichkeitsrechnung nachgerechnet hat. Dürre in Frankreich, Tagesschau, Überschrift am 21. oder so. Frankreich seit 31 Tagen ohne Regen.
31 Tagen?
Ein Monat lang kein Regen.
Und war es der Innenminister oder der Umweltminister, der jetzt in einer Talkshow in Frankreich saß und sagte, ja, wir müssen uns darauf vorbereiten und wir sind auch schon dabei, dass wir eine Erwärmung um 4 Grad haben. Also wir sprechen ja hier vom 1, 5 Grad Ziel, 2 Grad vielleicht. Jetzt wird hier ganz klar in der Talkshow gesagt, wir bereiten uns schon mal auf die 4 Grad vor.
Frankreich geht kalkuliert mit 4 Grad. Und das kann man ja nachlesen bei dem Wallace Wells, in dem die unbewohnbare Erde, dann geht er bis 8 Grad oder so die Szenarien durch und sagt schon bei 4 Grad, das ist im Grunde. Also 4 Grad weniger heißt, es liegt ein 80 Kilometer Eispanzer auf Europa. Und 4 Grad mehr heißt es genau das Gegenteil. Also es gibt nicht mal mehr Flüsse oder so.
Aber man sollte das jetzt ganz ganz ernst nehmen. Und das bedeutet auch, ich war mal bei so einer Klimakonferenz von einem Jahr und hatte dann neben diesen ganzen Jahren, was muss Europa tun, was muss Deutschland tun, gesagt, wir müssen mal daran denken, dass viele Menschen sich keine Kühlung leisten können. Ich fordere Klimaanlagen für alle. Es wurde überhaupt nicht goutiert in irgendeiner Weise. Hat gar keinen interessiert dort groß. Was redet der da? Man sieht mich dann da im Anzug sitzen und band mich dann wahrscheinlich in irgendeinem schönen Hotel. Und ich sitze da in aller Kühle. Nee, das war alles nicht gemeint. Ich rede nicht hier davon ein bisschen Luxus genießen, sondern das ist das große Thema. Und das wäre auch linke Politik im Übrigen, wenn man auch für die sorgt und die sich anpassen können, die es sich nicht vielleicht so leicht leisten können.
Ja, genau. Und damit sind erst mal vor allem auch wir Europäer gemeint, unsere konkreten Nachbarn. Im Winter sei so etwas wie in Frankreich seit Beginn der Aufzeichnung im Jahr 59 noch nicht vorgekommen, teilte der Wetterdienst Meteo France mit. Also wir haben es in Frankreich gerade mit Rekorddürre zu tun. Und übrigens ist Frankreich das Land, das uns dann wieder im Sommer erzählt, dass man die Atomkraftwerke nicht gekühlt kriegt und so. Weshalb wir hier in Gasemangellager und sowas reinrennen. Also geht schon mal gut los dieses Jahr. Norditalien kämpft um Wasser. Dürre wird immer schlimmer und Flüsse trocknen aus. 17. Februar 23, wetteronline.de In Norditalien herrscht seit über einem Jahr eine heftige Dürre. In der Pooebene trockneten mittlerweile ganze Flüsse aus und Boote liegen auf dem Grund. Der Gewässer bei den Anwohnern und Fischern macht sich immer mehr Verzweiflung breit. Also das gleiche Bild. Hier ist der Text vor allem so untermalt mit Bildern, wo du einfach, also das Foto ist einfach im Flussbett gemacht. Du hast vor dir so eine Mondlandschaft aus Flussbett und dann siehst du halt wie links so eine Stadt und der Brückenbogen noch. Also es ist einfach als Kulisse so sehr skurril. Und Spanien. Franz 24 hat ein kleines Video gemacht zum Thema Wie verhält sich es gerade in Spanien? Spanien und Portugal kennen Wasser Notstand. Portugal ist sehr darauf angewiesen, dass Wasser aus Spanien durch Portugal in den Ozean fließt. Und diese Flüsse lassen sich natürlich wegstauen, wenn man das Wasser besser in Spanien braucht. Also gibt es da eigentlich Abkommen, die das Regeln, wie das Wasser fließt, und zwar über alle Unwägbarkeiten hinweg. Also selbst wenn das eine in der Diktatur und die andere schon in der Modernität angekommen oder Weltkrieg oder was auch immer. Eigentlich war das immer geregelt. Und jetzt haben sie hier so einen Clip, wie sie so einen spanischen Bauer besuchen.
Für die letzten 44 Jahre hat Arturo Díenz das Meere des Viertels auf der Bühne des Reservoirs.
Vor diesem Sommer habe ich das Reservoirslevel nie so hoch oder so niedrig gesehen. Für das erste Mal haben wir uns über das nicht genannte Wasser zu trinken befürchtet.
Schaut euch das alte Foto an.
Das System für das Erbauen des Wassers ist komplett untergebrannt.
Zwei Monate vor dem Erbauen wurden 200 Millionen Kubikmeter Wasser in Portugal verwendet, um die Albufeira-Konvention zu erheben.
Wir konnten nicht, dass das Reservoir geöffnet wurde.
In diesem Bereich leben wir vor allem auf Farbe. Und wenn es keine Wasser gibt, müssen wir weg.
Was sollen wir tun?
So, während wir also diese afrikanische Erfahrung hören und die sagen, wir brauchen eine grundsätzliche Hinwendung zum Leben für die Menschen, für die Biosphäre, wie auch immer, sitzt der da und sagt, ich habe hier so ein Geschäft und ich kann auch nichts anderes machen, ich brauche hier Wasser für die Bewässerung meiner Felder. Liebe Regierung, kannst du mal Portugal das Wasser abdrehen und die so, ja, dass in Portugal vielleicht auch so ein Bauer rumsteht, der jetzt sagt, ich habe ja gar kein Wasser mehr und so, wird er einfach ausgeblendet. Also schon das innereuropäische Konfliktpotenzial ist hier immens. Und dann habe ich so einen Text gefunden bei Fokus, die sich zum Thema Gletscherschmelze auch auf das Jahr 2022 mal beziehen. Und das Phänomen von Peak Water vorstellen. Wir kennen ja alle Peak Oil und solche Sachen. Peak Water ist auch hochinteressant, denn im vergangenen Jahr gingen die Gletscher, das verbliebene Eis, um 6, 2% zurück. Bislang war das Rekordjahr der Jahrhundertsommer 2003. Damals ging es um 3, 8% zurück. Wir haben jetzt fast eine Nahezu Verdopplung auf 3, 2 Kilometer Wasser, das verloren geht. In diesem Text geht man die Gletscherszenarien durch. Denn wir haben weltweit Gletscher, die zum Beispiel im Himalajahr 1, 5 Milliarden Menschen mit Frischwasser versorgen. In den Anden ist die Gletschermasse um 27 Prozent zurückgegangen, Teile von Russland und Nordasien minus 35 Prozent. Das Volumen geht so richtig runter. Peak Water bezeichnet nun folgendes Phänomen. Die großen französischen Flüsse der Rhein entspringen alle in den Alpen. Und jetzt hat man in den Alpen Gletscher, die schrumpfen. Und solange sie schrumpfen, fließt ja auch Wasser ab. Sogar in Rekordmengen. Also wir haben ja eigentlich eine Trockenlage. Es sind ja nicht nur die Gletscherwasser, die hier die Flüsse füllen, sondern auch Regenwasser und Schmelzwasser aus dem Winter und so. Nur wenn man, so wie dieses Jahr, keinen richtigen Schneefall hat. Wir haben es ja gesehen, wie nur noch so diese weisen Beschneiten für die Touristen gemacht werden. Aber die Gebirge an sich keinen Schmelzwasser mehr liefern und die Gletscher zurückgehen. Dann hat man es grundsätzlich schon mal, durch das fehlende Schmelzwasser mit niedrigen Wasserständen zu tun. Die Gletscher schmelzen aber gerade im Rekordtempo, liefern also noch gerade besonders viel Wasser. Nur wenn die dann einmal weg sind, ist von heute auf morgen einfach Schluss. Der Gletscher schmilzt so lange, wie er schmilzt. Und umso wärmer es ist, umso schneller. Also sind die Flüsse noch voll. Aber dann hast du quasi so einen richtigen Tipping-Point. Und dann fehlen da einfach 20, 25, 30 Prozent des ganzen Zuflusses. Und dann kannst du einfach alles, was wir bisher nutzen, also sowohl Frischwasserversorgung als auch Transportwege und so weiter, fallen dann einfach aus. Wir haben es also jetzt gerade und noch die nächsten 10 bis 20 Jahre mit einem maximalen Wasseroutput zu tun. Und danach ist einfach Schicht im Schacht, sagt ja Bettina Scheffli, so eine Hydrologin an der Universität Bern. Also Peak Water sollte man sich nochmal anschauen, was das so bedeutet, wenn hier plötzlich alles auf einmal dann ausfällt.
Und müsste das nicht auch dann schon bei Bauvorschriften mit eingepreist sein? Müsste es nicht so sein, dass man Cisternen haben muss? Müsste es nicht so sein, dass Pools verboten werden in Privathäusern? Also so etwas. Da wären ja alles zumindest kleine Maßnahmen, die sinnvoll sind. Oder dass Rasen gesprengt werden, besprengt, dass den ganzen Sommer über damit man saftig grüne Wiesen hat und solche Geschichten. Wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass das immer noch geht, wo man ja sonst auch Bauschriften hat, wo vieles nicht mehr möglich ist, was man ohne Weiteres in den 80er Jahren noch tat?
Ja, also jetzt wo du das ansprichst, komme ich ja noch kurz auf einen Text in der Zeit zu sprechen, der genau das sich damit beschäftigt. Die Proposition 30, eine Klimagesetzpaket in Kalifornien. Also da gibt es eine Coalition for Clean Air zum Beispiel. Und das ist so eine dieser Organisationen, die sich da sehr für eingesetzt haben. Deren Ziel war, jeder, der mehr als zwei Millionen Dollar pro Jahr verdient, bezahlt 1, 75 Prozent extra Einkommenssteuer, die zweckgebunden nur zum Thema Klimaschutz investiert werden, beispielsweise um Wasserreservoirs zu bauen und Leute solche Sachen. Diese Gesetze werden natürlich torpediert. Also es ginge hier um 3, 5 bis 5 Milliarden extra Dollar im Jahr. Dann kommen aber zum Beispiel die Feuerwehrleute, die sich dafür aussprechen, weil ja sie davon profitieren würden, dass der eine oder andere Wald ein bisschen anders schon vorher geschützt wird und es dann gar nicht erst zu diesen krassen Feuerdingern kommt, wo sie dann sozusagen im Brandherren stehen und ihr Leben opfern müssen. Dagegen stehen aber zum Beispiel die Lehrer, die ihrerseits sagen, wir sind sehr für eine Steuer von den Reichen, aber bitte doch nicht zweckgebunden auf die Sachen, von denen wir gar nichts haben. Also man hätte dann eine Reichensteuer eingeführt, wofür die Lehrer sehr sind, aber es wäre keine, von der die Lehrer profitieren oder ihr, sondern die wäre dann sozusagen erstmal weg für die nächsten Jahrzehnte. Zweckgebunden, nicht in ihrem Milieu. Dann lieber gar keine. Dann lieber jetzt die Klimasteuer torpedieren, um danach einen Anlauf zu nehmen, die reichen Steuern auf die eigene Seite zu ziehen. Und dann kämpfen natürlich alle mit. Da kommt dann auch Re-Testings hinter Netwingsgründer und gibt halt auch eine Million Euro für die No-Kampagne.
Ach ja.
Keine Ahnung warum.
Vielleicht weil er noch Geld überhatte von dem Erfolg von Don't Look Up?
Zum Beispiel. Ja, da steckt Humor drin. Einer der ganz Großen, die dafür waren, waren der Fahrtdienstleister Lyft, der so mit Uber konkurriert. Und da geht es wahrscheinlich auch sehr darum, dass diese Chefetage da wirklich dran gelegen war, dass Kalifornien so lebenswert bleibt und so. Nur das wurde dann öffentlich so gedreht, dass die ja davon profitieren, dass die E-Flotten, also dass die Erneuerung der Flotten Unterstützung bekommen, um auf E-Mobilität, dass sie davon sehr profitieren. Es wurde dann nachgewiesen, es ist gar nicht so. Profitieren gar nicht über die Maßen. Aber es wurde halt massenmedial so dargestellt. Und der größte Gegner am Ende war aber tatsächlich Gavin Newsom, der Gouverneur, der ja zum einen diese ganze Wockelschiene fährt und sagt, wir sind Klimavorreiter, wir machen alles und so weiter. Aber er möchte Präsident werden. Und die Unterstellung ist, er kann es sich nicht mit den Superreichen verderben, die seine Präsidentschaftskampagne bezahlen sollen. Also hat er sich dann doch zu einem No durchgerungen. Und damit ist das Ding wieder vom Tisch genommen worden. Es ist ein großes Drama, gerade weil dieser Text, also ein sehr ausführlicher Zeittext, nochmal auch so darstellt, wie krass Kalifornien gebeutelt wird. Eben von diesem. Und naja, eine kleine Pointe, die ist noch ganz interessant. Oxfam veröffentlicht ja immer Zahlen zum Reichtum. Also diese einmal im Jahr vor Davos kommt Oxfam und sagt, vier Leute besitzen mehr als die Hälfte der Welt und so. Und das wusste ich gar nicht, aber seit Kurzem veröffentlichen die auch immer den CO2-Fußabdruck dieser Reichen dazu.
Ach ja.
Also die fahren da auch in ihre eigene Linie, dass sie jetzt ihre Aufmerksamkeit nutzen. Immer gleich darzustellen, so und so viele Leute besitzen so und so viel und leben 30-mal den Durchschnittsfußabdruck oder 35-mal oder 40-mal. Das sind die Faktoren, die da drin sind.
Und da gibt es auch dann eine Top Ten.
Also es gibt zum jeden Fall zum Reichtum eine Top Ten und da auch. Ja, also man kann die Top Ten nach Reichtum durchnehmen. Also das Forbes-Ding macht ja mehr so, dieses Top Ten-Ding. Aber diese Zahl, vier Leute haben so und so viel Geld und verbrauchen aber so und so viel CO2. Also es sind tatsächlich die Top Zehn Prozent, die hier, also in den reichen Ländern sind es schon die Top Zehn Prozent, die hauptsächlich fürs Klima verantwortlich sind. Also die Reichensteuer da anzusetzen, ist genau richtig. Thomas Piketty macht das auch. Der hat da so ein World Inequality Lab mit dem Co-Direktor Lukas Chancel, der wohl seit einer Weile sehr hart daran arbeitet, das in so eine Gesetzesform zu gießen, die dann auch anschlussfähig ist. Kalifornien war halt so einer dieser großen Versuche, wo man das mal vorbereitet hat. Es hat dann dort nicht geklappt. Aber vielleicht ist das auch so eine europäische Idee, dass man es dann hier ein bisschen besser unterkriegt.
Wir glauben aber nicht wirklich dran.
Ja, also der Chancel weist schon mal darauf hin hier, Zitat, wie hoch ein CO2-Fußabdruck ist, hängt mittlerweile weniger davon ab, wo ein Mensch lebt, als davon, ob er innerhalb dieses Landes zu den Armen oder Reichen gehört. Denn der deutsche Durchschnittsbürger oder der Französische ist schon bei sechs Tonnen. Also wenn wir die Reichen zehn Prozent mal wegnehmen, haben wir unser Klimaziel schon erreicht. Das sind dann die Top-10 Prozent, die nochmal alles mit verursachen.
Aber ich vermute, es wird eher andersrum sein, dass die, die wenig verbrauchen, noch mal weniger verbrauchen können auf grundgestiegener Preise. Oder weil man ihnen noch mal sagt, du versetzt ab sofort nicht mehr mit deinem Kleinwagen in die Stadt hinein. Wenn die anderen, du hattest es mir mal in Frankfurt gezeigt, zum Teil eingeflohen werden zum Flughafen, also die fahren gar nicht mehr mit dem Auto durch die Gegend. Das ist eher für uns Kleinbürger noch was. Und die werden aber dann bestimmt auch auf wichtigen Panels sagen, dass sie sich gerade sehr weiterentwickeln, was Klima und Nachhaltigkeit anbelangt. Hör ich jetzt viel. Hör ja viel auch so Marketing und Luxuspodcasts und so was. Und da ist das, glaubst gar nicht, wie partizipativ auch Jachten sein können, wenn man sie einfach für eine Million noch mal mieten kann. Man muss sie nicht immer gleich besitzen.
Also das Top 1% verbraucht 101 Tonnen pro Person, pro Jahr. Und alle anderen sind schon bei 6% angekommen. Also man kann zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe. Ist natürlich blöd, wenn man das als allererstes pionierarbeitsmäßig, legislativ in der Region, wo die meisten Milliardäre wohnen, probiert, in Kalifornien.
Aber auch am sinnvollsten.
Dort wäre es allerdings auch am sinnvollsten. Also in der Ansicht geht es drunter und drüber.
Aber ich bin sehr froh, dass ich die Menschen in der Zeitung noch nicht so viel von den anderen Menschen aus der Welt habe. Ich habe ein sehr, sehr interessantes Interview gehört im Deutschlandfunk Kultur mit Johanna Degen. Und es ist sehr gut, sich dem mal zu stellen, was sie da sagt. Denn erstmal ist interessant, dass Johanna Degen über das Daten zu ihrem Forschungsthema gelangt ist. Und sie erzählt dabei jetzt in diesem Interview erst einmal ein bisschen, wie sie das mit dem Dating angegangen ist. Wir hören da jetzt mal rein, wenn sie zum Beispiel in ein Hotel in Flensburg bad, um dort die Treffen zu arrangieren.
Und habe mich zum Beispiel jeden Mittwoch, da hatte ich Kinderbetreuung, dann in einem Hotel getroffen, im Hotelhafen Flensburg. Das ist ein schickeres Hotel, mit dem ich mich dann getroffen habe, sollte auch bereit sein, mal für einen Gin Tonic, keine Ahnung, 19 Euro auszugeben. Das war die erste Hürde. Also bin ich dir das wert?
Ja, was bin ich wert? Das ist eigentlich die Grundfrage, die sich natürlich stellt bei diesen ganzen Dating-Portalen, die es gibt. Inwieweit bin ich gefragt? Und das ist ja inzwischen unglaublich zugespitzt. Also es ist ja doch interessant, dass viele Dating-Apps nicht nur einfach eine Mitgliedschaft anbieten, sondern dann gibt es ja die Bezahlmitgliedschaft. Und die Bezahlmitgliedschaft renkt dich dann auch schon mal besser. Das ist jetzt so, wie man jetzt auch bei Twitter sich den blauen Haken kaufen kann. Und dann gibt es ja noch die Möglichkeit, dass man sein Profil bewerben kann. Also wie ich ja auch jetzt bei YouTube meine Videos bewerben könnte, Geld ausgebe oder Posts bei Facebook bewerben könnte, so kann ich auch mein Profil bewerben. Also dass das möglichst vielen angezeigt wird.
Also bei Tinder wirst du angehalten, sowieso schon mal zu bezahlen. Und dann kriegst du immer diesen, wenn du jetzt auf den Knopf drückst, wirst du für eine halbe Stunde lang zehnmal so viel angezeigt.
Ach ja.
Die Leuten. Und dann kostet das halt extra. Und dann soll das die Wahrscheinlichkeit erhöhen, dass jemand auf dein Profil reagiert.
Das heißt, wir haben hier schon mal eine ganz klare Hierarchie durch Geld drin. Also wer zahlt, ist schon mal der häufiger gesehene. Und wir haben damit natürlich auch einen extremen Konkurrenzkampf. Und man kann also mit Geld sehr viel regeln. Sie wollte jetzt mal prüfen, was bin ich wert. Gibt da mehr jemand auch einen teuren Drink aus? Sie sagt dann weiter.
Und dann habe ich gerne versucht, mal jemanden aus Hamburg dazu zu kriegen, hochzufahren. Also ich habe so ein bisschen auch getestet. Investieren die? Investieren, die bin ich denn spannend genug. Und auch, was bin ich eigentlich noch wert als junge Mutter? Ist vielleicht auch nicht so der Moment, an dem man sich am wertvollsten fühlt?
Ich meine, zunächst einmal ist es nachvollziehbar, dass man gucken will, was bin ich wert, beziehungsweise was ist jemand bereit zu investieren. Zugleich ist diese Datingplattform aufgrund dieses einfachen Matchens ja darauf ausgelegt, dass es keine großen Hürden hat. Also dass man nicht extra in ein Tanzcafé gehen muss, so wie früher. Und jetzt sagt man aber, naja, aber so ein Treffen, das kann ja dann am Tag fünf Stück sein. Aber bin ich jetzt auch ein besonderes Treffen. Da kommt jetzt noch eine neue Hürde dazu. Wir lassen mal jemanden von weiter anfangen. Also ist der Person das auch wert? Und dann sagt sie aber auch ganz klar, dass sie Fehler gemacht hat.
Und dann habe ich aber auch lauter blöde Sachen gemacht, die ich überhaupt nicht empfehlen würde. Zum Beispiel das mit den Kindern verheimlicht. Also ich habe das nicht gesagt. Und das gab natürlich auch total blöde Situationen. Also viele sagen dann, man sieht dir das auch gar nicht an. Denke ich immer, was soll man denn da auch so sehen?
Finde ich ganz interessant, dass sie also auch ein Image sich da aufgebaut hat, das dann nicht absolut der Realität entspricht. Das ist ja was, was nun seit es diese Datingplattform gibt, bekannt ist, dass man irgendetwas von sich kreiert, was dann nicht so ist.
Das ist halt die Frage, was sie suchte. Weil Kinder verheimlichen ist ja wie, ja klar, haben wir gegenseitige Eltern, aber die müssen wir uns ja nicht zeigen. Also das ist ja mittlerweile auch gang und gäbe.
Aber wenn man nicht sagt, dass man Mutter ist.
Ja, aber wenn man wirklich nur alle zwei Wochen auf eine Date Night gehen will und ansonsten gar nicht groß an Beziehungen interessiert ist.
Na, ich glaube, hier ging es schon darum, jemand Neues zu suchen. Also ich glaube, es ging jetzt nicht darum, also klar, wenn man jetzt einfach nur Sex-Thingen, wie das ja heißt, macht, da muss man nicht jedes Mal noch sagen. Und übrigens, ich habe zwei Kinder, das wäre ja unsinnig. Da wäre genauso, wenn man sagen würde, wo man, weiß ich nicht, welchen Beruf man exakt hat oder so. Das ist natürlich dann nicht notwendig. Aber es ging jetzt hier schon da, dass man erst so ein Image aufbaut. Und was ist aber dann, wenn die Realität einbricht? Wie lang kann ich dieses Image aufrecht erhalten? Es ist ja doch bei dieser Datinggeschichte so eine Sache, dass es so eine, also man ist auf diesen Plattformen, hat alle Möglichkeiten und zugleich auch keine Möglichkeiten, ist die ganze Zeit dort beschäftigt und ist aber nicht besonders glücklich. Und das ist eigentlich ein großes Thema. Das kennen wir ja auch von Twitter oder Instagram. Man verbringt dort viel Zeit, zu viel Zeit, würde fast jeder sagen. Und es ist aber nicht so, dass man dort gerne viel Zeit verbringt, aber man verbringt sie doch dort. Und das ist so etwas, was sie beschäftigt. Und sie kommt dann von sich als Person weg. Also sie wollte nur mal sagen, ich habe auch damit zu tun. Meine Forschung, die reicht mitten ins Leben hinein. Und jetzt geht sie aber dazu über, ein bisschen mal zu erläutern, was sind eigentlich parasoziale Beziehungen? Denn das ist ja eine Begrifflichkeit, die häufiger inzwischen zu hören ist.
Früher war parasoziales, wenn ich ein Fan war und ich hatte zum Beispiel einen Schauspieler, den ich toll fand. Das war parasozial, also irgendwie einseitig. Ich habe dann alle Filme geguckt, mir Poster gekauft. Und heute verändert sich das aber so, dass wir zum Beispiel Follower sind von Influencern oder wir verbringen eben sehr viel Zeit damit im digitalen Online Dating.
Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, aber hat sich dann überhaupt so viel verändert? Ob man jetzt Elvis an der Wand hängen hat, ob man irgendeine Teenie-Band toll findet oder ob man jetzt Influencern folgt. Wo ist da eigentlich der Unterschied? Und sie macht aber einen, finde ich, sehr guten aus.
Und das, was dann passiert, jetzt gucken wir mal, das ist nämlich spezifisch. Wenn ich groovy bin oder ich gehe auf viele Konzerte und hoffe, ich treffe meinen Star oder ich sehe bei einer Filmpremiere meinen Star, dann hatte ich trotzdem noch das Erlebnis. Ich bin nach Kalifornien geflogen und habe vielleicht einen anderen Fan kennengelernt. Oder ich hatte dieses Erlebnis. Und wenn ich früher in eine Diskothek gegangen bin mit Freunden, dann hatte ich vielleicht noch einen schönen Abend oder...
Ja, heute aber. Naja, also wir haben schon, wenn wir eine parasoziale Beziehung haben, nicht unbedingt ist diese Beziehung alle umfassend, sondern beziehungsweise wir haben Möglichkeiten, dann zum Beispiel auf ein Konzert zu gehen. Und haben natürlich dann ein Erlebnis, das jetzt Instagram uns nicht gibt.
Das stimmt. Wenn man die Leute, die man bei Tinder so trifft, und da ist ja im Grunde nur Chatten gemein, nicht in Wirklichkeit trifft, hat man sie niemals erlebt. Und ich habe ja damals für Redaktionsschluss mit Dirk Becker gesprochen, der ja dann in meinem Buch auch so diese Idee aufmachte. Wenn man jetzt so chattet, man hat Brieffreunde, aber in digitaler Form, also ein bisschen häufiger als man macht immer so diese kleine Kommunikation zwischendurch. Aber das gilt dann eben auch für Leute, die man schon kennt, dass man doch mehr mit der Maschine kommuniziert als in echt. Denn wenn man jetzt so stundenlang irgendwas schreibt, das hätte man ja in einem Gespräch innerhalb von drei Sekunden geklärt. Also das sind ja so Wortwechsel, die zieht man so in eine ewige Länge. Man beschäftigt sich also sehr viel mit einer Maschine, in die man das so reintippt und dann auf Antwort wartet und so. Und das hätte man in einer echten Kommunikation viel schneller gelöst. Und dieser Art der, wir haben es mit einer Maschine zu tun, ist insbesondere interessant, wenn man ja beim Dating im Speziellen, nicht nur den Gegenüber, sondern auch sich selber, das Verhältnis zu sich selber, die ganze Zeit beobachtet jetzt, denn es gibt dieses Phänomen, das hat Scott Galloway, das ist immer mal wieder. Also Scott Galloway sieht ja in seinem Podcast Pivot, immer wieder die Gefahr, wie soll man sagen, als einen wohlwollenden Blick auf die Insel und die politische Gefahr, die so ein bisschen da drin steckt. Dass sehr viele junge Männer so gar nicht mehr wissen, wie gestalte ich jetzt überhaupt irgendeine Beziehung, auch Freundschaften oder zu den eigenen Eltern und da eben auch. Denn eigentlich ist ja die Eheanbahnung, um mal dieses ganz alte Bild zu bemühen, immer an Situationen geknüpft gewesen. Schule, Studium, Ausbildungsplatz, Arbeitsplatz. Jetzt wurde in Amerika der Arbeitsplatz ausgeräumt. Einfach juristisch steht nicht mehr zur Verfügung. Du darfst nicht am Arbeitsplatz und es wird ja auch sehr vielen zu echt großen Verhängnissen, dass sie dann da plötzlich Liebschaften anfangen.
Und generell gilt das für viele Unternehmen, ne? Das ist also nicht mehr nur hierarchische Unternehmen, sondern auch Mitarbeiter untereinander. Das ist auch schon ein Problem.
Ja, also in Amerika kann sich auf, also da, wo man in sozialen Situationen ist, wo man andere Menschen erlebt und auch über Zeit kennenlernt und so einige Vorzüge oder so zu schätzen weiß, oder zu schätzen lernt, da ist diese Art von Liebesbonding verboten. Sondern das müssen streng professionelle Verhältnisse bleiben.
Womit die Firmen dann versuchen, dass nie irgendein Skandal oder was?
Genau, man will ja keinen Skandal, aber man kann die Produktivität hochhalten und lauter solche Sachen.
Es ist ja, und das, ich meine, das wird auch ein Zokia halten, wirst du noch sehen.
Ja, wird noch kommen. Springer ist ja krass auf die Fresse gefallen in Amerika, als man hier diese Meduian Reichelt.
Na gut, aber da ging es ja um eine klare Hierarchie wohl. Oder ja, da kommen ja immer irgendwelche heraus, aber dann sagen wir, bevor so was wie so eine Reicheltsgeschichte kommt, dann untersagen wir es lieber ganz.
Genau, die Reicheltssache wäre ja unter juristischen Gesichtspunkten in Deutschland gar nicht so heikel gewesen. Aber weil es diese große Investitionsbemühungen in Amerika gibt, war das für Springer ein absolutes No-Go, dass plötzlich in der New York Times diese Art der Machenschaften in der Belegschaft publik wurden.
Nur frage ich mich, wie kommen Menschen damit klar? Also es ist ja völlig logisch, dass man im Arbeitsumfeld hauptsächlich sicher umtut.
Genau, und das ist nämlich der Punkt.
Und dort trifft man auf Leute, die man potenziell attraktiv findet.
Genau.
Und das ist das Risiko des Lebens, dass man eingeht, dass man Menschen attraktiv finden könnte und vielleicht sogar noch mehr.
Genau, und deswegen hast du jetzt eine Co-Evolution von zwei Phänomen. Zum einen der Arbeitsplatz als raumgebundene, interaktionslastige Situationen, in der man sich befindet, fällt aus.
Aber die haben doch einen Knall.
Und die Dating-Apps kommen.
Ja, und da kann man dann aber nicht den Kollegen treffen.
Wenn du ihn da triffst, kannst du ja so unter der Hand irgendwie, keine Ahnung, aber du kannst nicht den Arbeitsplatz nutzen. Genau, du kannst nicht auf dem Arbeitsplatz anfangen zu flirten oder so, weil das immer gleich als Belästigung angesehen wird. So, also der Arbeitsplatz fällt aus, die echte soziale Begegnung fällt aus für Anwandelungen, aber der Datingmarkt über die Apps kommt plötzlich.
Und das Fitnessstudio ist ja auch ein sehr eigenartiger Ort.
Es gab jetzt einen Beitrag.
Ja, ich will aber auf einen Beitrag verweisen, deswegen ziehen wir uns aus der Affäre. Und zwar von Gnu, das ist eine Streamerin, eine sehr bekannte deutsche Streamerin. Die hatte nämlich jetzt einen Beitrag dazu über die Frage, inwieweit im Fitnessstudio man als sexuelles Wesen betrachtet wird oder nicht. Und sie hat dann darauf verwiesen, dass es wohl bei TikTok einen Trend gibt, dass junge Frauen Männer abfilmen, die gucken, wie sie Sport machen. Aber bei vielen ist überhaupt nicht klar, gucken die überhaupt dahin? Oder ist das jetzt, also klar, da guckt man ja auch jemand. Und ich weiß, man kommt ja jetzt auf ganz, ganz dünnes Eis, auf das ich mich bewege. Deswegen will ich nur auf dieses Video. Gnu erklärt das, was da ist und wo sie das Problem sieht und sagt, natürlich kann man auch jemanden attraktiv finden. Und natürlich kann man auch mal dahin gucken. Und ich höre, dass das Fitnessstudio aber sehr stark ein asexueller Raum fasst. Das sagen wir so, wie ich mir vorstelle, man am FKK-Strand herum rennt, also ohne sexuelles Begehren. Aber zugleich ist irgendwie liegt so alles auf der Hand. Und auch die Mode hat sich ja sowohl bei den Herren, bei den Damen verknapte, sagen wir mal. Aber trotzdem ist der Körper, der dort trainiert wird und der wird eigentlich einem sehr stark sexualisierten Ideal angeglichen. Ich würde sagen, dass die Pornografie einen erheblichen Einfluss darauf hat, wie Körper im Fitnessstudio geformt werden. Und zugleich wird es aber da nicht stattfinden. Und dann erzählte mir aber mein Friseur, er behauptete, zwischen den Sätzen sitzen ja alle immer dort mit ihren Smartphones und er sagt, ja, man hat nicht diese Blicke. Dann vielleicht, man guckt dann auf den entsprechenden Apps nach, ist hier jemand auf dem Umfeld.
Also es ist ein sehr großer Diskurs gerade. Es gibt nicht nur ein Video von GNU oder so, sondern ganz YouTube ist voll mit dieser Debatte. Und es ist insbesondere verlogen und das Argument ist schnell gemacht. Und man kann es nicht noch raffinierter machen. Das Fitnessstudio ist ein Ort, in dem es um nichts anderes geht, als den Körper hin zu einer sexuell attraktiveren Figur zu formen. Im Fitnessstudio trainiert man nicht speziell nach irgendwelchen Muskeln, die man für den Sport, den man eh macht, braucht oder so was. Sondern da geht es wirklich nur darum, in 99, 9% Sexia zu sehen.
Was aber auch ja nicht schlimm ist, würde man jetzt sagen.
Was gar nicht schlimm ist.
Wir reden noch viel über Sexpositivity, da könnte man doch sagen, es ist ja schön, wenn Menschen Lust an ihrem eigenen Körper oder daran haben, einen Körper zu haben, mit dem man dann sexuell mehr machen, mehr ansteigen kann.
Es geht auch um Fähigkeiten, nicht nur um Aussehen, sondern auch um Ausdauerfähigkeiten und Beweglichkeit, der ganze Kram. Jetzt hat man dieses Phänomen, das finde ich sehr merkwürdig, denn wenn ich ins Fitnessstudio gehe, ziehe ich mir die schlappesten Sachen irgendwie an. Frauen immer hauteng. Ich habe das nie verstanden. Warum ziehen sie sich immer so hauteng an? Und sehr viele, und das sehe ich jetzt auch schon in meinem Fitnessstudio, filmen sich ab, während sie Sport machen. Und zwar nur, um möglichst viel Publikum über soziale Netze anzuziehen. Gleichzeitig ist aber der eine konkrete Blick vor Ort, der raumgebundene Blick, wo ein echter Körper dranhängt, weil der Mann, der zuschaut, nur drei Meter entfernt ist, der es untersagt und wird auch immer mehr verpönt.
Aber zugleich haben wir doch denselben dran. Du magst sein, dass du dann in Schlapperklamotten gehst, und das glaube ich dir natürlich sofort.
Nee, die Männer sind recht locker angezogen.
Nee, nee. Vielleicht bist du bei so einem Gesundheitsding, so einem Rehaarsport. Nein, aber ich kenne ja die Fitnessinfluencer und kenne ja diese ganzen Insta-Stories. Und was ich feststelle, sind eigentlich drei Outfits. Also das eine ist natürlich das Posen in der Umkleidekabine mit freiem Oberkörper, um zu zeigen, was man gemacht hat.
Das heißt aber nicht mehr posen, das heißt jetzt flexen.
Ach so, das heißt flexen. Entschuldigung. Und dann haben die Jungs entweder Tanktops an, die also Leibchen in meinen Augen sind, die tiefer ausgehen. Also irgendwas haben sie noch angezogen, damit sie könnten aber auch fast oberkörperfrei gehen. Oder sie haben eigentlich als Pendant zu den Frauen diese hautengen Geschichten an, die dann auch alles genau abzeichnen wie eine Leggins.
Ich muss es ja leider kurz mensplänen als jemand, der wirklich vor Ort ist. Ich habe noch nie einen Mann gesehen, der sich im Fitnessstudio beim Sport abfilmt.
Aber wie kommen die ganzen Insta-Sachen zustande, die ich sehe?
Na ja, Menschen filmen sich im Fitnessstudio. Nur das ist ja wieder dieses Social-Media-Ding. Klar, die ganze Welt connectet sich und deine Schulfreunde finden sie trotzdem nicht bei Facebook, weil die da sich nie angemeldet haben. Und so ist das auch ein bisschen. Ja, 0, 01 Prozent der Männer flexen im Fitnessstudio auch vor ihrer eigenen Social-Media-Kamera und denen ist das auch nicht peinlich, obwohl sie von allen peinlich angeschaut werden, wenn sie das da machen. Also es ist noch nicht so on vogue, dass jedes Fitnessstudio gleichzeitig eine Bühne ist, die man einfach so mal für sich benutzen kann, sondern wenn da jemand seine Kamera hinstellt, kommen schon zwei Leute und fragen, filmst du mich hier gerade und so? Aus Versehen. Also es ist noch nicht so normal, wie es sich auf YouTube immer wirkt, wenn die da in diesen amerikanischen Riesenhorts, wo nur junge Leute und so, da scheint es anders zu sein. Aber ich habe schon erlebt, obwohl es für Männer immer noch, also Männer ziehen sich einfach ein T-Shirt an oder irgendwas Haut, also freies, nicht hauteng, sondern dann sind halt die Arme frei oder so und machen halt ihren Sport. Frauen immer hauteng. Ich habe niemanden in einem schlapperen T-Shirt gesehen. Also ich verstehe es nicht so ganz. Und diese Diskussion, die jetzt gerade läuft, mit diesem, ich nutze das Fitnessstudio als Bühne, um mich zu zeigen, aber nur für abwesendes Publikum. Dem Anwesenden ist es strengstens verboten, auch mal rüberzulunsten. Das finde ich irgendwie crazy. Also da geht eine Diskussion nicht zum ersten Mal, aber mal eine wieder völlig außerhand.
Das scheint das Thema von Knu in diesem Video zu sein, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe. Und ich glaube, dass man aber, ich meine, man kann ja niemanden, wir wollen hier nicht, dass das irgendwie missverstanden wird, wir wollen ja hier niemanden sagen, wie sie sich anzuzählen. Ich glaube nur, dass man einfach eine ganz positive, selbstbewusste Verbindung dazu ziehen soll. Also klar gibt es da irgendwelche Arschlöcher, die einen doof anmachen oder so, völlig klar. Aber jetzt mal von diesen Ausnahmen da abgesehen, sollte es doch eher darum gehen, dass man sagt, es ist ja schön.
Ja, aber der dreht zurück zum Dating. Und deswegen sehe ich da so eine große Gefahr. Das, was wir bei den jungen Frauen im Fitnessstudio sehen, nämlich diese totale Selbstbeschäftigung mit sich und ihrem medialen Bild und erst machen die Männer doch jetzt lassen wir mal das Argument machen. Also man ist im Fitnessstudio als Frau und filmt sich ab. Und zwar anders als das Männer machen. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Bei Männern sehe ich das doch nicht so. Die Frauen filmen sich ab und suchen sich aber für die Publikation dessen, was sie von sich produzieren, den Self-Space aus, dass sie selber noch mal editieren wollen. Also man darf nicht im Making-of schon zuschauen, sondern erst sie filmen sich ab. Sie legen einen Filter drauf, sie schneiden es zurecht. Dann wird es veröffentlicht mit irgendeiner Musik. Und dann dürfen aber alle zugucken. Sie brauchen also eine Bühne, auf der sie nicht alleine sind. Das ist nicht ihr Fitnessstudio, sondern in der auch Männer anwesend sind. Machen dort eine mega sexy Show. Männer belästigen sie nicht, sondern gucken halt mal so rüber aus zehn Metern Entfernung. Das kommt dann mit drauf in dieses Video. Deswegen gibt es ja so viele Artefakte von genau diesem Zustand.
Genau, und dann werden da so TikTok virale Hits rausgekriegt.
Das ist dann plötzlich, das ist überall und so, das wird dann so plötzlich hochgejesst. So, und jetzt haben wir dieses Phänomen. Das Fitnessstudio als dieser raumgebundene Feld aus, so wie viele andere Bereiche, Arbeitsplatz und so weiter. Dem Mann wird es verboten, die Frau auch nur anzusehen, geschweigenden anzusprechen. Gleichzeitig nutzt aber die Frau diesen Ort. Hör zu, ist jetzt in dieser schon Abdimension, die Scott Galloway so schlimm findet, weil nämlich das Dating heute nur noch auf, ich pflege oder ich kümmere mich nicht um eine Situation und es geht mir auch nicht um andere, sondern ich sehe erst mal nur mein Profil. Ich kann ja nur an meinem Profil arbeiten. Ich kann ja keine Situation gestalten, denn der andere ist ja noch nicht da. Also arbeitet man ewig lange an der Auswahl seiner Profilbilder, an den Texten, die man da drauf schreibt, und ist aber ganz in sich. Und das macht Leute wahnsinnig unglücklich. Dass sie nicht von anderen die Reaktion auf ihr Verhalten bekommen, sondern selber abschätzen müssen, ist das jetzt sexy genug? Ist das jetzt gut genug? Ist dieser Text lustig genug? Und kein Korrektiv zu bekommen, sondern nur in sich selbst, im infiniten Regress, mit sich selber zu sein, obwohl man sich der Welt präsentieren will. Das bieten dir alle Dating-Apps, aber das ist auch alles, was sie bieten.
Stefan, ich stimme dir in allem zu, aber ich glaube, was du völlig verkennst, ist die Emanzipation, nämlich die Emanzipation der Männer, was die Ästhetik anbelangt, nämlich dort bei den Männern. Und ich rede jetzt wirklich von den 17-
18-
19- 20-Jährigen. Da ist das genauso anzutreffen, wie das, was du jetzt für Frauen beschrieben hast. Ja, kann auch sein. Das mag sein, dass das in deiner Alterskohorte nicht der Fall ist. Es würde mich auch ein bisschen sehr amüsieren, wenn du das jetzt erzählst. Aber du hast, ich habe die Fitnessinfluencer, ich habe sie ihnen ja gefolgt. Ich habe mir die Videos der Elevator Boys bei TikTok und so weiter angesehen. Die Jungs kreieren von sich das perfekte Cuteness-Bild mit Sixpack und einem boyischen Lächeln, dass es ja die Pose der Jungs ist. Man streckt die Zunge raus und zeigt Zähne dabei zugleich. Also sagt damit einiges aus. Also es sind sexuelle Posen und man optimiert in der Insta-Story oder bei TikTok sich gleichermaßen und inszeniert sich wie die Frauen. Und wenn ich an den Fitnessstudios auch in Kopen zu vorbei fahre, da sind Selfie-Sticks und die werden auch von Männern gehalten. Ich glaube, dass wir da eine absolute Angleichung erleben, was ja völlig logisch ist, da ja sowohl die Frauen mit diesen perfekten Bildern dann auf Tinder erscheinen, als auch die Männer darauf erscheinen, mal von den...
Ach so, darum ging es mir gar nicht.
Genau, weil du das so auf die Frau, die gesehen werden will und nicht gesehen wird.
Rein analytisch, da gibt es keinen Streitpunkt. Warte, da gibt es keinen Streitpunkt.
Da sind beide Geschlechter gleich auch.
Wir können jetzt analytisch sagen, für jede Frau, die das macht, wie ich es beschrieben habe, gibt es auch einen Mann.
Garantiert.
Aber der Unterschied, um den es mir geht, ist folgender. Wenn ein Mann das macht und eine Frau guckt mal rüber, oder geht vielleicht sogar zu ihm und spricht ihm an, würde der Mann das nicht als Belästigung aufgreifen. Und den Frauen wird aber gerade gesagt, dass jeder Blick Belästigung ist.
Das ist natürlich sehr schwierig dann in der Geschlechterkonstellation. Gut, man kann es zum einen natürlich nachvollziehen, wenn man bedenkt, dass wann immer Frau und Mann aufeinandertreffen, es eine Historie gibt, die mitschwingt, also die des Patriarchats. Jetzt kann man sagen, dass es weitgehend überwunden oder noch nicht genug überwunden. Jedenfalls gab es das Patriarchat und das steht auch in gewisser Weise zwischen Mann und Frau noch immer. Das bedeutet auch, dass gewisse Wünsche, die artikuliert werden oder Begehrlichkeiten, die ausgesprochen werden, immer vor diesem Hintergrund irgendwie auch präsent sind. Johanna Degen sagt das an einer Stelle des Interviews, dass sie auch zum Beispiel Jungs, die sich mit 16, 17 mal homophob äußern, denen darf man nicht dann als Lehrer oder was gleich sagen, du bist ein Menschenfeind, sondern man muss mit denen über Männlichkeit reden, denn welche Männlichkeitsvorstellungen haben die, dass sie zu solch homophoben Aussagen kommen? Aber um zurückzukommen zu dem Thema, also das heißt, wenn Mann und Frau sich begegnen, ist da diese Geschichte der Unterdrückung, ist diese Geschichte der Unterdrückung ja auch präsent gemacht, wenn wir daran denken, dass die edrosexuelle Mainstream-Pornografie dominiert ist davon, dass die Frau unterdrückt wird. Also das ist, da mag sich irgendwas mit feministischer Pornografie in irgendwelchen Ecken tun, weiß ich nicht, aber der Mainstream wird sich nicht verändert haben zu dem, was in den 90er Jahren war. Eher sagen ja manche, sei es härter, schlimmer geworden. Und deshalb ist natürlich da ein Unterschied, wenn der Mann die Frau anspricht oder die Frau den Mann anspricht. Aber das Problem ist natürlich, diese Geschichte wird man nicht los, aber natürlich kann der 19-jährige nichts für eine patriarchale Geschichte, weil er nicht für diese verantwortlich ist, sondern er lebt damit. Und das macht das miteinander so schwer, obwohl wir an einem ganz verrückten Punkt hier angelangt sind, an einem tollen Punkt angelangt sind. Zum ersten Mal in der Menschheitsgeschichte, zumindest jetzt hier bezogen auf den Westen, können wir unsere Liebe frei wählen. Das heißt, wir haben nicht eine Kirche, wir haben nicht Eltern, wir haben nicht, weiß ich nicht was, den Staat dazwischen, der sagt, das geht aber nicht. Also das heißt, diese bürgerlichen Dramen, Ständeverlust und was weiß ich, die haben wir in dieser Weise nicht. Also eigentlich ist die Liebe befreiter denn je, aber es sind dann viele andere Dinge, die dazwischen kommen. Und man kann das nämlich sehr gut abgleichen, dieses ja wie Männer, Frauen, Frauen Männer ansprechen, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sich nicht heterosexuelle Konstellationen ansehen, also wie zum Beispiel Frauen Frauen ansprechen können oder Männer Männer ansprechen können. Da gibt es nicht die patriarchale Geschichte, die mitschwingt. Das heißt, da ist der der Bespruch ganz anders einzuordnen, der hat nicht was mit Unterdrückung unbedingt zu tun. Also der Satz, ich würde dich gerne heute Abend noch flachlegen, so das würde man das kann weder die Frau zu dem Mann noch der Mann zu der Frau sagen. Das ist aber in, also jetzt natürlich in einer entsprechenden Atmosphäre, sagen wir in einer Bar irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, LGBT-Bar oder so, wäre dieser Spruch vielleicht noch unangebracht in der jeweiligen Konstellation, vielleicht aber auch sehr forderneckig, was auch immer. Er würde jedenfalls nicht verknüpft werden mit der Geschichte von Patriarchat oder er will mich heute Abend noch unterdrücken und damit ist das eine andere Sphäre. Das Patriarchat und seine Geschichte wird man nicht so leicht los und deswegen muss natürlich eine besondere Sensibilität da sein. Aber ich glaube, dass wir uns inzwischen in eine Rolle hineinbegeben haben, wo wir diese direkte Blickkontakte, um die es ja, also die eigentlich wichtig wären, um zu flirten, um miteinander ins Gespräch zu kommen, dass diese immer mehr verpönt sind. Und dann ist das wirklich das gefunden Fressen für die Dating Plattform, weil die sagen, wir machen das hier für euch. Hier können wir das alles regeln. Und das ist eigentlich sehr schade, dass damit auch der öffentliche Raum so einen Liebes- und Erotikentzug leidet.
Genau. Also wir haben auch ein paar Lehlen. Vielleicht ist das sogar jetzt für die Bühne schon noch was. Aber wir werden auf jeden Fall ausführlich noch dieses Jahr darüber reden, hier im Podcast, wie in dieser Art von Sehnsuchtsindustrie, mit der wir es ja zu tun haben, sowohl die Männer als auch die Frauen, aber jeder auf sehr unterschiedliche Art und Weise komplett unter die Räder kommen. Frauen, weil ihnen gesagt wird, dein Traumprinzen gibt es, musst nur lang genug warten und suchen und wie auch immer, aber er wird dich irgendwann ansprechen und er wird 80.000 Euro im Jahr verdienen und er wird schon das Haus haben, von seinen Eltern vererbt und er werde zwei Urlauber im Jahr machen. Und dann wird Frauen, die das ganz offen vor Kameras so sagen, was wünscht du dir für einen, ja, also er sollte schon so und so und mich mit dem Auto abholen.
Das war ja in der Tinder-Swindler so zu hören.
Das habe ich nicht verfolgt.
Das waren ja Frauen, die auf einen Hochstapler eingefallen sind, der gesagt hat, ich bin euer Prinz aus dem Disney-Kur.
Also die haben da sehr leichte Einfallstore und dann werden diese jungen Frauen, also ich habe so ein paar Videos, auch wenn ich jetzt schon für das Familienbuch ein bisschen recherchiere und so, so ein paar Videos, die kann man durchaus hier mal spielen, denen dann einfach mal die Realität vor Augen geführt wird. Der durchschnittliche amerikanische Mann verdient 40.000 Dollar oder so 38.000. Und überhaupt nur fünf Prozent schaffen es jemals, mehr als 100.000 Dollar innerhalb eines Jahres zu verdienen und wahrscheinlich auch nur mal einem Jahr durch Zufall oder so. Und dann sitzen die so da und man sieht so richtig, wie ihr ganzes Lebensmodell plötzlich zerfällt. Weil sie einfach wissen, es gibt meinen Traumprinzen gar nicht. Obwohl mir das immer anders erzählt wurde. Die ganze Hollywoodgeschichte ist voll davon. Und eben auch diese ganze, die E-Mails, Newsletter begleitende Dating und hier nochmal das YouTube-Video und wie man jetzt seinen Traumprinzen findet und so weiter. Aber es gibt einfach gar keinen Traumprinzen. Und bei den Männern ist es eben genau dasselbe.
Was hat man denen?
Man steigert sich so rein in so Idealform. Also gerade was sexuelle Attraktivität angeht. Und man muss ihnen dann irgendwann sagen, ja, aber umso länger du wartest, umso mehr von den Frauen, denen du nachrennst, sind halt einfach vom Markt. Und nur weil mal eine reagiert hat auf den Chat, den du hattest, heißt das noch nicht, dass das schon für dich jetzt ein gemachtes Ding ist. Sondern die chatten halt mit ewig vielen. Also das ist diese totale Verengung. Irgendwie 80 Prozent der Frauen bei Tinder jagen zehn Prozent der Männer. Also über diese Profilkonstellation. Ein absolutes Dismatching. Riesengroßes Aufbauen von Erwartungsenttäuschung. Plus, dass du dann so absolute TikTok hast, die jetzt, die haben die Tage wieder so einen neuen Filter.
Ich wollte dir den vorstellen, genau diesen Teenage-Filter. Ich hab da schon Clips geschnitten für unsere Liveshow.
Und wirklich schrocken darüber sind wir gut, wie plötzlich aussehen, wie sehen die, in der es gefällt. Sie wissen genau, sie können diesem Filter nicht widerstehen. Und damit nähern sie natürlich jeder für sich. Dieses Bild, so sehen Frauen aus. Und jeder weiß, dass es eigentlich anders ist. Und es funktioniert aber trotzdem. Du kannst dem nicht widerstehen. Das ist dann das neue Ideal. Und alle jagen dem hinterher und niemand kommt mehr zu rande.
Aber auch hier, ich hab dann mal nach Videos gesucht. Und ja, es gibt mehr Videos von Frauen, schien mir, die diesen Filter nutzen und darauf reagieren. Aber auch viele Männer. Also Männer, die so 30, 35 sind, also die nicht mehr wie 17-Jährige aussehen. Und die sich dann diesen Filter drauflegen und dann plötzlich sagen, ach so, ja, so hab ich ausgesehen, so sehe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr aus.
Ja, wir haben gestern auch damit rumgespielt, haben so Halligalli von uns Videos und Bilder davon gemacht und die so ein bisschen rumgeschickt, weil das halt auch auch amüsant ist. Aber es gibt halt extrem viele Videos, die jetzt gerade so auftauchen, wo sich Frauen mit diesem Filter, wo sie ihn das erste Mal verwenden.
Also ich hab Männer und Frauen weinen sehen, die den Filter nutzen und die weinten dann darüber, dass sie so nicht mehr aussehen können, sondern dass das nur noch die Technik herstellt.
Und die sich auch gegenseitig warnen. Wenn ihr solche Fotos seht, seid euch bewusst, das ist alles nicht echt. Hier wird jetzt mit Leule und so. Und das ist, ja so langsam fragt man sich, wie überhaupt noch so Matching funktioniert. Gestern habe ich viele Hinweise bekommen auf so einen Text aus Japan, wo ein Provinzgouverneur aufgerufen hat, die Romantic Ability zu erforschen. Sind die jungen Leute überhaupt noch in der Lage, Beziehungen einzugehen? Oder haben wir es hier mit strukturellen, kognitiven Problemen zu tun, dass wir gar nicht mehr darauf hoffen müssen, über Sozial- und Familienpolitik irgendwas zu erreichen?
Und was heißt jetzt Jung? Denn wir haben ja auch bei den über 40, 50, 60-Jährigen einen Single-Zuwachs, der große oder beziehungsweise viele Trennungen, die stattfinden dann und viel Gesuche. Es ist ja auch inzwischen so, dass die Älteren alle diese Plattformen frequentieren. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass Tinder irgendwie so abgesperrt ist.
Tinder geht so für die Millennials. Die Jüngeren nutzen jetzt Hinge und sowas. Bumble, dadurch, dass das nicht aus dieser match.com, wir machen alle Apps und so, nochmal so ein eigenes Indie-Produkt. Also es ist durch die Bargains betrifft alle Altersgruppen. Es sind auch die 75-jährigen Senioren, die zu drei Vierteln alleine leben und so. Wir haben es jedenfalls mit einem extrem großen Problem zu tun, dass dieses persönliche Matching einfach nicht mal stattfindet. Und dass wir da, wo noch die letzten Räume irgendwie...
Also wir brauchen da, um das jetzt mal abzuschließen, weil jetzt haben wir ja so viele angerissen.
Wir greifen das noch groß auf.
Und wir haben das, wir hoffen, wir haben jetzt nicht uns im Kopf vom Kragen gerät. Aber was uns eigentlich, und das ist aber so ein Imperativ, der mal so gesagt werden kann, aber viel mehr dann noch nicht, eigentlich müsste man irgendwie versuchen, aufgrund der gesellschaftlichen Errungenschaften, die wir haben, eine gewisse Gelassenheit reinzubekommen, zum eigenen Körper, zur Attraktivität des eigenen Körpers, aber zur Attraktivität auch die ausstrahlt auf andere. Und das Gespräch eigentlich nicht scheuen, es kommt auf die Sekunde an, also den Moment dann auch nutzen und nicht sagen, ah ja, interessant, ganz attraktiv, ich gucke mal eine Stunde auf meiner Datingplattform nach, ob ich die Person nochmal wiederfinden kann dort, sondern vielleicht das eher dann direkt machen. Das wäre ja eigentlich das nur, was zu empfehlen ist. Und das ist natürlich dann problematisch, wenn diese Räume verschwinden und wenn das dann wirklich über rechtliche Schritte geht in Unternehmen, dass das alles nicht mehr möglich ist. Denn natürlich lernen sich ganz viele Leute da kennen. Wo soll man sich auch sonst kennenlernen, wenn man ohnehin schon 40 Stunden arbeitet?
Das ist die Frage.
Gut, man kann dann irgendwo hin feiern gehen oder so. Aber man erlebt ja vielleicht doch auch eher so im Alltäglichen das, was man an einer Person schätzt und nicht ausgerechnet auf einer Tanzfläche.
Ja, also es gibt diese Gegenbewegung, die so ein bisschen Aufklärung versucht, wie zum Beispiel mit der totalen Entzauberung des Überhalts über den Kopf verlieben, dieses magischen ersten Treffen. Eigentlich wächst man so in so eine Liebe rein und lernt irgendwelche Vorzüge kennen nach dem, ach so, ja, habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Also Johanna Degen sagt, da gibt es einen Artebeitrag, den kann man bei YouTube sehen, der ist zwei Monate alt. Sie sagt es doch, es gibt die Liebe auf den ersten Blick und das sind Millisekunden. Die Frage ist nur, wird man über diesen Moment und diese Glücksausschüttung und dieses Erkanntwerden einander erkennen, hinaus es schaffen eine Beziehung zu kreieren?
Ja, es gibt sehr gute, sagen wir mal, Dating-Coaches auf YouTube. Wir können durchaus mal ein paar besprechen. Es sind nicht alle schlecht und es gibt einige, die dann doch so Wert darauf legen. Ja, also klar, es gibt diese allererste Art Aktivität. Klar, Werbebilder, man sucht halt, man macht ja dann diese AB-Tests und so und dann wird halt das Model ausgewählt, dass diesen Sekundenbruchteil dann auch entsprechend nutzt. Aber das, was vielversprechende Liebe dann ausmacht, ist doch, dass man, also sagen dann diese Leute, die sich so ein bisschen noch diese Forschung, es gibt ja erstaunlicherweise sehr gute wissenschaftliche Forschung. Und dann Dean Hilscher, dieses Buch Liebe, Neue Denken, ist ja voller Wissenschaft, das ist ja nicht so, das ist alles nur so Pi mal Daumen und private Erfahrungen und so. Aber wenn man so soziale Beziehungen gestaltet, und dann muss es eben nicht die Liebesbeziehung sein, aber man stellt dann so fest, eigentlich treffen wir uns aus den und den Gründen, aber dann ist ja immer noch das dabei. Also wenn das so zweigleisig oder dreigleisig fährt, wenn da so Verschachtelungen, die brauchen aber Zeit entdeckt zu werden. Manchmal hat es auch damit zu tun, dass jemand eine besondere Attraktivität vor anderen plötzlich, also dass man jemand mag, wie sich jemand verhält, anderen gegenüber, man selbst ist dann nur Zuschauer in dem Moment und ist aber froh, dass man dann mit der Person nach Hause geht, auch wenn man in der Situation selbst gar nicht einen großen Anteil oder so, man bleibt dann der Zuschauer oder so. Also lauter solche Sachen. Und am Ende fällt man sehr häufig auf diese alten griechischen Philosophien zu drück und so, dass man halt mehrere Götter und auch mehrere Dimensionen der Liebe und so weiter und dieses europäische Modell in den Roman steht, die eine Liebe und die beginnt und dann endet sie leider tragisch und dann beginnt halt die nächste. Also diese serielle, also ich empfehle sehr Isda Perel und die machen da sehr inspirative Videos in ihrem Falle und immer Eva Ilu's empfohlen. Wir haben sie ja vorhin schon noch mal nicht zum Krieg, sondern dann zum eigentlichen Krieg, Liebe und so was, sich das mal anzuschauen. Aber wir kommen darauf zurück. Zurück zum Dating.
Ein bisschen noch was zur parasozialen Beziehung.
Wenn ich zu Hause sitze und nur Instagram scrolle und die Funktion ist, ich soll auch lange meinen Augapfel drauf ruhen lassen oder einen Kaufbutton anklicken oder das nächste Profil liken oder beim Online Dating, dass ich Matches sammle, bis ich mich nicht mehr schlecht fühle, dann hat das quasi keine positiven Spillover Effekte. Ich habe dann in der Regel keine tollen neuen Freunde gefunden, keine Erinnerungen geschaffen.
Also die Vereinsamung nimmt zu, während man versucht, sein Selbstwertgefühl zu steigern. Und sie ist anfangs immer an diese ganzen technischen Errungenschaften mit einem großen Optimismus herangegangen. Und inzwischen klingt sie aber so.
Keine Geschichte von einer sehr guten Kollegin, die mir das erzählt hat. Ein ganz süßes Mädchen sitzt bei ihr in der Therapie und sagt, sie traut sich niemandem zu küssen, sie fühlt sich viel zu hässlich. Sie guckt sich auf Instagram alle an, die sind so schön. Und sie hat deswegen gar keine Sexualität und die sah ganz süß aus, ganz normal. Und das sind so Dinge, da werde ich immer melancholischer, muss ich sagen. Und das hatte ich früher nicht. Früher dachte ich, ja, ja, wir können eine gesunde Handynutzung haben. Alles wird gut, da müssen wir nicht so kulturpessimistisch sein.
Ja, inzwischen aber sieht sie da anders dazu und sie beschreibt mal, wie das Smartphone den Alltag durchdringt.
Wenn wir jemanden fragen, wie stehst du auf morgens, dann sagen die, ja, nee, mein Handywecker klingelt und dann gehe ich duschen und dann gehe ich zur Arbeit. Und dann sage ich, ja, aber was passiert dazwischen? Also der Handywecker klingelt, wo ist denn das Handy? Unterm Kopfkissen. Okay. Und da war es dann, drückst du dann auf den Knopf an der Seite oder wie machst du den aus? Nee, ich mache das kurz auf den Screen. Und dann gehe ich duschen. Ja, okay, aber du machst also nur den Wecker aus. Nee, ich gucke auch kurz Arbeits-E-Mails und dann scroll ich noch bei Insta runter und dann sage ich aha, okay, wie lange? 20 Minuten, das stelle ich mir schon so ein. Da sage ich okay und dann frage ich auch, wie geht es Ihnen dabei? Ist das ein schöner Start in den Tag? Wie ist es so? Ja, eigentlich blöd und langweilig. Ich sage dann auch, ist das spannend dann und bist du dann excited? Nee, bin nicht gespannt und excited. Ich fühle eigentlich, das war Quatsch. Was macht ihre Frau dabei? TikTok scrollen.
Ja, also ich habe es in der Alten Republik ja beschrieben, dieses große, völlig übersehene historische Problem, dass wir mit der Armut der Jugend ab 2008 durch Immobilienkrise und der ganze Kram niemand kann sich mehr irgendwas leisten. Gleichzeitig diese angebliche Selbstermächtigung. Steve Jobs stellt das iPhone vor und wir können ja alle total nah dran teilnehmen am parlamentarischen Betrieb und Kevin Kühnert oder die ganzen CDU-Horten kommen ja auch in meinen Clubhouse-Meeting und so. Dass man sich so nahe wähnt, während man gleichzeitig im Grunde extreme Distanz zur Welt aufbaut. Aber vorgegaukelt dadurch, dass man ja selber den Daumen benutzt, um durchzuscrollen, denkt man, man ist selber der Aktive. Aber nein, das wird natürlich mit einem gespielt. Also TikTok entscheidet, was man sieht und nicht man selber, nur weil man den Daumen benutzt. Und dieses Zurückgeworfen sein auf ein Selbst und dann, wie sie ja eben sagt, auf diese jämmerliches Selbst. Also diese Verjämmerlichung des Selbstbildes, weil man ja immer nur die anderen sieht und so auch coole Profile und selber sieht man so blöd aus. Man sieht die ganze Zeit TikTok-Filterbilder und dann steht man wirklich auf nach 20 Minuten, guckt den Spiegel und das ist natürlich ein Drama. So und das betrifft aber alle Ebenen. Also es ist nicht nur das TikTok und die Bilder dort, sondern alles grundsätzlich. Man ist sich so in einer Weltlage ausgeliefert, auch bei Putin kann man auch nichts mehr machen, es geht so durch. Was ist heute Nacht in der Ukraine passiert? Man kriegt noch ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil man selber nicht die Möglichkeit hatte, jetzt zum Held zu werden. Es ist leider keine Bombe aufs Haus gefallen, man konnte nicht heroisch rausrennen und noch jemanden mit retten und so. Und überall wird man immer wieder auf das jämmerliche selbst zurückgeworfen. Insbesondere hier bei diesem, eigentlich suche ich ja einen Partner, eine Partnerin und die ganze Zeit arbeite ich aber nur an meinem Profil. Und frage mich, kann ich damit jetzt irgendwo auftreten? Nee, noch nicht, ich muss noch und so. Man ist sich gar nicht mehr selbst genug. Und das ist echt ein großes Drama.
Auch als Paar ist man sich dann nicht mehr selbst genug.
Auch zum Beispiel in der Sexualität spielt es eine Rolle. Wir schlafen miteinander, dann rollen sich beide auf die Seite und machen TikTok an. Dann gibt es keine zweite Runde, keinen in die Augen gucken, was Serotonin antreiben würde.
Also fällt alles weg. Man hat die Beschäftigung mit den Gadgets, weiter sagt sie noch.
Ja und da drängt sich das Parasoziale mitten in unser Wohlbefinden, in die Familien, in die Bindung rein. Wir binden uns eben an das, was wir fokussieren. Und wir fokussieren irgendwelche Influencer, denen wir nur an der Masse, der Anzahl was bedeuten.
Also es ist natürlich fürs Gehirn extrem entspannt, Menschen bei irgendwas zuzusehen und die ganze Zeit die Gewissheit zu haben. Ich kann die Situation durch mein eigenes Verhalten gerade nicht boykottieren oder stören oder sonst irgendwie. Ich muss hier nicht taktvoll sein oder sonst irgendwas. Lisa und Lena spielen mir tolle Familie und tolle Freundschaften vor. An mir scheitert es nicht. Ich bin ja nur Zuschauer. Und gleichzeitig verwechselt man das aber gerade mit Untermenschen sein. Weil man ist ja Untermenschen, aber nicht so richtig. Also im Gehirn, nicht im Bewusstsein, aber im Gehirn für unsere eigene Vitalität ist, Lisa und Lena zu gucken, genau wie eine weiße Wand Tapete angucken.
Ja, und sie beendet das dann auch eigentlich mit so einer Frage.
Warum macht man das? Ich frage mich oft, warum tun wir, was uns nicht gut tut? Weil ich habe unter den vielen Menschen, mit denen ich rede und den Prozessen, die ich beobachte, noch niemanden gefunden, der gesagt hat, das finde ich super und ich will es so weitermachen.
Und das ist ja in der Tat so. Man hat noch niemand getroffen, der sagte, ich muss unbedingt mal eine Stunde länger bei Instagram verbringen.
Ich brauche meinen TikTok immer im Leben, dann ist es besser.
Man hat wirklich noch nie getroffen und man kann es ja für sich selbst auch immer wieder feststellen, dass sich davon losmachen eigentlich immer das Schönste ist.
Genau. Die Qualitätsminuten, sagt der Markowitz, der ja angefangen hat, eine App zu schreiben, um sich selbst das zu kontrollieren, dann hat er sich so ein Download angeboten und aus dieser Erkenntnis, wie die Leute ihr Handy nutzen, dieses Buch, dessen Titel mir jetzt nicht einfällt, aber die Qualitätsminute ist ab der 15. ohne Smartphone. Wenn man alle 15 Minuten, spätestens alle 15 Minuten zum Smartphone greift, hat man gar keine Qualitätsminute in seinem Leben. Ich würde das noch mal einschränken mit, ich bin unterwegs und suche wirklich nur am Fahrplan raus, wann meine Bahn fährt und gucke, ob ich jetzt pünktlich bin. Aber sobald man, und die Apps kennen wir alle, auch nur eine Sekunde aufmacht, ist das Gehirn wieder im anderen Modus und nicht mehr in der Situation. Geht ja so weit, ich habe damals auch drüber geschrieben, du hast eine Sparkassenfiliale und da liegen einfach bewusstlose Menschen drin. Und du gehst mit dem Smartphone in der Hand da rein, hebst dein Geld ab, gehst wieder raus, tust so, als hättest du nichts gesehen. Und dann wirst du drauf angesprochen und sagst, ja, hab ich nicht gesehen, redest dich so raus und so. Aber man konnte nachweisen, wenn die Menschen sich in ihrer parasozialen Situation gefangen nehmen lassen, sind sie umso weniger in der eigentlichen Situation, in der sie sind.
Das ist ja nochmal ein ganz guter Bezug zum Fitnessstudio zum Beispiel, wo das dann stattfindet oder auch, wo es ja auch jetzt nicht verpönt ist in dem Sinne, aber wo es immer weniger möglich ist, ist ja der Blickkontakt in einem Restaurant irgendwo, weil dort auch immer sofort gleich auf das Smartphone geguckt wird oder auf freier Wildbahn, wenn irgendwo Leute stehen am Bahnsteig oder was. Es ist also dieser Blickkontakt, der ja auch nicht immer nur auf Flirt oder was hinauslaufen soll, sondern es könnte ja auch einfach mal ein Gespräch sein über irgendetwas. Das ist ja etwas, was auch ganz verrückt ist oder dass, wenn ich ja kein Smartphone habe, Leute nach dem Weg fragen. Meistens, ja, gucken sie mal bei Google nach und ich denke dann, ja, hätte ich vielleicht auch drauf kommen können, dann sage ich, na ja, ich habe kein Smartphone. Aber dass man auch eigentlich schon so verblüfft ist, dass man überhaupt noch mal so angesprochen wird wegen irgendetwas.
Ja, diese Degen, das ist ja hier dieser 21 Podcast oder so, oder Udi? Und da hatten die kürzlich auch über Ghosting gesprochen. Ghosting, die sich einfach aus der Affäre ziehen, indem man gar nicht mehr reagiert. Und da würde ich ganz scharf zwischen zwei Arten von Ghosting unterscheiden. Zum einen findet einfach nicht mehr statt, der andere fragt aber auch nicht nach oder der andere fragt noch nach und bekommt keine Antwort mehr. Weil ich finde dieses, das war jetzt so meine Erfahrung aus Tinder, mittlerweile habe ich ja alles wieder gelöscht und so. Aber ein Tinder Date, jemanden zu treffen, den man vorher bei Tinder angeschrieben hatte, ist ganz schwer zu organisieren unter dieser Maßgabe. Einfach nur treffen. Das läuft sofort unter diesem, ja sind wir jetzt einander was fürs Leben oder nicht so? Weißte? Du hast einfach dieses, man geht einfach mal hin und ist halt zufällig da und der andere auch. Und dann guckt man einfach mal. Und dass das Ghosting so verpönt ist, finde ich nicht gut. Denn man sollte sich einfach, also es sollte unter dieser Maxime laufen.
Genau, aber Ghosting meint glaube ich jetzt eher, dass man schon eine Art Beziehung oder zumindest eine Regelmäßigkeit etabliert hat. Ja. Und dann meldet, also das wäre jetzt ein bisschen eigenartig, wenn man eine Person trifft, sich wieder mit ihr trifft und dann das fast etabliert und dann plötzlich gefragt wird, und sollen wir uns morgen sehen und man einfach keine Antwort mehr erhält.
Genau.
Dann ist es ja ganz klar, dass man ist bei der anderen Person mit einer heftigen Kommunikationsstörung oder was auch immer zu tun hat. Denn sonst könnte man ja mitteilen, also ja, das war jetzt ganz schön, aber weißt du, ich habe es mir anders überlegt.
Also die Ghosting-Definition beginnt in dieser Podcast-Ausgabe, die ich jetzt im Ohr habe, da wo man sagt, man wechselt von Tinder zu einem anderen Chatprogramm. Also man chattet nicht mehr nur bei Tinder, sondern man hat schon Nummern ausgetauscht und chattet bei WhatsApp oder so. Dann darf man nicht mehr ge-ghostet werden, ab dann ist jeder rechenschaftspflichtig, auch wenn er nicht mehr kommunizieren will. Da würde ich sagen, nee, es sollte immer unter der Prämisse laufen, dass man auch einfach aufhören darf, ohne verbrannte Erde zu hinterlassen, ohne dass der andere denkt, oh, jetzt fühle ich mich aber schlecht und der andere ist schuld. Sondern nee, das Ghost-Ding selbst, sagt dann auch der eine Experte, der immer noch zugeschaltet wird, Ghosten selbst ist ein kommunikativer Akt. Der andere reagiert einfach nicht mehr. Er möchte nicht mehr. Man muss es deswegen nicht so mega auf sich beziehen oder so. Man wird halt einfach, ja, es ist, es war nichts und es geht halt auseinander. Also das, und da finde ich, ist das zu, die Leute sind, also man nutzt gar nicht die Dating-Plattformen als Gelegenheit, sich zu sehen und sich wahrzunehmen, sondern es ist immer schon gleich Kommunikation. Und wenn die aufhört, ist das bitte zu erklären. Und sei es, dass eine Frau mit zehn verschiedenen Männern gleichzeitig chattet und dann eben fünf aussatiert, aber denen das ja nicht erklärt oder so.
Was man ja jetzt in der Bar auch machen würde, also man spricht, man geht so rum und dann sagt ja ganz oft, ich komme gleich nochmal wieder und komme dann doch nicht wieder, aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Ja, man nimmt so einen Stehempfang mit den anderen Leuten rum und so.
Genau, also man muss es vielleicht dann doch eher als Stehempfang sich vorstellen, wo man so herumplaniert und dann, ergeben sich Gespräche oder auch nicht. Ich würde sagen, das ist ein gutes Schlusswort. Wir freuen uns dann alle, die noch Karten ergattern konnten, zu sehen bei unserer Live-Show.
Das ist am 21.
Liebe Mädels, liebe Jungs, ihr dürft natürlich anziehen, was ihr wollt. Wir haben kein Dresscode und ihr dürft uns ansprechen. Ihr dürft einander ansprechen, was genauso wichtig ist oder wichtiger noch ist, damit es ein soziales Erlebnis wird.
Das ist der Punkt. Jetzt haben wir allen gesagt, sie sollen sich einander ansprechen. Jetzt haben wir viele, die da nebeneinander sitzen und überlegen, soll ich jetzt oder nicht. Das ist nämlich superwitzig, weil einige dann doch zu uns kommen und das Gespräch so eröffnen wollen unter, ich will nicht über das Wetter reden, sondern seid ihr denn aufgeregt und dann ist eigentlich immer die naheliegend Antwort nicht so aufgeregt, wie die Hörer, die hier sind. Also mir scheint das Publikum bei uns immer sehr viel nervöser zu sein. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das Plädoyer aussehen soll.
Also es gibt keinen Grund. Wir sind ganz gelassen, locker gehen wir da rein, aber man kann natürlich nicht Lockerheit empfehlen. Wir werden dann diese Live-Show, die wird dann ein Tag später auch zu hören sein. Für alle, die den Salon abonnieren, es lohnt sich doppelt, weil wir natürlich auch noch in diesem Monat, also im März, unseren regulären Salon aufnehmen. Wie schon angekündigt, werden wir da über den Habermas-Essay, das Alexander-Kluge-Interview und das Buch von Christoph Heusgen sprechen, Führung und Verantwortung. Also wie wird Deutschlands Rolle künftig in der Welt aussehen? Was ich schon verraten kann, ich möchte noch sprechen über ein Buch von Richard Münch, die Herrschaft der Inzidenzen und Evidenzen regieren in den Fallstrecken des Cientismus. Wir hatten ja in der letzten Folge schon eine gewisse Kritik an MyLab und hier haben wir einen Gesellschaftstheoretiker, der zeigt, warum das vielleicht nicht so gut ist, wenn man einfach nur so sagt, die Politik soll mal auf die Wissenschaft hören. Wir glaube ich, haben es da mit einem interessanten Beitrag zu dieser Debatte zu tun, die wir jetzt nicht bei Corona zu Ende ist vergessen sollten, sondern die muss jetzt eigentlich erstmal gründlich geführt werden. Und dann werde ich, das kann ich auch schon ankündigen, einen ganz eigenartigen Text vorstellen. Ich sage mal so viel, Theater in leichter Sprache. Ich werde zornig werden, das kann ich wohl schon mal sagen.
Sehr gut. Hast du auch schon was an Blagern? Also wir haben jetzt schon viele Festlegungen zum Thema Krieg. Klug, Habermas, Heusgen. Ich werde mal noch schauen, vielleicht verlagere ich Teile des Ernährungsdiskurses, da es wirklich sehr gute Texte gab. Also es gab Anfang Februar eine Spiegel-Titel-Story zum Thema, die mir sehr gut gefallen hat. Außerdem hat Die Neue Zürcher die größte Indoor-Farm in Dubai besucht der Welt. Von der ich, wenn ich das nur so lese, der Text kommt ganz sachlich daher und ist auch ein bisschen flapsig geschrieben, denke, das ist echt eine Revolution. Also das ist vielleicht nicht nur was für Dubai, sondern es macht überall Sinn, auch nur mit 5 Prozent des Wassers, den man in der konventionellen Vergleichsweise brauchen würde, mal ordentlich Erträge abwerfen zu lassen und so. Aber es ist ein ganz überraschend anderer, irrer Umgang mit der Pflanze an sich, da man sie halt komplett unter Kontrolle hat, sowohl was Licht, Nahrungs- und auch Luft und alles angeht. Also ist erstaunliches Zeug. Vielleicht verlagere ich Teile in den Salon, sodass wir dann im Anschluss daran Ende März mal diese Bundestagsdebatte zum Thema Ernährung, das ist echter Halligalli. Oder vielleicht wäre es auch was für die Bühne. Na mal sehen, ich baue es also alles noch zusammen. Lasst euch überraschen.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns im Salon und einen schönen Monat.